bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le Figaro
light pour tous ceux qui nous rejoignent
nous sommes ensemble tout au long de
l'après-midi pour vous faire vivre cette
neuvième journée de mobilisation contre
la réforme des retraites une journée de
mobilisation au cours de laquelle
évidemment les syndicats espèrent
capitaliser sur la colère engendrée par
le recours à l'article 49-3 la semaine
dernière à l'Assemblée nationale ici les
manifestants vont vont traverser un
parcours bien connu puisque c'est
celui-là même qui avait été emprunté
dans le sens inverse le 7 mars dernier
départ donc de la place de la Bastille
où je me trouve avec Julien Leclerc dans
le 11e arrondissement de Paris direction
la place de l'Opéra qui elle se trouve
dans le 9e arrondissement le cortège
syndical qui va donc emprunter dans un
premier temps le boulevard De
Beaumarchais pour rejoindre la place de
la République également le boulevard du
Temple ensuite les manifestants qui vont
emprunter le boulevard Saint-Martin afin
de passer devant la porte Saint-Denis
devant bonne nouvelle et de bifurquer
sur le boulevard des Italiens pour
arriver ensuite sur cette place de
l'Opéra l'enjeu cet après-midi c'est
évidemment l'ampleur de la mobilisation
les syndicats l'affirmes il va y avoir
du monde beaucoup de monde dans les rues
de la capitale aujourd'hui pour mémoire
le pic de la mobilisation avait été
enregistré le 11 février dernier avec
93000 manifestants un chiffre qui n'a
jamais été atteint depuis aujourd'hui 40
000 à 70 000 personnes seraient
attendues de sources policières et face
au risque de débordement évidemment gros
dispositif de sécurité cet après-midi
puisque ce sont pas moins de 5000
policiers et gendarmes qui sont déployés
un petit peu partout dans les rues de la
capitale
bonjour à tous merci beaucoup Timothée
d'Hélène de nous avoir introduit au cœur
de la manifestation au coeur de cette 9e
journée de mobilisation 9e journée de
mobilisation à Paris et également dans
les grandes villes de France on va faire
le point sur ces différentes
manifestations puisque il y en a
plusieurs centaines qui sont prévus
elles sont également en augmentation et
nous allons donc vous les faire vivre et
vous donner un petit peu le pouls de
cette de cette mobilisation à travers le
pays tout au long de l'après-midi à
partir de maintenant ici à Paris tout
près du Figaro puisque c'est là que
passera cette manifestation et puis et
puis et puis également à l'intérieur des
cortèges et dans les différentes villes
grâce notamment aux informations que
nous donnera en milieu d'après-midi le
figu data qui est le le service qui
cartographie c'est mobilisation mais qui
cartographie également les blocages
qu'il y a également on fera un point sur
toutes ces questions là tout au long de
l'après-midi également avec les
journalistes spécialistes du Figaro à
15h à Alexis viendra également nous
donner son analyse et son regard sur
cette mobilisation et
ce soir aux alentours de 18h pas
d'émission au point de vue ce soir on
reste en émission spéciale mais nous
serons avec les
responsables de l'Institut backbone qui
vient de réaliser un sondage avec
odoxa sur la façon dont a été reçu
l'interview du président de la
République hier et sondage que vous
pouvez déjà consulter sur le site du
Figaro et puis également le syndicalisme
l'ancien syndicaliste Joseph touvenel
qui est le directeur cteur du capital
social un nouveau magazine consacré à
l'actualité sociale et le syndicaliste
policier Mathieu Valley on va retourner
d'abord je vous le propose place de la
près de la place de la Bastille
retrouver Vincent roseron
Vincent quelle est vous êtes arrivés il
y a quelques quelques minutes déjà
quelle est l'ambiance sur place
et bien l'ambiance est bonne enfance
comme on avait dit en début de cortège
comme le poncif comme on le dit souvent
pour l'instant une ambiance tout à
tranquille Deschamps alors vous voyez
peut-être pas sur ces images je vais
essayer de vous montrer mais tout au
fond là-bas c'est la place de la
Bastille j'ai pris un peu d'avance en
fait sur le cortège le cortège inter
syndical est un peu plus loin et là en
fait je me trouve au niveau des
politiques les politiques qui ont tenu
un point presse les membres de la nups
qui ont tenu un point presse il y a à
peu près 20 minutes qui reste déterminé
on a eu Jérôme Guedj alerté Emmanuel
Macron sur le chaos qu'il provoquait
marine Tondelier qui a réagi bien
évidemment la chef des Verts au
Parlement qui a qui a qui a réagi en
disant que
l'interview de Macron d'hier était une
provocation de plus et comme il disait
il reste déterminé pour continuer leur
lutte contre la réforme même si celle-ci
a été votée et je après suivre tout au
long de cette journée avec des
interviews de manifestants et d'hommes
politiques merci beaucoup et bien sûr
dès que il y aura dès qu'on vous verra
avec
une personnalité ou bien des
manifestants on vous donnera la parole
je vous rappelle donc cette itinéraire
il part de donc de la place de la
Bastille alors là je pense pas qu'on
soit place de la vessie on est dans un
autre dans un autre endroit c'est encore
une facétie des agences de presse qui
nous fournissent ces images qui parfois
changent de canal sans nous prévenir ne
vous étonnez pas donc là on n'était pas
à Paris on était ailleurs dans le Monde
à Paris place de la Bastille direction
place de l'Opéra c'est le nouveau trajet
de ce cortège
Timothée Timothée délayme juste je
voulais vous poser la question
est-ce que vous disiez en tous les cas
mais est-ce que vous pouvez bien me le
confirmer qu'il y a pas mal de forces de
l'ordre qui sont mobilisées aujourd'hui
notez et dans la foule on lui reposera
la question tout à l'heure et on posera
la question également à Christophe
Cornavin
alors effectivement apparemment il y a
pas trop de retour dans l'oreille mais
ça va ça va venir ça ce sont les aléas
du direct et peut-être que vous en aurez
d'autres pendant toute l'après-midi
effectivement on posera la question tout
à l'heure à Christophe Cornavin du
service société du Figaro quelle est la
doctrine en termes de maintien de
l'ordre qu'est-ce que les forces de
l'ordre attendent aujourd'hui on sait
qu'elles sont sur le pied de guerre
elles sont sur le sur le qui-vive on va
retourner voir sans doute Vincent
roserand qui est avec le député France
insoumise de Seine-Saint-Denis Alexis
Corbière est-ce que Vincent m'entend et
apparemment Alexis Corbière est avec
nous Vincent vous avez la parole et
c'est tout
oui bonjour Vincent je suis
effectivement avec Alexis Corbière
d'éviter de la France insoumise Alexis
Corbière c'était très important pour
vous d'être ici pour une nouvelle
manifestation malgré ce qui s'est passé
à l'Assemblée en raison de ce qui s'est
passé à l'Assemblée le grand l'étape
nouvelle qu'on a franchi je crois c'est
que ce mail à la colère sociale
désormais la colère démocratique la
crise sociale se met la crise
démocratique l'utilisation du 49.3 jeudi
dernier à rebooster la mobilisation
beaucoup de gens qui étaient contre
cette réforme des retraites ont été
indignés choqués par cette utilisation
abusive d'un article qui piétine le
Parlement et donc désormais c'est la
question même démocratique les gens dis
pourquoi autant de pouvoir se concentre
sur un homme le président de la
République il n'est pas légitime pour
faire ça et les gens commencent à
réfléchir déjà ce étudier la
Constitution c'est passionnant de
manière populaire les gens parlent du
49-3 de cet article 47 qui avait limité
les débats donc on est dans à ce moment
là c'est intéressant parce que dans
l'histoire de France quand la crise
sociale se mêle à la crise démocratique
qui est une autre manière de dire aussi
la crise nationale c'est-à-dire
qu'est-ce qui nous fonde comme peuple
quels sont les règles communes quelles
sont nos institutions on est en général
dans des moments de grande crise
politique qui peuvent amener des grandes
changements alors faut être là
aujourd'hui évidemment faudra être là
peut-être pour la suite parce qu'on a
bien compris que le Président de la
République en vertu de la sa
communication d'hier est plutôt sur une
ligne de refaire des 40 pro 49 3
verbales quoi j'ai raison contre tout le
monde mais la puissance d'un peuple
mobilisé peut changer les choses vous
vous pensez que l'intervention
d'Emmanuel Macron hier elle a plutôt
galvanisé les foules écoutez je suis pas
un grand communicant et je suis pas
conseillé de Monsieur Macron mais si
vous voulez inviter plus de gens à venir
manifester il a réussi son coup sinon
quel est l'intérêt de cette
communication qui par sa nature même un
côté arrogant c'était en gros je vous
réexplique ce que depuis des mois on a
entendu alors certes c'est un grand
communicant mais enfin il devrait avoir
un peu de modestie ce qui répète on l'a
entendu de la part de Monsieur du somme
madame borne et ça qu'on va pas et c'est
tellement peu à l'écoute de ce que le
pays attend que de fait il remobilise
contre lui c'est sa personne c'est
d'ailleurs assez intéressant et
inquiétant pour lui c'est qu'il y a plus
de bornes il y a plus du stop il y a
plus rien c'est directement le président
contre le peuple il y a plus de fusible
c'est cette manifestation justement on a
l'impression que ça a dépassé la réforme
des retraites c'est plus la réforme des
retraites beaucoup de gens beaucoup de
gens sont là contre ma fête finalement
Emmanuel Macron oui c'est ce que je vais
vous dire tout à l'heure c'est la crise
sociale qui se met à la crise
démocratique c'est les deux questions
c'est plus seulement la question des
retraites même si c'est fondamentalement
la question des retraites mais c'est
aussi la crise démocratique le centre il
faut pour que toute société fonctionne
il faut qu'il y a un consentement à
l'autorité faut que vous disiez bon même
si je suis pas d'accord le pouvoir
prendre des décisions il y a une forme
de légitimité mais avec Macron c'est
plus le cas les gens n'acceptent pas ont
bien compris qu'il a été élu dans un
rejet de Madame Le Pen qui n'a pas été
lu sur ce programme qu'il ne convainc
pas qu'une un immense majorité contre
lui et la méthode du 49-3 donne un côté
mauvais joueur c'est-à-dire qu'il y a de
quelqu'un qui pète il même la
représentation nationale qui certes est
une photographie déformée de la réalité
mais qui quand même est au diapason de
se payer en colère donc on est vraiment
dans quelque chose qui est assez tendu
il faut retirer le texte s'il veut pas
le faire on verra il y a d'autres c'est
ça la question c'est que aujourd'hui
finalement la réforme des retraites
c'était pas encore tout à fait fini mais
ça ça semble pas loin
aujourd'hui une grande manifestation ce
sera quoi le calendrier pour plus tard
ce sera quoi pardon le calendrier pour
plus tard alors moi je suis très attaché
à l'intersyndical qui donne le
calendrier des mobilisations et
vis-à-vis duquel on est en soutien après
d'un point de vue déjà la loi n'est pas
promulguée on va voir ce que nous dit le
Conseil constitutionnel on a déposé des
recours déjà on peut avoir des surprises
moi je pense j'ai la petite idée bon
c'est un pronostic que le Conseil
constitutionnel peut retoquer nos textes
ou une partie sera intéressant à voir
parce que beaucoup de choses de ont été
utilisés dans la procédure parlementaire
qui sont assez brutalisantes ensuite on
peut avoir aussi on a déposé la demande
de référendum d'initiative partagé on va
voir ce qu'on nous dit le Conseil
constitue si c'est retenu le président
lui-même convoquer un référendum tu le
souverain c'est le peuple il pourrait
être convoqué et puis il y a les
mobilisations moi j'en ai vu un des
premiers ministres extrêmement droit
dans leur bottes paraît-il et puis qui
sont revenus en tong c'est à dire que
quand le peuple se mobilise au bout d'un
moment même les plus arrogants sont
obligés de l'entendre donc on est dans
ce moment on peut un certain mais ils
ont pas gagné ça c'est clair ce
référendum initiative populaire ça
demande beaucoup de signatures est-ce
que vous y croyez arriver à mobiliser
autant de gens sur cela alors ça
s'appelle référendum initiative partagée
mais mais mais mais effectivement vous
avez raison à travers ce mot c'est que
ce serait bien si c'était populaire mais
le chemin est en chemin de croix
quasiment d'ordre institutionnels il
faut que le Conseil constitutionnel
valide notre demande et puis une fois
qu'il serait validé s'enclenche après 9
mois durant lesquels il faut faire une
récolte de 10% du corps électoral
c'est-à-dire 4,8 millions d'électeurs il
y a 48 millions d'électeurs inscrits
donc c'est extrêmement long et une fois
qu'on aurait récolté toutes ces
signatures alors le président peut c'est
pas doit convoquer un référendum ou
éventuellement à nouveau une discussion
parlementaire bon tout ça c'est
extrêmement incertain mais ça peut
produire aussi une dynamique populaire
qui exige par les 4,8 millions
d'électeurs qui le demanderait à ce
qu'il y a une consultation donc c'est
une des voies possibles une écorde que
nous avons à nos arts même si je le
répète le moteur TU en toute chose ce
sont ces mobilisations ces salariés en
grève c'est manifestations puissantes
c'est ça qui donne le la et qui peut
amener à ce que une fois de plus Macron
retire son texte très bien merci
beaucoup monsieur
voilà merci Alexis Corbière merci
Vincent 350
000 manifestants à 14h c'est le dernier
pointage que nous donne actuellement le
figata et on va continuer à suivre cette
mobilisation bonjour Jean-Yves Guerin
bonjour Vincent vous suivez la question
des transports au Figaro économie
quel est l'ampleur déjà de la
mobilisation et de la grève dans les
transports aujourd'hui alors l'ampleur
c'est je regardais par exemple les c'est
une source syndicale pour l'instant la
direction n'a pas communiqué mais on est
à 25% de grévistes à la à la SNCF
25% de grévistes SNCF et plus d'un
conducteur sur deux qui travaillent pas
aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup c'est plus
que des fois précédentes beaucoup c'est
plus que la fois précédente mais faut
pas se tromper de d'ampleur au début du
mouvement le 19 janvier c'était la
première journée de
c'était beaucoup plus haut on était à
l'époque à plus de 46%, le 7 mars début
de la grève renouvelable en tout cas de
l'appel à la grève renouvelable par les
syndicats on était à 39% aujourd'hui
25%, c'est significatif mais on retrait
à quoi attribuez-vous justement ce
retrait par rapport au premier jour de
la mobilisation
parce qu'il y a une sorte de
d'épuisement c'est à dire que même si il
y a des caisses de grève etc faire grève
avec l'inflation ça coûte
cher premièrement et puis et puis
deuxièmement certes il y a déjà eu des
retraits de textes qui étaient qui
étaient voté adopté par le Parlement
pour les plus anciens on peut se
souvenir du contrat premier embauche le
CPE en 2006 mais c'est quand même très
rare c'est à dire que mobiliser
des salariés mécontents
pour des textes qui ne sont pas encore
adoptés qui passent à l'assemblée qui
passe au Sénat qui passe en commission
mix paritaire qui passe alors qu'il y a
une motion de censurer etc
c'est possible là je vais dire la
possibilité de mobiliser les gens sur un
retrait éventuel d'un gouvernement alors
que hier le président de la République a
encore dit que
une retirerait pas le texte mais plus
compliqué
c'est plus compliqué pour des salariés
après on voit ce qui se passe dans la
rue mais pour des salariés
on voit bien qu'on ne sait pas par
exemple moi j'ai eu le patron de l'UNSA
ferroviaire donc c'est le deuxième
syndicat
à la SNCF
qui savent pas ce qu'ils vont faire
demain ils attendent
ce que vont dire les confédérations ce
soir il y a pas une grande visibilité
pour savoir si
alors ça c'est très intéressant parce
que ça c'est l'une des questions qui va
traverser
nos discussions toute cette après-midi
on regarde peut-être les images qui nous
parviennent pour l'instant de la place
de la bâtisse Bastille qui est le point
de départ de la manifestation où
effectivement on a on voit que ça se
remplit sur sur la place on rejoindra
tout à l'heure nos envoyer nous envoyer
spéciaux notamment Timothée delhem et
Julien Julien Leclerc et on verra quel
est l'ampleur de la mobilisation mais ce
qui est intéressant effectivement c'est
que
dans ce que vous dites en tout cas ce
que je retiens c'est que le premier
élément c'est que peut-être qu'il y aura
du monde peut-être qu'il y aura plus de
monde peut-être que cette d'ailleurs
cette manifestation sera galvanisée en
tous les cas renforcé dans sa
détermination après l'interview
d'Emmanuel Macron hier mais en termes de
mobilisation de grève là par contre on
n'est pas dans les comparable au début
de la au début au début du mouvement non
et on le voit également à la RATP alors
c'est plus local la RATP c'est à Paris
mais ceux qui prennent le métro on
constaté c'est à dire que oui le trafic
est perturbé mais non il est beaucoup
moins perturbé que
au tout début de la grève une nouvelle
fois en janvier où il y a eu je crois
deux journées de mobilisation
donc les salariés
s'épuisent probablement parce que les
perspectives sont pas évidentes d'une
part et sont pas tracés et que les
perspectives c'est-à-dire que les
perspectives pour eux si on se situe du
côté de ceux qui refusent cette réforme
et c'est bien pour ça qu'ils font qu'ils
font la grève
la perspective de gagner ou d'arriver à
un compromis elle est assez évanescente
puis et puis après il y a un autre
malgré le 49,3 malgré le regain de
détermination auquel on assiste depuis
quelques jours oui parce que
faut juste revenir sur un autre élément
qui est spécifique sur cet univers des
transports
il y a 3 ans il y a eu déjà une réforme
des retraites tenté déjà une
mobilisation contre cette réforme des
retraites mais qui s'est traduite par
une grève continue à la SNCF et la RATP
pendant plus de six semaines tous les
jours pas de temps en temps comme cette
année c'était la grève voilà tous les
jours alors que là cette fois-ci c'est
allez on va dire toutes les semaines
tous les 10 jours la différence c'est
quoi c'est que en 2019 les hivernes
2019-2020 les cheminots ou les gens qui
travaillent à la RATP avec beaucoup
beaucoup plus à perdre
pourquoi parce que aujourd'hui leur
retraite est calculée sur 75% du dernier
salaire
la réforme de 2019-2020 remettait ça en
cause là ce n'est pas le cas on leur dit
simplement
vous travaillez en moyenne par exemple
pour des conducteurs vous partez vers 56
57 ans vous allez décaler votre âge de
retraite de deux ans
à leurs yeux c'est pas rien mais ça met
pas en cause tout le tous les défis
c'est ce qui explique c'est ce qui
explique que et bien c'est ne sont pas
partis dans un mouvement
voilà l'info l'angoisse en tout cas en
ce moment c'est les carburants et c'est
là le est-ce que c'est là que on va
avoir le vraiment le point de crispation
en tout cas dans les transports mais
cette fois-ci ils sont pas les
transports ferroviaires sur les
transports en voiture alors en voiture
on a vu également des alertes sur le
kérosène c'est moins
non tous les jours c'est pour l'avion
oui pour pour l'avion dans les dans les
aéroports on voit également que et bien
régulièrement
il y a
l'administration demande à les jours de
grève à diminuer le nombre de vols c'est
-20 - 30 % régulièrement à Orly d'accord
après sur le risque d'alimentation en
carburant
je dirais sans vouloir être ironique le
gouvernement on a l'habitude il a déjà
géré à l'automne dernier il y a une arme
qui est qui s'appelle la réquisition et
il y a relativement bien marché la fois
précédente pas tout de suite mais
si effectivement ça se durcit il y a une
arme alors que la grève sont les
réquisitions ce sont les réquisitions a
priori la situation va est-ce que là
pour l'instant on voit notamment en
Île-de-France 14% des actions d'essence
qui sont privées d'essence 40% des
départements qui sont touchés est-ce que
ça risque d'empirer ça risque d'empirer
si c'est ce que disent les les autorités
si vous et moi en tant que consommateur
et bien on fait des achats très cautions
c'est à dire que non seulement on fait
le plein de ta voiture alors que on est
à Mijo je veux voir trois quarts et en
plus ce qu'on commence à voir on arrive
avec un bidon en supplément etc parce
que beaucoup de gens vont travailler en
voiture
on va rejoindre Timothée délène place de
la Bastille et on va continuer cette
conversation Jean-Yves quelques minutes
encore Timothée est-ce que le cortège
s'est élancé
et bien c'est difficile à avoir Vincent
pour la simple et bonne raison qu'il y a
énormément de monde ici sur cette place
de la Bastille et c'est d'ailleurs la
raison pour laquelle nous devons pour
l'instant rester place de la Bastille
parce que il y a des problèmes de
connexion des problèmes de réseau
beaucoup de monde et vous le voyez
d'ailleurs certainement derrière moi du
monde qui est en train en fait
d'emprunter les rues adjacentes pour la
simple et bonne raison que le boulevard
Beaumarchais est noir de monde et voilà
on a du mal à circuler on a du mal à
avancer sa piétine vraiment et donc les
gens sont en train de passer par les
rues adjacentes pour tenter de rejoindre
la tête de cortège qui devait s'élancer
il y a une vingtaine de minutes
difficile du point de vue où je me
trouve de vous dire si le cortège est
véritablement parti ou non pour le
moment
150000 manifestants à travers toute la
France 350 000 manifestants c'est le
pointage en tous les cas qui est donné
par le figata pour l'instant donc on
attend de voir bien sûr si
combien de personnes il y aura à Paris
l'objectif au moins pour les syndicats
assez 800 000 voire un million selon le
décompte de la police est plus que le
million 3 revendiqué par la CGT le 7
mars dernier lors de la 8e journée
effectivement c'était 480 000 selon la
police un million selon les syndicats et
on le disait ce matin avec Richard
Florin c'était en baisse il y a un autre
point de blocage un autre point de
crispation ce sont les routes et les
périphériques coupés est-ce que
aujourd'hui ça continue Jean-Yves et
est-ce que ça va continuer
alors
ça continue oui mais de façon de façon
parcellaire c'est-à-dire que quand il y
a des périphs coupés c'est pas toute la
journée d'accord c'est des
c'est des blocages ponctuels et puis
après
le gouvernement a je dirais fait
quelques concessions par exemple ou
chauffeur de poids lourds c'est pas très
connu mais qui fait que on évite et bien
que cette profession rentre massivement
dans le conflit qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
fait il y avait un dispositif de congé
de fin de carrière qui vous permet de
partir avant 60 ans et sans entrer dans
les détails et bien un petit peu sans en
faire de la publicité le ministère des
Transports là proroger la continuer
d'accord donc
ça enlève
l'envie à beaucoup de chauffeurs de
rentrer dans le conflit
de même de même même si c'est
périphérique vous observerez que les
pilotes les pilotes d'avion qui savent
très bien défendre leur leurs intérêts
ils font pas grève une appellent pas à
la grève il pourrait tout question parce
que le terminal 1 de l'aéroport Charles
de Gaulle a été bloqué par les
manifestants la question c'est est-ce
qu'on va pouvoir prendre l'avion parce
que entre les blocages de terminaux les
blocages d'aéroport il y a une tentative
à Nice ce matin et les problèmes de
kérosène les grèves de éventuelles de
personnel du personnel navigant
d'ailleurs simplement les les avions
mais également les aiguilleurs les
personnages ah il se trouve c'est un
hasard mais il se trouve que moi j'étais
j'avais une conversation téléphonique
avec un des patrons de d'ADP qui me
disait j'ai dit alors vous êtes sur les
charmoisons etc votre piste est bloqué
il me dit il y a 70 personnes qui
bloquent la piste ça ne va pas durer
éternellement 70 personnes c'est pas
vous ne bloquez pas techniquement tout
un aéroport donc des blocages ponctuels
oui
le fait que aucun avion ne décolle non
si je vous suis et si finalement je
il y a une conclusion à retenir c'est
que le secteur des transports est quand
même impacté bien sûr par tous ces
mouvements mais il est moins que lors de
mouvement précédent en particulier vous
le disiez tout à l'heure en 2019 et
finalement
les salariés de transports ne sont pas
plus concernés que ça par cette réforme
ils le sont mais habituellement ils
étaient les faire de Lons de la
contestation sociale et là c'est moins
le cas et là c'est nettement merci
beaucoup Jean-Yves pour toutes ces
précisions et d'être passé par les
studios du Figaro bien entendu on va
continuer à suivre la situation avec
vous on va recommander bien sûr tous les
articles que vous écrivez c'est sur le
site du Figaro ou bien sûr le PDF du
figure parce que aujourd'hui le Figaro
n'a pas pu paraître en kiosque mais bien
sûr tout est à dire et tout est à
retrouver dans les pages économies du
Figaro dans les pages Chaumont de
l'édition papier et sur le site du
Figaro économie on va retrouver si on
peut Vincent roseron à moins que oui
voilà je vois que les images rebouchent
Vincent où en est la situation là où là
où vous êtes est-ce qu'il y a encore des
des élus est-ce qu'il y a encore des
politiques autour de vous et est-ce que
le cortège était lancé
alors vous pouvez voir la dernière
question oui le cortège s'était lancé il
s'était lancé juste d'ici que vous voyez
là voilà il s'était ici que la police
faisait un peu barrage au début de la
manifestation vers 14h10 ils ont laissé
passer les gens sachant que les tous
premiers on est sur le boulevard
Beaumarchais on n'est pas place de la
Bastille on est quand même au moins 500
mètres devant en fait la place de la
Bastille donc il y a un premier cortège
qui a commencé à passer et on est sur un
cortège assez informel là qui s'est
lancé et qui est parti puisque si vous
regardez là-bas il y a les premiers
ballons tout au fond de cette image vous
voyez les premiers ballons de solidaire
qui sont les premiers ballons de de
syndicat donc en fait le vrai défilé des
syndicats on va dire est encore tout au
fond et c'est pour ça que tout au fond
là-bas la foule est encore très compacte
alors qu'ici pour l'instant pas vraiment
on n'est pas encore avec une foule si
compact que ça vous me parlez aussi des
politiques les politiques ils ont tenu
un point presse juste à l'angle de cette
rue ici tout à l'heure je vous le disais
à peu près une demi-heure là où on a
interrogé d'ailleurs Alexis Corbière et
ensuite ils sont partis rejoindre leur
stand puisque ils ont des stands de tout
au long de la manifestation on les
rejoindra aussi le long tout au long de
cette manifestations pour aller leur
poser des questions aux différents
groupes politiques bien évidemment et en
tout cas voilà là on voit la
manifestation qui on va dire réellement
démarré avec de plus en plus de monde
qui affluent depuis la place de la
Bastille et qui arrive petit à petit sur
ce boulevard Beaumarchais en tout cas
qui continue à l'endroit où je me trouve
en tout cas actuellement avec beaucoup
beaucoup de monde qui arrivent des
fumigènes déjà
allumé voilà
et bien vous voyez effectivement on les
voit assez fumigènes ils sont derrière
vous mon cher Vincent et bien vous nous
prévenez dès que vous avez quelqu'un dès
que vous avez un de ces manifestants qui
a commencé à battre le pavé en direction
de la place de l'Opéra ou bien une
personnalité politique Thomas en grande
bonjour bonjour Vincent vous suivez
l'actualité sociale ou Figaro économie
et en particulier les syndicats quel est
justement l'humeur aujourd'hui dans les
centrales syndicales alors elle est
bonne d'un côté parce que il y a l'air
d'y avoir beaucoup de monde c'est les
retours qui qui pointent voilà donc 350
000 à 14h voilà c'est les chiffres eux
de ce qu'ils disent ça serait entre la
journée du 7 et du 31 bon alors voilà ça
c'est ce qui revendique mais ce qui
serait effectivement même enfin plutôt
une bonne journée et puis surtout un peu
tiré à l'inverse des des précédentes
mobilisations qui avaient été qui
avaient laissé imaginer le début d'un
déclin quand même les les rassemblements
va pas rassembler autant de monde que
lors des semaines précédentes donc là si
effectivement les chiffres étaient à peu
près aussi élevés que ce qu'ils
annoncent ça serait vraiment quand même
le symbole que il y a eu une sorte de
redémarrage de la contestation donc ça
l'objectif c'est quoi c'est de passer
800 de dépasser 800000 manifestants et
ils ont pas fixé objectivement ils ont
pas pris les risques en fait je pense
qu'il y a quelque chose qui la fois
dernière déjà bah alors ça je pense que
s'il y arrive pas ça serait très
inquiétant mais surtout je pense en fait
ils hésitaient de savoir de quel côté la
pièce va tomber entre deux tendances
contradictoires c'est-à-dire d'une part
le 49,3 éventuellement le passage de
Emmanuel Macron au trésor dire à quel
point ça pouvait peut-être relancer la
contestation repousser les gens à
redescendre la rue et de l'autre ben
l'usure habituelle de tout mouvement
social on est quand même à la neuvième
journée de mobilisation effectivement ça
durera moins longtemps que les impôts
comme disait un des syndicalistes
présents un mois justement ce que nous
dire ce que vient de dire Jean-Yves
Guéra juste avant que vous vouliez et
très intéressant c'est que effectivement
on voit une mobilisation on voit
d'ailleurs ces images place de la
Bastille et quand on sait que les
boulevards alentours sont déjà
pleinement noir de monde nous disait
tout à l'heure Timothée délaime ça
présage effectivement d'une forte
mobilisation mais par exemple quand on
regarde au niveau des d'autres
indicateurs comme tout simplement
la grève ou les arrêts de travail dans
un secteur aussi emblématique pour ce
genre de mouvement que celui des
transports on s'aperçoit que certes 25%
mais enfin c'est bien moins que le début
du mouvement et c'est moins quand en
2018 2019 malgré la question malgré le
regain je sais qu'il a encore plutôt
pour répondre mais malgré le regard et
la détermination est-ce que quand même
la lassitude quand même ne persiste pas
s'il y a effectivement et
obligatoirement un effet de lassitude
donc effectivement il se voit dans un
taux de grévistes et blocage qui en fait
stagne stagne n'explose pas n'atteint
pas les des niveaux qui ont été connus
dans des précédents mouvements de toute
façon il n'avait déjà pas réussi lors de
la du 7 mars de la journée française à
l'arrêt donc effectivement de ce côté-là
ça c'est l'un des c'est l'un des quand
même ça c'est l'un des phénomènes de ce
mouvement c'est exactement alors est-ce
que c'est parce que ça c'est la question
que se posait certains leaders
ces dernières semaines est-ce que ça a
raté parce que on n'a pas réussi à
trouver les bons mots ou parce que on
n'a pas trouvé la bonne méthode ou
est-ce que
ça veut dire que les temps ont changé
qu'aujourd'hui l'interdicale ne peut
tout simplement plus bloquer le pays
comme elle a été capable de le faire à
la fin des années 90 ou même avant voilà
ça c'est la même au milieu des années 90
voilà donc donc ça date voilà ça c'est
la question un peu qui est
qui inquiétait aussi les syndicats alors
l'objectif pour aujourd'hui donc déjà
c'est de faire mieux avec la foi à la
fois précédente et c'est d'arriver
d'avoisiner de tutoyer en tout cas une
mobilisation comparable à celle du 7
mars qui a été pour l'instant la
mobilisation record effectivement si ils
arrivent comme ils disent à tourner
autour du 31 du 7 je pense qu'ils seront
ça sera un très bon résultat pour les
syndics
donc c'est une nouvelle journée ce qu'il
faut s'attendre à de nouvelles journées
de manifestations au regard de ce que
vous êtes en train de me dire ça semble
effectivement c'est un risque c'est un
risque important alors officiellement il
renvoie tous il renvoie tous les
journalistes vers l'Inter syndicale qui
a lieu ce soir au siège de la CFDT à
19h30 ou ils annonceront
si on a une ou pas et si oui la date
mais très très objectivement quand on
lit entre les LIGNES on se demande
comment il n'annonceront pas une
nouvelle date la semaine prochaine
quels sont les alors je vous demandais
quel était l'humeur alors qu'on voit
visiblement notamment des syndicalistes
de la CFTC ça c'est un des phénomènes
quand même la mobilisation très ferme en
tout cas des syndicats réformistes CFTC
c'est je sais bien sûr CFDT oui oui bah
et enfin c'est que moyennement étonnant
surtout par exemple pour la CFDT où on
sait que Laurent Berger lors de son
dernier congrès a été réélu vraiment
avec cette ligne de pas de recul sur
l'âge de départ et pas d'allongement de
la durée de la nuitée c'est intéressant
ce que vous anticipez sur une des
questions que je voulais vous poser les
syndicats voilà sont sur une ligne ferme
et est-ce que justement cette fermeté ne
vient pas du fait que il y a eu 3
centrales en congrès bon la CGC
actuellement avec la réélection François
homeryl qui a eu un langage là aussi
assez ferme assez dur la CGT
prochainement et puis la CFDT
dernièrement
bah c'est sûr que ça a joué c'est sûr
que ça a joué d'ailleurs certains
syndicalistes pointent notamment pour ça
parfois le manque de stratégie du
gouvernement qui est certain réformiste
d'ailleurs ils ont prévenu en disant
attention si le vote timing est
dangereux si vous mettez un sujet aussi
brûlant à quelques semaines de certaines
centrales vous allez enfin vous mettez
vous-même un bâton dans les roues parce
que effectivement ça va pousser les plus
radicaux à
sortir du bois et effectivement c'est ce
qui se passe ça ne fait aucun doute que
du côté de la CGT d'ailleurs il s'agit
très très probablement du dernier
cortège parisien de
Philippe Martinez le leader de la CGT
donc non non c'est sûr que il y a eu un
effet de radicalisation en tout cas à la
CGT voir chez la CFE-CGC de
l'approche du Congrès et de cette
réforme des retraites
on va on va revenir avec des questions
effectivement qui sont posées sur le
site du Figaro vous continuez ça débat
ça commente mais sur la colère et la
manifestation est-ce qu'elle
n'engagent pas plusieurs motifs de mes
contentement contre la macronie bien
au-delà de la réforme des retraites on
revient sur la question des syndicats
là il y a eu un motif de colère c'était
en tous les cas des syndicats des
réactions vivent encore ce matin Laurent
Berger par rapport à la prise de parole
d'Emmanuel Macron
Olivier du soft
a déclaré ce matin sur RTL que il était
prêt à reparler avec les
syndicats réactions il faut un délai de
décence CFDT bon quand est-ce que ce
délai de décence s'arrête et quelles
sont les conditions des syndicats pour
reparler au gouvernement
c'est flou
Laurent Berger a dit j'irai pas la
semaine prochaine au delà effectivement
donc voilà il a il a dit que ça sera
plus d'une semaine c'est tout ce qu'on
sait après objectivement ça va aussi
beaucoup dépendre de la mobilisation
dans les prochains jours les prochaines
semaines aussi si les syndicats estiment
qu'ils peuvent qu'ils ont toujours
intérêt à rester complètement concentré
sur le bras de fer avec le gouvernement
sur la forme des retraites il se
précipiteront d'autant moins
au ministère du travail ou à l'Élysée
ça c'était la première question ça c'est
le délai de dessin quels sont les
conditions les conditions voilà donc
Laurent Berger les a quand même un peu
rappelé c'est à dire que
il est toujours il se dit toujours
partant pour aller échanger avec le
gouvernement à condition que il y a une
vraie concertation comme il l'a dit
c'est à dire que il n'ira pas de nouveau
au ministère du travail uniquement pour
servir de caution comme il dit de
caution de discussion de voilà au
gouvernement il cette fois il a dit
qu'il voudrait des garanties objectives
sur un à quoi servent les discussions et
deux
jusqu'où le gouvernement est prêt à
aller c'est à dire que ce que reproche
beaucoup les syndicats notamment sur la
question des retraites sur la discussion
c'est à dire que le gouvernement leur a
dit enfin c'est ce qu'ils disent qu'ils
étaient prêts à concertés qui que le
gouvernement était prêt à concerter mais
que de toute façon il ne reviendrait pas
sur les 64 ans et eux c'est typiquement
sur ce sur quoi il voulait revenir donc
en fait il se dit si demain par exemple
on parle de la loi pleine emploi qui va
être une concentration de différentes
mesures Laurent Berger dit ben dites moi
précisément sur quoi enfin si vous êtes
vraiment prêt à bouger si vous n'êtes
pas forcément
inutile que de me faire venir on va
repartir place de la Bastille en tous
les cas aux alentours de la place de la
Bâthie Bastille
retrouvée Timothée délai mais Julien
Leclerc Timothée apparemment ça y est de
votre côté le cortège est parti
alors effectivement le cortège on le
voit sur ces images et reparties et mais
apparemment il y a des problèmes de
réseau alors ça vous sachiez que
effectivement quand on est assez
compacté dans une foule comme ça bien on
est plusieurs médias à avoir des
liaisons téléphone des liaisons
satellites par lesquelles on reçoit ces
images et finalement c'est un petit peu
plus compliqué d'être toujours en lien
donc on s'écarte parfois ça nous arrive
notamment le 14 juillet et donc voilà
c'est le phénomène qui arrive à Timothée
DM c'est le signe quand même que là où
ils sont en tous les cas il y a il y a
du monde on va retrouver peut-être
Vincent roserand qui lui est sur un
autre tronçon du cortège Vincent est-ce
que d'abord vous nous entendez et
ensuite est-ce que là où vous êtes
effectivement on ne voit le cortège
partir
oui Vincent je trouve actuellement à
haut niveau du début du cortège j'ai vu
passer l'Inter syndical Laurent Berger
et Philippe Martinez de la CGT et de la
CFDT qui avançait côte à côte en
rigolant même l'ambiance était plutôt
pas d'entre eux et là vous voyez
solidaire c'est le premier cortège qui
est là solidaire avec une foule compacte
une foule compact qui a avance petit à
petit et ça ne m'étonne pas d'ailleurs
que vous n'ayez qui ait des problèmes de
réseau puisque il y a beaucoup beaucoup
de monde pour l'instant on voit une
foule assez compact comme je vous le
disais
très calme et semble assez sereine je
reviens vers vous Thomas d'abord une
première réaction à ce que disait
Vincent les relations entre Laurent
Berger et et Philippe Martinez dans
quelle mesure elles sont aussi bonnes
que celles qu'on peut percevoir en tout
cas elles sont affichées je pense
qu'elles sont enfin alors est-ce qu'il
joue aussi une sorte d'union qui est
aussi dans leur intérêt toujours à
montrer que l'Inter syndicale est plus
forte que jamais et qui a pas l'écart
d'un d'un gravillon comme disait comme
disait un des leaders voilà entre eux
mais je pense qu'objectivement c'est
vrai que à force de se rencontrer toutes
les semaines depuis trois mois d'avoir
un combat en commun sacré forcément du
lien ça ils le disent tous hein pas
forcément Laurent Berger et Philippe
Martinez voilà même certains
syndicat très radicaux comme solidaire a
reconnu lui-même que ça avait permis de
casser beaucoup de préjugés sur sur
d'autres centrales y compris les plus
réformistes donc il y a effectivement
des liens qui sont créés en plus bon il
y a quelque chose qui joue là qui est
plus anecdotique mais c'est que il
s'agit des derniers jours c'est un peu
triste de dire mais en tout cas des
derniers jours de Philippe Martinez à la
tête de la société donc en soi il il a
lui-même plus grand chose à jouer dans
l'idée il peut voilà je pense qu'il est
aussi plus serein plus voilà c'est
combat celui-là c'est le dernier il
partira et ça facilite le je reviens sur
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure sur
les
échanges entre le gouvernement et les
syndicats un des phénomènes en tous les
cas depuis l'arrivée de d'Emmanuel
Macron à l'Elysée c'est que
les relations sont quand même
notoirement mauvaises entre l'Élysée et
les syndicats du temps de Nicolas
Sarkozy du temps de François Hollande il
y avait des conseillers sociaux qui
échangaient régulièrement on se souvient
notamment de Raymond souby sous sous
Sarkozy qui était un orfèvre des
relations sociales là c'est pas le cas
dans l'entourage d'Emmanuel Macron alors
est-ce qu'il y a pas de conseillers
social certainement qu'il y en a mais
c'est vrai que les syndicats ont noté
surtout parmi les militants qui sont
depuis plus longtemps et qu'on connu
effectivement plusieurs quinquennat et
qui peuvent faire des comparaisons entre
eux ils notent qu'effectivement il y a
quand même eu un changement entre ce
qu'ils avaient vu sous les autres
quinquennats et les deux de d'Emmanuel
Macron effectivement le public a été
différent ça a été d'ailleurs ça a été
très officialisé par Emmanuel Macron il
a voulu aussi ramener des personnes de
la société civile comme il a dit des
gens qui n'étaient pas des politiques
pour plein de raisons qui qui justifient
d'ailleurs mais une des conséquences
c'est qu'effectivement ils ont une
connaissance une maîtrise
du dialogue social qui n'est pas le même
que leur prédécesseurs et ça les
syndicats sentent très bien bon alors là
forcément en période de conflit ça
participe à tendre attendre les
relations effectivement entre les
syndicats et le gouvernement plusieurs
se sont pleins syndicats d'avoir été
reçus alors même pas par des ministres
par des vraiment des gens ne savaient
pas qui c'était en gros ils avaient été
un peu peut-être pas à la juste valeur
et puis aussi plusieurs
choix tactiques étonnants du
gouvernement notamment je parlais la
proximité des différents congrès avec
cette bataille des retraites qui n'était
pas forcément
Albert Zenou ce matin dans le dans le
Figaro c'est qu'il y a vraiment un
mauvais timing dans le dans le choix en
tout cas le timing ne joue pas en faveur
d'une proposition comme celle de la
réforme de retraite avec le
reportotémique de l'âge oui oui c'est ça
effectivement c'est les syndicats ont
pointé plusieurs plusieurs fois des
erreurs tactiques vraiment purement du
gouvernement et ce qu'ils disent ce
qu'il disait un certain moment notamment
pendant les trois semaines qu'on séparés
la journée de mobilisation du
c'était du cesse de 16 février celle du
7 mars 3 semaines ça pouvait paraître
énorme et beaucoup craignaient que la
contestation complètement s'essouffle
pendant ce moment-là et les syndicats
étaient là étaient très confiants en
disant le gouvernement a sorti plusieurs
erreurs qui nous nourrissent donc même
si on leur laisse la parole on
s'inquiète pas tellement pour la suite
du mouvement c'était l'époque de 1200
euros notamment alors justement on va
voir si la contestation s'essouffle on
va retrouver Timothée délai qui enfin a
retrouvé du réseau et à retrouver
l'image elle est parfaite elle est
claire elle est limpide Timothée
quelle est l'influence autour de vous on
voit effectivement juste à côté de vous
sur cette sur ce player énormément de
monde ça doit être justement dans les
avenues entre la Place de la Bastille et
la place de l'Opéra il y a un peu moins
de monde autour de vous mais peut-être
que c'est un entrepreneur parce que vous
avez dû vous écarter
exactement Vincent c'est assez trompeur
parce qu'il y a tellement de monde que
nous avons dû nous écarter parce que
nous avons du mal à capter le réseau là
nous nous trouvons au niveau sur le
boulevard Beaumarchais ce boulevard
Beaumarchais qui donc relie la place de
la Bastille a la place de la République
en passant par le boulevard du Temple
également le cortège syndical la tête du
cortège qui se trouve derrière nous vous
les voyez peut-être sur ces images de
Julien Leclerc là-bas les ballons
solidaires les ballons Sud rails que
nous avons que nous avons dépassé à pied
et nous sommes passés pour cela par des
rues adjacentes parce que et bien comme
je vous le disais tout à l'heure c'est
vrai qu'on piétine beaucoup en ce début
de manifestation car il y a vraiment
beaucoup de monde la rue des Tournelles
par exemple qui est une rue parallèle au
boulevard du Beaumarchais et elle aussi
noire de monde parce que les
manifestants certains et bien essayé de
faire le tour donc ils sont ils sont
sortis de cette place de la Bastille ils
ont emprunté la rue des Tournelles et
ils essayent de rejoindre ce boulevard
Beaumarchais mais c'est vrai que voilà
on a du mal à
sur ce boulevard parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de monde et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous nous trouvons donc à
présent devant le devant le cortège nous
avons aperçu différents leaders
syndicaux Philippe barthinez de la CGT
Laurent Berger de la CFDT pour ne citer
que et donc solidaire reste une rail qui
se trouve derrière nous le cortège en
tous les cas qui est parti en retard
avec environ 30 minutes de retard et qui
maintenant pour le coup bien parti sur
ce boulevard Beaumarchais
on a vu ces derniers jours et puis vous
étiez d'ailleurs sur le terrain encore
hier soir Timothée pour voir comment ça
se passait pas mal de tension et même
des violences
est-ce que on sent cette tension dans la
manifestation ou bien est-ce que le
calme le calme qu'on a vu dans les
précédentes mobilisations et de retour
et bien le calme est de retour en tous
les cas pour le moment c'est vrai que la
présence des forces de l'ordre se fait
assez discrète il y a évidemment un
barrage de force de l'ordre pour accéder
à la manifestation et au début de la
manifestation sur cette place de la
Bastille parce que nous concerne nous
avons été fouillé pour les sacs nous
avons également montré notre notre carte
de presse pour justifier les casques que
nous avons avec nous en cas de
d'éventuelles débordement mais à part ça
c'est vrai que la présence policière se
fait assez discrète d'ailleurs ça se
voit sur ces images pas de pas de
policier pas de gendarme ni de ni de CRS
et pour l'instant en tout cas cette
manifestation qui se déroule dans le
calme qui se déroule très classiquement
avec beaucoup de slogans avec beaucoup
de pancartes également et aussi une
manifestation assez intergénérationnelle
autant c'est vrai que par exemple hier
soir de la rue de la capitale nous avons
parlé avec beaucoup de jeunes beaucoup
d'étudiants qui s'étaient Rasse lés ici
ou là là c'est vrai qu'il y a des
étudiants mais pas seulement vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup de personnes des
retraités et des et des plus jeunes qui
sont qui défilent dans les rues de la
capitale pour le moment cet après-midi
merci beaucoup Timothée pour ces
précisions on va revenir vers vous d'ici
une dizaine de minutes au plus tard
je salue frog qui nous regarde depuis
Vienne en Autriche et bien vous nous
dites justement comment réagissent les
Autrichiens par rapport à cette à ces
manifestations comment cette situation
est vue de là où vous êtes
sur les slogans Castellane Etienne nous
dit la seule chose que j'apprécie que
j'apprécie chez les manifestants ce sont
certains slogans très drôles comme 16,64
c'est une bière pas une carrière
allusion bien sûr aux carrières longues
et une autre question harcèle pas yeux
alors il est très en colère contre les
les manifestants et contre contre les
syndicats il nous dit et j'aimerais bien
avoir la votre précision lorsque je vois
les ballons les véhicules les gilets par
payer avec nos impôts CGT et par pour la
CGT et les autres syndicats c'est une
honte les sources de revenus pour les
syndicats en France c'est quoi
exactement ce sont les Cotis
principalement les cotisations des des
militants payés payés voilà donc ça
c'est c'est ce qui fait la force la
force les moyens aussi du syndicat c'est
vrai qu'une manifestation coûte très
cher ça on s'en rend pas forcément
compte mais entre les ballons comme vous
dites les véhicules ramener parfois
aussi des militants de différentes
villes communautes sur la capitale pour
pour faire du nombre il y a beaucoup de
services d'ordre et effectivement ils
vont mettre ils vont être mis
probablement
au travail enfin ils vont devoir
beaucoup travailler aujourd'hui parce
que Ben effectivement certains l'annonce
ça sera sûrement tendu on a vu ce qui
s'est passé ces derniers jours et
effectivement le reste débordement est
une vraie crainte du côté des syndicats
organisateurs
Laurent Berger ce matin condamné la
violence il la redit d'ailleurs en début
de en début de manifester en début de
manifestation je vais vous redonner tout
de suite la déclaration elle vient de
disparaître de mon écran mais ça n'est
qu'une affaire de seconde
Laurent Berger donc la redit tout à
l'heure en disant qu'il appelait à la
non-violence
pour garder l'opinion question est-ce
que
pendant que Laurent Berger condorne la
violence appel à la non-violence on
entend Céline verte c'est l'éthi de la
CGT et qui estime que la violence c'est
d'abord celle des forces de l'ordre
quelle est la position de
l'intersyndicale face justement dont
seulement au blocage mais mais par
rapport à ces violences là est-ce que il
y a pas une risque un premier risque de
fissure de ce France syndical
effectivement c'est vrai que la question
des violences policières c'est quelque
chose qui n'avait pas de violence contre
les policiers et des violences parfois
qui sont le faites des policiers mais
c'est vrai que c'est un thème qui
n'avait pas du tout imprimé que même les
syndicats les plus radicaux n'avaient
pas brandi effectivement ça a commencé à
arriver et chose assez rare Laurent
Berger de façon très mesurée a aussi
signaler qu'il avait vu des
comportements inadmissibles de la part
des forces de l'ordre alors il y a tout
à l'heure voilà exactement il a il a mis
dos à dos manifestants violents et
effectivement certains membres des
forces de l'ordre un petit groupe qui
auraient pu effectivement donc ça voilà
sorti de leur
contexte
officiellement en tout cas l'Inter
syndicale elle reste sur l'idée que pas
de violence et surtout ne pas s'en
prendre au bien et aux personnes c'est
le mot d'ordre effectivement ils ont
conscience de l'importance de ce mot
d'ordre pour garder l'opinion publique
avec eux alors je vois que Fabien
Roussel est près de une caméra peut-être
que Vincent rose on va arriver à la voir
Vincent est-ce qu'on peut avoir Fabien
Roussel
ah non c'est Timothée d'Hélène qui est à
côté de Fabien Roussel
alors apparemment bon on va justement
toute la journée je m'arrête là
c'est toujours Noël
comme ça ils auront par écrit
quelques mots monsieur pour Le Figaro on
y va elle est où bonjour ça va vous
allez bien
allez Timothée c'est à vous
on y va oui Vincent roux voilà avec avec
Fabien Roussel bonjour Fabien Roussel
quels sont vos attentes pour cette
mobilisation de cet après-midi mais
d'abord on va voir les chiffres mais ça
a l'air d'être encore une mobilisation
exceptionnelle ce qui montre qu'il y a
vraiment pas des soufflement dans le
rejet des Français de cette réforme de
retraite à 64 ans c'est un signe
d'espoir la position du gouvernement et
du président de la République est
intenable ils sont de plus en plus
isolés dans le pays et donc nous
appelons à poursuivre le combat chacun
dans notre rôle chacun dans nos missions
j'appelle les salariés et les militants
communistes justement dans leurs
entreprises à bloquer l'outil de travail
à mettre l'économie à l'arrêt à bloquer
les voies de circulation nous ne
céderons rien nous ne céderons pas d'un
pouce et d'ailleurs nous élu
parlementaire nous nous posons la
question nous nous interrogeons sur la
manière dont nous pouvons continuer de
travailler avec le ministre et le
gouvernement on peut pas continuer à
aller sierger comme si de rien n'était
après ce qui est en ce qui s'est passé
après l'attitude du gouvernement et du
président de la République et donc nous
sommes donc vous le voyez très déterminé
et nous entrons résistance vous pensez
qu'il n'y a pas d'alternative à un
blocage du pays pour faire changer le
gouvernement d'avis si il y a une
alternative elle est pacifique elle est
démocratique elle est même
constitutionnelle c'est de laisser faire
le référendum d'initiative partagé et
pendant ce temps-là de suspendre la
réforme pour apaiser la situation et
renouer les fils du dialogue et donner
la parole au peuple français si
aujourd'hui le président de la
République décidait de suspendre cette
réforme d'engager ce référendum je peux
vous dire que je pense que rapidement
nous pourrions retrouver le calme et le
sens du débat vous parliez de l'ampleur
de la mobilisation c'est vrai que c'est
un élément important qui est scruté de
près y compris par l'exécutif à partir
de combien de personnes est-ce que vous
considérez que cette manifestation
d'aujourd'hui est une réussite
vous voyez bien que pour le président de
la République c'est pas le nombre qui
compte
et qu'importe pour lui le nombre que
nous serions dans la rue 9 Français sur
10 ne veulent pas de cette réforme et il
continue il y a des manifestations comme
jamais il y en a eu dans notre pays et
il maintient sa réforme il fait le pari
de la violence il fait le pari que ça
déborde et qu'il y ait des blessés il se
comporte comme un casseur et c'est
extrêmement grave un casseur de la
démocratie un casseur du dialogue social
il fait le pari des débordements de la
violence et ça je le dénonce fermement
nous nous faisons le pari
de mobilisation pacifique et non
violente et nous continuerons dans ce
sens là il y a eu malgré tout ces
derniers jours quelques quelques moments
effectivement de violence qu'est-ce que
vous dites à aux personnes qui ont pu
céder à la violence et bien justement je
j'appelle à ce que nous puissions
continuer poursuivre des mobilisations
passifiques et non violente comme l’ont
fait d'ailleurs les organisations
syndicales jusqu'à maintenant et que ces
rassemblements se tiennent de la manière
la plus calme possible et je regrette
que le choix du président de la
République soit celui de susciter la
colère dans le pays car on est en train
aujourd'hui de passer de manifestations
pacifiques au Gold cassées on est en
train de passer de grandes
manifestations à des chocs violents
entre les forces de l'ordre et des
manifestants et ça c'est extrêmement
grave et c'est ce n'est pas ce que je
souhaite pour mon pays qu'est-ce que
vous avez pensé de son intervention
télévisée hier après-midi le président
de la République fait le choix avec sa
morgue de mépriser complètement ce qui
se passe dans le pays de passer en force
et c'est pour ça que je dis qu'il fait
le choix de la violence il fait le choix
de provoquer les violences comme si
aujourd'hui il voulait retourner
l'opinion
contre les organisations syndicales
c'est grave parce qu'en faisant ça il
fracture encore plus la démocratie
sociale et il prend le risque qu'il y
ait des blessés de quelques côtés que ce
soit et bien moi je ne souhaite de
blesser ni chez les forces de l'ordre ni
chez les manifestants et d'ailleurs
j'appelle les forces de l'ordre à
rejoindre le mouvement parce que nous
sommes tous ensemble dans ce combat pour
le progrès social un dernier mot Fabien
Roussel est-ce que vous pensez que il y
aura d'autres manifestations à venir
dans les prochains jours peut-être des
samedis c'est à l'Inter syndical de
décider de la suite du mouvement c'est
eux qui ont toujours décidé de manière
exemplaire la manière dont il fallait le
poursuivre je leur fais entièrement
confiance mais nous nous participons à
tous les appels qu'ils lanceront et nous
créerons toutes les conditions dans les
entreprises de durcir le mouvement et de
mettre le pays l'économie à l'arrêt
merci beaucoup Fabien Roussel le
secrétaire national du Parti communiste
qui réagissait pour Le Figaro beaucoup
de monde beaucoup de journalistes on va
essayer de s'extirper de cette foule
Vincent merci beaucoup Timothée bonjour
Alexis
vous êtes le directeur des rédactions du
groupe Figaro
l'environnement Roussel qui finalement
essaye de ménager les deux c'est-à-dire
d'avoir un discours très ferme mais d'un
autre côté qui a qui ne veut pas
paraître comme quelqu'un qui veut
attiser la violence peut-être aussi une
volonté de se distinguer de ses
camarades insoumis disons que depuis le
début les les syndicats et c'est vrai
les communistes et Fred garde à ne pas
prêter le flanc à cette critique qui
serait qu'on dise qu'ils sont des
facteurs de désordre de violence etc
parce qu'ils veulent surtout pas que le
gouvernement puisse rééditer ce qu'on
avait vu lors des gilets jaunes
c'est-à-dire de redevenir le parti de
l'ordre et fédérer derrière lui et
contre le mouvement l'opinion
aujourd'hui le Paris des forces
syndicales semble pour l'instant on va
voir ce qui se passe enfin pour
l'instant ça va plutôt réussie c'est à
dire que le temps passe le mouvement
commence c'est quoi le 19 janvier donc
ça fait maintenant trois mois
il y a une phase de montée sur une phase
de semble-t-il de décrit du mouvement et
là on pouvait se dire bon maintenant
c'est à dire le tout le pari du
gouvernement et de d'Emmanuel Macron se
dire maintenant c'est voter on va on va
en sortir les gens vont se faire une
raison après tout ils sont résignés et
c'est vrai que depuis
l'utilisation du quart de froid il y
avait pas forcément d'autres solutions
d'ailleurs depuis l'utilisation de 49-3
depuis l'intervention du président de la
République
hier soir derrière
pour l'instant les choses ne donnent pas
l'impression de se calmer on dirait même
au contraire et donc si alors qu'on
attendait une décrue du mouvement le
mouvement repart à la hausse
politiquement c'est quand même alors il
y a deux indicateurs donc là on est en
train de voir la mobilisation en ce
moment visiblement on va on va voir ça
tout au long de l'après-midi on n'a pas
encore de chiffre définitif mais enfin
les indicateurs sont à la hausse donc on
sait pas jusqu'à quel moment à la hausse
mais Jean-Yves Guerin lui disait tout à
l'heure par exemple un secteur qui
traditionnellement se mobilise beaucoup
dans ce genre d'actualité que le secteur
des transports finalement la grève elle
est moins forte pas que la semaine
dernière mais que au tout début
mouvement du mouvement il y a moins de
mobilisation il y a des blogages
sporadiques mais le pays est pas
complètement bloqué et ce qui traduisait
ils étaient en tout cas un signe un
signe de lassitude donc est-ce que
finalement il y a pas justement les jeux
sont pas encore quand même assez ouverts
les choses sont ouvertes absolument
c'est pour ça que cette journée
aujourd'hui était importante après le
temps va passer on va voir
les choses ne vont pas se décider
aujourd'hui c'est pas pile ça tombe d'un
côté face à tombe de l'autre c'est plus
plus complexe que ça c'est vrai que le
transport semble plutôt moins bloquer
qu'au début moi et plus ou moins moins
bloqué qu'ils n'ont été par le passé en
revanche il y a la question notamment à
Paris mais pas que des poubelles qui par
le passé
en ligne de compte qui me semble-t-il à
un élément important de visibilité de
mouvement de nuisances pour pour la
population et puis peut-être de symboles
de tout qui se détraquent quand les
poubelles sont dans la rue donc là il y
a quelque chose qui est nouveau il va
falloir surveiller aussi les dépôts
d'essence dans quel est ce que on va
revivre un scénario comme au mois
d'octobre ou pas on verra bien donc
on peut pas c'est vrai que tout ça c'est
quelque chose de multifactoriel mais
c'est aussi quelque chose de très
impalpable c'était un climat c'est
est-ce que tout à coup
le sentiment va s'installer que ça ne
fait que grossir à ce moment-là le
gouvernement serait quand même très très
embêté ça c'est une question d'une
internaute et d'autres internautes qu'on
a tout au long de ces directs c'est mais
est-ce que justement cette mobilisation
elle n'est le nom que d'un refus de la
réforme des retraites où elle agrège
d'autres revendications d'autres colères
il y a cette dimension qu'est-ce que je
propose et qui n'apaisent pas forcément
les mêmes réponses en tout cas à court
terme pour le gouvernement
l'affaire politique elle se joue du côté
droit si le gouvernement veut trouver
une majorité à son lit il faudrait
qu'elle aille plutôt à droite bon ça m'a
l'air mal parti et j'ai pas l'impression
que la droite est très envie mais enfin
en tout cas on sent bien que la majorité
complémentaire ou de d'élargissement et
du côté droit la crise sociale elle
l'appelle des réponses de gauche la
colère sociale mécontentement c'est
c'est une c'est lié aussi au pouvoir
d'achat c'est lié à l'inflation et donc
c'est très difficile et dans une
certaine mesure on vit là comment dire
le le
la traduction du du piège définitif mais
en même temps le gouvernement doit aller
à droite d'un côté à gauche de l'autre
résultat il va nulle part et résultat il
se fait taper et par la droite politique
et par la gauche sur le terrain social
et il est quand même pris un peu comme
le lapin dans les phares de d'une
voiture est-ce que la traduction de ça
c'est pas le sondage justement qu'on
publie en ce moment c'est que Emmanuel
Macron n'a visiblement pas convaincu
après ces interventions elle est ni les
internautes du Figaro ni l'ensemble des
fleurs on vient on fait un sondage avec
odoxa et bac brun Consulting qu'on a
publié sur le site à tout à l'heure sur
finalement est-ce que le Macron a réussi
à calmer le jeu et la réponse est non
plus des trois quarts des Français n'ont
pas été convaincus parce qu'il a dit
il juge que il n'a pas du tout compris
leur préoccupation que qui est edit
surtout et c'est ça qui est plus
préoccupant que la mobilisation doit se
poursuivre et qui sont plus nombreux à
soutenir la mobilisation ou la
protestation ou la colère que par le
passé il dit si jamais il y a des
violences et des débordements parce que
on leur pose la question on leur dit ben
ça quand même disons c'est évidemment
c'est pas bien mais ce sera la faute du
gouvernement donc c'est vrai que le
cahier des charges de macro d'Emmanuel
Macron qui était d'essayer de calmer le
jeu d'apaiser autant que se faire se
peut les choses ça n'a pas fonctionné il
n'a pas trouvé les mots pour le pour le
faire est-ce que on entendait tout à
l'heure Fabien Roussel maintenant quand
on regarde ça c'est côté Macron mais
quand on regarde en face qui qui sort
enfin j'allais pas dire vainqueur mais
enfin est-ce que la gauche sort par
exemple renforcer de cette séquence de
votre point de vue aujourd'hui c'est
trop tôt pour le dire aujourd'hui non
non parce que aujourd'hui la gauche en
tout cas politique
cette
il y a plus de gauche
money il y a plus de socialisme
quasiment plus de communistes on les
voit quand même très peu donc
aujourd'hui c'est Mélenchon qui qui je
pense pour l'instant ne tire pas profit
ne tiens pas profite cette affaire donc
pour l'instant il y a que des paroles si
on voulait
désigner un gagnant potentiel on
pourrait dire c'est le Front national
encore que
on a le sentiment mais il y a rien qui
permet de le mesurer c'est vrai que si
on regarde les partiels on peut pas dire
que le Front national le fasse des des
scores mirobolants donc dans les
sondages il y a quand même de plutôt une
progression dans les open donc si on
devait dire aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui
dans une opposition mais une opposition
qui reste plutôt modérée c'est plutôt le
Front national mais c'est trop tôt pour
le dire l'affaire est pas fini loin de
là donc aujourd'hui on va voir direct
conclusion c'est ça serait ça serait
imprudent en tout cas il y a un parti
qui souffre énormément en ce moment
c'est c'est les républicains
rien il ne peut faire qu'attendre peut
faire qu'attendre ils sont divisés ils
sont en capilota il semble aujourd'hui
on voit de disparition
ils sont traversés d'opposition mais ça
a toujours été le cas
au fond la seule chose qui puisse faire
c'est attendre l'élection présidentielle
qui dans une certaine mesure va les
compteurs à zéro il y aura plus Emmanuel
Macron donc si par miracle aujourd'hui
c'est pas le cas il émergeait en leur
sein un candidat alors est-ce que c'est
vous qui est-ce que c'est l'isnard
est-ce que c'est Bertrand est-ce que
c'est un autre on verra on peut imaginer
qu'à ce moment-là
faut se refasse la crise je crois qu'il
ne faut plus analyser la petite COP
française comme on le faisait autrefois
disant qu'elle se structure autour de
parti politique la politique française
se détermine ce cristallise autour de
l'élection présidentielle autour de
personnes on l'a vu le macronisme est né
avec Macron le macronisme Macron et
enfin avec le départ de Macron qui ne
veut pas se représenter et donc à ce
moment là on peut imaginer que quelque
chose se produise autour dedouard
Philippe autour de Bruno Le Maire autour
de vos quais la question c'est qui sera
face à Marine Le Pen parce que là pour
l'instant il semble à peu près à qui en
tout cas dans les dans les études quelle
sera la second tour la prochaine fois
mais je pense que ça serait là encore
trop tôt pour dire il y aura évidemment
pas de LR la question pas de savoir si
on est LR ou pas LR la question c'est
qui incarnera
en gros elle ne pignon modéré une centre
droit au centre gauche autour de thèses
relativement classique qui sont assez
proches au fond de celles de d'Emmanuel
Macron mais sans Emmanuel Macron est-ce
que justement dans ces conditions et
Emmanuel Macron hier dans son interview
à parler d'une coalition fin d'une offre
de coalition d'une main tendue est-ce
que la droite doit l'accepter plutôt
intéressant dans le capitaine du Titanic
qui a heurté le l'isberg vous dit est-ce
que vous voulez monter sur le bateau il
voulait pas avant ça m'étonnerait
qu'après le choc ils ont envie de monter
ça me paraîtrait très imprudent en tout
cas de me monter sur le ballon ça veut
pas dire que la droite ne doit pas
quand la question sera présente se
soutenir telle ou telle loi qui leur
paraîtrait juste c'est à dire c'est ce
qu'ils ont fait pour les deux tiers
d'entre eux quand même c'est pas tout à
fait rien sur les retraites ils sont
mais de là aller entrer dans une
coalition pour faire quoi avec Macron
mais mais qui par ailleurs dit il faut
aussi faire venir des socialistes donc
vous voyez aujourd'hui la droite c'est
un gouvernement Macron avec des ex
socialistes
enfin ça c'est le meilleur moyen de
faire pousser Mélenchon et le Pen de
part et d'autre donc moi pour moi il ne
monteront pas dans le dans l'affaire et
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui manuel Macron
nous dit il faut faire moins de loi et
on comprend pourquoi c'est qu'on voit
pas du tout comment il peut
l'affaire de l'immigration exemple on
voit pas bien maintenant ce qu'il veut
faire c'est à dire que des questions qui
revient souvent mais est-ce que il
fallait faire absolument
prioritairement cette réforme et ce qui
est pas des réformes plus urgente plus
importante comme l'accélération
nucléaire qui vient d'être adopté hier
et où l'immigration ou la loi sur
l'immigration qui va être reportique qui
est après coup on peut toujours dire ça
quand effectivement c'est vrai que de se
dire après coup bloqué parce que c'est
quand même ça potentiellement qui est en
train de se jouer en ce moment que
l'affaire des retraites passe ou ne
passe pas elle est quand même plutôt
partie pour passer la loi évoquée on
peut supposer c'est pas encore garanti
que le Conseil émotionnel la validera et
sauf énorme surprise qui ont
contraindrait explosion sociale qui
contrôlerait Macron à qui on peut
supposer que c'est toi va passer ce qui
se joue donc c'est l'incapacité la
paralysie dans les mois peut-être les
années qui viennent d'Emmanuel Macron
qui n'a plus de majorité et puis les
ressources politiques de d'agir c'est
vrai que quand on compare une loi sur
les retraites et ce qui peut d'ailleurs
la paraît Lisie pendant éventuellement
deux trois quatre ans c'est vrai qu'on
peut se dire c'était bien la peine mais
on dit toujours ça après
c'est sûr que si on ne fait rien on ne
peut pas on n'a pas d'ennuis mais en
même temps si on considère que cette
réforme était nécessaire il y a jamais
de bon moment et voilà ce qui est sûr
c'est que tout ça était mal préparé mal
vendu mal géré mal expliqué
et mal fait voilà est-ce que la
possibilité de se représenter de votre
point de vue
affaibli ou affaiblit pas Emmanuel
Macron évidemment l'affaiblit évidemment
cette réforme objectivement
et très très mauvaise pour l'autorité du
président qui fait son second mandat
parce que dès aujourd'hui on le voit
d'ailleurs à travers les déclarations
d'Édouard Philippe de Bruno Le Maire les
stratégies des uns des autres tout le
monde se dit bon bah de toute façon dans
3 ans il est plus là donc il faut
commencer à préparer la suite donc non
c'est pas bon du tout l'autre scénario
de se dire ah bah il a plus rien à
perdre donc comme il veut pas se
représenter il va y aller il va tout
faire c'est ça c'est des raisonnements
qu'on fait sur le papier c'est jamais
comme ça que ça se passe dans la vie on
a toujours quelque chose à perdre la
preuve il a perdre que que la rue lui
fasse retirer sa loi donc dire on a rien
à perdre ça n'est pas vrai et donc le
fait de ne pas pouvoir se représenter
c'est quelque chose qui vous affaiblit
considérablement c'est vrai aux
États-Unis c'est l'enfance
quelle sortie de crise actuellement pour
lui vous disiez bon il y a
plutôt aller plutôt partie pour pour
être adopté cette réforme bon vous allez
en parler tout à l'heure est-ce que un
référendum pour hypothétique que soit
cette solution serait une bonne sortie
de crise autant retirer la loi tout de
suite si c'est pour la référendum c'est
perdu
4,60 66 ou entre 65 70% des Français
cette position donc faire un référendum
c'est évidemment ce qu'on est la loi
autant la retirer c'est déjà bon bah ça
serait pas glorieux mais si la retire ça
veut dire qu'il peut plus rien faire
derrière
il n'a plus de c'est un désavetel que il
faudra trois ans pour se remettre et
puis ensuite restera la dernière année
qui sera la présidentielle et donc ça
sera fini donc la retirer ça serait une
catastrophe de pour l'action au
gouvernementale mais le référendum mon
avis ne n'est pas une solution tout ce
qui peut espérer c'est serré les dents
et pour pas dire autre chose en
attendant que ça passe et en espérant
que la rue va se lasser et que les gens
vont se résigner et que ce qui est
possible c'est vrai qu'une fois que la
loi sera votée une fois que le conseil
que Ciel l'aura validé si de la valide
on peut se dire dire que
berger et la CFDT même si aujourd'hui il
est très remonté très énervé contre le
président qui aurait pu peut-être éviter
de le provoquer hier bon il peut aussi
dire bon maintenant c'est fait c'est
fait on passe à autre chose donc on peut
imaginer une descente on peut imaginer
je dis pas que c'est garantie une
descente en sifflet de de de de de la
pression sociale et que bon bah dans
quelques semaines ça soit qu'un mauvais
souvenir restera les conséquences de ça
ce qui est la quasi impossibilité de
continuer à légiférer ce qui est
dramatique dans ce qui est toujours en
ce moment c'est que soit il a retire il
peut plus rien faire et soit s'il la
passe et à mon avis il peut plus faire
grand-chose non plus donc ce qui se joue
et c'est une très mauvaise nouvelle pour
le pays il y a vraiment pas de raison de
s'en réjouir parce qu'il est quand même
beaucoup de choses à faire dans ce pays
qu'on pense à l'hôpital qu'on pense
à l'école on pense à l'immigration vous
en parliez il y a mille choses qui se
serait nécessaire et là on se dit
qu'avec cette affaire
le gouvernement que ça finisse par
l'adoption de la loi ou par le retrait
je crois quand même mis plus sur
l'adoption en tant que faire autant
on voit mal ce qui pourrait faire
derrière ça va être un affaiblissement
considérable il a plus de il a plus de
majorité plus d'alliés possible et
trèsiblement isolé
dans l'échiquier politique et devant
l'opinion ça va être très très compliqué
merci beaucoup Alexis en tout cas on va
continuer à regarder ce qui se passe
observer ça et on va retourner sur le
sur le terrain notamment retrouver
Timothée délai Timothée où on est le où
en est le cortège
et bien le cortège figurez-vous n'est
pas encore arrivé sur la place de la
République que vous reconnaissez
derrière moi avec la la Marianne et donc
le cortège qui n'est pas encore arrivé
place de la République alors même que
cette place est déjà pleine de plein de
monde du monde donc qui attend l'arrivée
de des premiers du cortège syndical donc
voilà ça ça illustre bien c'est vrai la
forte influence qu'il y a cet après-midi
on entend à l'instant même de nombreux
slogans qui arrivent parce que le
cortège est en train d'arriver vraiment
sur cette place de la République il y a
également eu une une odeur de gaz
lacrymogène il y a quelques secondes sur
cette place on n'a pas vu de mouvement
de foule mais c'est vrai que voilà il y
a eu cette odeur de gaz donc peut-être y
a-t-il eu quelques échauffourés en tous
les cas le cortège est en train était en
train d'arriver voilà à l'instant même
sur ces images Julien Leclerc va vous va
vous montrer donc les premiers drapeaux
qui arrivent vous reconnaissez les
propos de la CGT le drapeau de SUD Rail
FSU voilà les les
manifestants qui sont en train d'arriver
vous apercevez également les services
d'ordre des forces de l'ordre avec ce
brassard rose que Julien est en train de
vous montrer vous voyez également le
brassard bleu ça c'est les services de
du syndicat une ça qui sont donc en tête
de ce de ce cortège pour évidemment
contenir tout éventuel débordements je
vous parlais à l'instant de cette odeur
de gaz lacrymogène c'est vrai que nous
avons senti cela même si il faut dire
aussi que l'ambiance pour l'instant est
malgré tout assez calme en tous les cas
assez classique avec donc c'est slogans
c'est pancartes il y a un élément
également assez nouveau par rapport aux
précédentes manifestations c'est vrai
qu'on avait l'habitude de voir
notamment vers l'avant du cortège des
populations tout de noir vêtus qui avait
visage assez fermé et c'est vrai que ça
donnait une ambiance un petit peu
spéciale pour l'instant en tous les cas
nous n'en n'avons pas croisé donc c'est
vrai que l'ambiance pour l'instant est
assez et assez bonne à l'image
d'ailleurs vous le voyez de ce nouvel
banderole qui est en train d'arriver
avec ses slogans qui sont qui sont
scandés par par les manifestants merci
Timothée et je vous suis très
reconnaissant je vous c'est tout à fait
gré de nous avoir évité le traditionnel
bon enfant je pour l'ambiance je salue
Arthur bijouta mais avant qu'on commence
à regarder un petit peu les différents
indicateurs on va essayer de retrouver
Vincent Rosemont Vincent qui se trouve
un autre endroit du cortège là encore on
voit la plus un cortège gauche radical
Vincent autour de vous quel est
l'ambiance
apparemment je ne sais pas s'il y a de
route du retour pour pour Vincent mais
dès qu'on a son retour on repart vers
le cortège et en tout cas l'endroit où
il se trouve bonjour Arthur Dujardin
bonjour Vincent bonjour à tous vous
travaillez au fil data justement on en
parlait tout à l'heure et vous avez des
nombreux déjà 350 000 personnes
à 14h sur toute le pays les premières
indications donc nous montre des grosses
mobilisations en région est-ce que ça se
confirme effectivement on peut déjà dire
qu'il y avait 412
000 manifestants aujourd'hui à 15h que
nous avons déjà comptabilisé ce sont
évidemment des chiffres des préfectures
des renseignements généraux de la police
qui qui compte les différents cortèges
et selon nos prévisions selon nos
estimations par rapport à la
mobilisation des dernières semaines par
rapport aux villes qui restent qui sont
à l'heure actuelle en train de défiler
on peut estimer que la mobilisation
devrait FLIR avec le million de
personnes dans la rue on est autour de
9905 dans nos prévisions pour pour le
chiffre France de ce soir vous répétez
le chiffre entre 990000 et 1,05 ml alors
entre 980 mille et 1,05 millions ce
serait au delà donc du de ce qui est de
ce qui est annoncé depuis depuis
ce midi et ce serait en tous les cas
un chiffre qui avoisinerait les les
scores qu'on a connus
des plus fortes mobilisations notamment
autour du 7 mars là on avait c'était
plus d'un million trois qui habitait
revendiqués par la CGT et 800 000 à
l'époque c'est tout à fait ça on est à
peu près on est légèrement en dessous
des deux plus grosses mobilisations 31
janvier et 7 mars 1,27 et 1,28 millions
de de manifestants selon le ministère de
l'Intérieur là on sera
nos estimations mais attention c'est
j'emploie le conditionnel et c'est
apprendre évidemment avec des pincettes
on peut toujours assister très grosse
mobilisation à Paris ou dans les villes
qui qui sont en train de défiler mais on
serait légèrement en dessous on serait
autour du million ce qui en ferait la
troisième plus grosse manifestation
depuis le début du mouvement on est à la
9e manifestation 9e journée de
mobilisation aujourd'hui on va revenir
sur les différents indicateurs en tous
les cas que vous que vous avez et que
vous traitez depuis le début de ces
cette mobilisation depuis le 19 janvier
une question quand même parce qu'il y a
un mouvement qui qui monte qui inquiète
les uns et qui en tout cas scruter de
près c'est celui des blocages des
raffineries et de l'essence ou est-ce
qu'on en est à l'heure où on se parle
alors aujourd'hui ce qu'on peut dire
c'est qu'il y a à peu près une station
sur 7 ça fait 15% qui est ce qu'on
appelle en difficulté pour nous en
difficulté ça veut dire que soit elle
n'a pas d'essence soit elle n'a pas de
diesel soit elle n'a pas les deux donc
15% au niveau national le mieux c'est de
rouler au 2
évidemment il n'y a pas de moteur
hybride donc ça n'existe pas là on est
pour l'instant à 15% au niveau national
ce qui est déjà assez élevé ce qui
rappelle le début de la pénurie
d'octobre dernier mais il y a de très
fortes disparités on a un carnet on a
quasiment zéro pour cent je pense au
Grand Est à la Lorraine à l'Alsace tout
va pour le mieux à la pompe alors que à
Nantes autour de Nantes on est à 55,2 %
les stations en difficulté en
Loire-Atlantique 49% en Ille-et-Vilaine
à Rennes donc c'est c'est assez
compliqué la situation est également
complexe à Marseille on avait plus de
50%, ça c'est un petit peu amélioré hier
mais ça reste à voir ce qui est
intéressant c'est que dans cette
géographie des blocages ça recoupe une
autre géographie mais peut-être que
c'est fortuit c'est celle de la
mobilisation quand on regarde les cartes
que vous établissez on s'aperçoit que il
y a une un record en Bretagne et natonie
à Nice alors question est-ce que c'est
un élément des explications pour ces
blocages et questions subsidiaire est-ce
que c'est le même c'est le même scénario
qu'on voit aujourd'hui c'est une
question aussi de technique et de tuyaux
on va dire puisque
les Bouches-du-Rhône sont principalement
touchées car le dépôt de fosse sur mer
et bloqué par la CGT énergie et ce dépôt
de force sur mer il faut savoir qu'il
alimente la région PACA l'est de
l'Occitanie et également la région
lyonnaise par le duc et on voit très
bien que ces régions sont les plus
touchées et c'est la même chose pour la
Bretagne pour Nantes etc c'est la
raffinerie de Donges qui est bloquée les
importations également qui viennent par
bateau par par pétrolier sont également
bloqués donc c'est c'est là c'est au
plus près en fait au plus près des
blocages que les que les que les
pénuries sont les plus importantes
si on revient maintenant à ces images à
la mobilisation actuellement quelle est
la géographie en dehors de la cette
place qui est la place de la République
à Paris effectivement qui est assez
large qui est assez qui est très grandes
et qui est donc on le voit pleine
la géographie de la mobilisation est-ce
que on voit un phénomène comparable à
celui que vous avez décrit notamment
pour la cinquième journée de
mobilisation si mes souvenirs sont bons
record en Bretagne à Tony à Nice
effectivement on voit exactement la même
chose aujourd'hui Nice 5200 manifestants
c'est c'est pas un chiffre faible mais
c'est pas non plus un record Nice qui
est pourtant une très grande
agglomération française
5200 c'est très très très peu il y a de
nombreuses villes moyennes de nombreuses
préfectures et sous-préfecture qui font
bien mieux alors qu'en Bretagne en
Bretagne par exemple vous avez Brest qui
a fait je crois quasiment 20
000 manifestants le record étant à 20500
donc qui s'est approché du record on a
on a également
Saint-Brieuc carrec qui a battu un
record ce matin donc évidemment on
constate à la fois plus de monde et plus
de lieux de rassemblement en Bretagne si
vous regardez la carte de figata vous
voyez de nombreux petits points en
Bretagne sur vraiment toute la Bretagne
et je dirais même tout le nord-ouest du
pays alors que dans le sud-est il y en a
beaucoup moins
le point intéressant c'est qu'à Nice des
manifestants ont essayé d'envahir
l'aéroport ce matin mais là encore on
voit que c'est vraiment une minorité
c'est une minorité en revanche est-ce
que c'est lui notamment la sociologie
des
Alpes-Maritimes je salue d'ailleurs
Nicole 06 qui est une internautes qui
est régulière et fidèle et qui justement
habite les Alpes-Maritimes mais
est-ce que la sociologie les
Alpes-Maritimes qui ne sociologique
quand même assez retraité qu'à Nice
explique aussi ce phénomène je pense
qu'il y a deux choses dans votre
question Vincent il y a à la fois le
fait que sur la Côte d'Azur les
Alpes-Maritimes on a une population de
retraités qui est plus importante
population donc qui est plus favorable à
l'autre été qui est plus favorable à la
réforme je crois que si la mémoire est
bonne c'est la seule catégorie ou
l'acceptation de la réforme est
supérieure à 50 %, je crois que c'est 60
% des retraités qui sont favorables à la
réforme on a une deuxième chose c'est
qu'il y a pas une tradition sociale bien
ancrée à Nice que que on pourrait avoir
en Bretagne on se souvient tous des du
mouvement des gilets jaunes on se
souvient également tous des bonnets
rouges des bonnets rouges
au tout début du quinquennat de François
Hollande en octobre 2013 qui avait
vraiment manifesté il y avait eu
beaucoup de violences à ce moment là
donc il y a également une différence de
tradition sociale précisément c'était
justement la question quelle leçon on
tire de cette géographie de la de la
mobilisation parce qu'il y a pas que la
Bretagne qui ont concerné on voit le
centre Val de Loire et l'Occitanie alors
l'Occitanie bon on peut à la rigueur il
y a toujours une tradition sociale c'est
des régions qui ont voté
très RN mais qui ont également à gauche
donc deux quand même deux quand même
courants qui sont contre la réforme mais
il y a aussi le centre Val de Loire le
centre Val de Loire oui plutôt centriste
oui on soulignera les rassemblements
importants encore 6500 à Châteauroux ce
matin 3700 à Guéret bon c'est dans la
Creuse c'est en nouvelle-aquitaine mais
c'est assez proche donc on il y a
vraiment une Châteauroux tradition
syndicale voilà industrie de défense il
y a également Vendée tradition des
vieilles terre de gauche voilà et il y a
également Vendôme ou Vendôme dans le
Loir-et-Cher vous avez 2500 2800
manifestants à chaque fois ce qui est
quand même assez important par rapport à
la population totale et oui l'Occitanie
on se souvient lors de la cinquième
journée de mobilisation le 16 février
les syndicats Laurent Berger Philippe
Martinez était parti manifester où à
Albi est-ce qu'il y a du monde
justement ça la question de jouer on n'a
pas encore les chiffres à Albi on a
encore on a on a quelques chiffres pour
pour vous pour appuyer sur l'Occitanie
on a Tarbes 7500 personnes qui bat son
record aujourd'hui on a peau également
16000 16000 personnes et puis un petit
peu plus au nord même beaucoup plus au
nord en Normandie Rouen abattu un record
aussi aujourd'hui comme comme Toulon et
Arles point intéressant Toulon encore un
record de mobilisation 12000 en revanche
vous citiez le Nord précisément on voit
sur ces cartes que le Nord est moins
mobilisé alors que par exemple le Nord
le Pas-de-Calais sont les passions
rassemblement national très populaires à
quoi on attribue cette moindre
mobilisation est-ce que c'est dû aussi
être moindre syndicalisation dans ces
dans ces régions là également on tout le
monde se souvient tout le monde sait
qu'il y a une tradition de mineur de
sidérurgie très importante le mineur
plus dans le nord de sidérurgie plus
vers la Lorraine on se souvient de tout
ça mais il y a également à la fois un
fort une forte abstention dans ces
régions et je me souviens d'une
interview avec Jérôme Fourquet qui me
disait les gens certes sont contre la
réforme des retraites mais ils se disent
maintenant à quoi bon à quoi bon allez
voter et à quoi bon aller manifester
donc on peut on pourrait expliquer ça
par une forme de désintérêt de
désaffiliation de de le terme le terme
aquabon résume bien la le sentiment le
sentiment majoritaire dans ces régions
images en ce moment à Paris de la
manifestation effectivement avec
beaucoup d'affluence une ambiance très
calme ce que vous ne voyez pas sur ces
images peut-être avec ces
fumigènes mais
hormis ce fumigène une ambiance très
calme ça veut pas dire d'ailleurs que le
fait qu'il est fumigène ne soit pas
calme c'est un une figure imposée d'un
certain nombre de manifestations en
revanche notre confrère Armory coûte en
C qui se trouve sur place pour le live
texte du Figaro qui est au-dessus de ce
player
nous indique quelques dégradations déjà
en tête de cortège avec des vitres qui
sont cassées on va continuer de suivre
ça vous signaler également Arthur dans
cette carte qui fait état des
mobilisations qu'il y a aujourd'hui de
nouvelles mobilisations effectivement
alors il y a de nouvelles mobilisations
à la fois car la dernière journée de de
grève le mercredi 15 mars avait été
assez peu suivi c'était la troisième en
huit jours il y avait le mardi 7 le
samedi 11 puis ensuite le mercredi 15
donc il y avait une forme
d'essoufflement ça fait quand même
beaucoup de manifestations donc c'est ce
qui explique c'est c'est point bleus
c'est nouveau rassemblement on les voit
pas il faut regarder sur regarder pour
l'instant vous restez avec nous y
compris surtout si vous êtes sur Youtube
et on vous salue merci beaucoup de nous
suivre nombreux et donc toujours ces
points bleus mais vous avez quand même
certains certaines villes je pense à
Cluny en Saône-et-Loire ça m'a ou Vernon
dans leur ce matin où il y avait
absolument pas eu de manifestations
pendant les 8 premiers premiers jours de
mobilisation et aujourd'hui vous aviez
900 personnes à vers nom 200 inclus
voilà donc on a encore des petits points
des nouveaux rassemblements de manière
totalement étonnante
est-ce que
les grandes villes mobilisent plus
les grandes villes pour le moment c'est
assez contrasté elle mobilise plus que
le 15 mars c'est pour ça que vous voyez
dans un autre un papier des grands ronds
verts parce que c'est super la
mobilisation est supérieure au 15 mars
mais on n'a pas non plus on les voit pas
sur les grandes métropoles on n'a pas
non plus un record Marseille fait 16000
Marseille avait fait 40000 à un moment
dans la manifestation dans les
précédentes manifestations
Orléans avec dépassé les 10000
aujourd'hui il ne passe pas ce cap
pareil pour tour qui est bloqué à 9500
alors qu'ils avaient fait 14000 donc
dans les grandes dans les 20 plus
grandes métropoles
qu'on met sur cette carte il y a
certains regains de mobilisation mais
les records ne sont pas battus les
records sont plus battus par par Pau par
Hal par ou en partant on va on va
continuer d'en parler merci beaucoup
Arthur vous vous restez pour l'instant
avec nous on va retourner voir Timothée
d'Hélène qui se trouve dans le cortège
et qui se trouve même avec un
manifestant à Timothée c'est à vous
absolument Vincent avec un manifestant
adhérent à la CGT adhérent en partie
commise vous me disiez à l'instant
depuis les années 60 ça fait longtemps
vous en avez 70
%. c'est plutôt 70 alors est-ce que vous
constatez quelles sont les différences
entre la manifestation la mobilisation
contre la réforme des retraites en 2022
et les autres mouvements de mobilisation
que auquel vous avez vu participer aussi
68 alors est-ce que vous voyez les
différences par rapport peut-être pas 68
mais par rapport peut-être à 95 à 95 oui
mais 95 c'était moi moi général que là
c'est général quand même aujourd'hui
quels sont vos attentes sur cette
mobilisation
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est ces
crédible c'est possible que Emmanuel
Macron retire c'est pas c'est pas une
réforme des retraites pour sauver les
retraites c'est une réforme financière
c'est pas la même chose c'est une
réforme demandée par le MEDEF et
l'Europe et qui fait les frais de cette
réforme c'est les salariés c'est pas
c'est pas les copains
il y a de l'argent en France lui quand
on quand on écoute Emmanuel Macron hier
par exemple lors de cette interview à
France 2 à TF1 il me dit c'est très fort
c'était une nécessité mais ça ne me fait
pas plaisir pour autant de la faire
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez un faux cul
un faux cul parce qu'il sait très bien
que c'est pas une nécessité c'est parce
que il y a des il y a des commandes des
sociétés d'assurance qui veulent
récupérer l'argent des retraites par les
pour faire des retraites par comment
par capitalisation et ça c'est un faux
cul et il le dit pas mais il est là pour
ça parce qu'il a pas été élu il a jamais
été élu pour faire une réforme des
retraites il a été élu contre Le Pen
c'est pas la même chose vous dites
qu'Emmanuel Macron n'a pas été élu sur
son programme et qu'il a été élu sur le
rejet de Marine Le Pen il fait 20 22 23
% au premier tour on peut pas dire qu'il
a été élu sur son programme en tous les
cas on peut pas lui reprocher le mérite
de la clarté il avait dit qu'il ferait
cette réforme
il l'avait enlevé déjà il y a avant le
covid et là il la remet il revient non
non c'est il a dit pendant sa campagne
qu'il réformerait les retraites oui oui
mais il a pas dit ce qu'il mettait
dedans c'est un scandale de d'envoyer
les anciens travailler jusqu'à 64 ans ça
se voit c'est des mecs en cravate et en
col blanc qui décide ce que ceux qui
sont en bas les ceux qui ont applaudis
pendant le covid
qu'est-ce qu'on leur fait on leur donne
deux ans de plus hein
c'est une panne de c'est une panne
capitale ça alors vous êtes vous-même
déjà à la retraite comme vous me le
disiez
60 ans alors parti à 60 ans et donc vous
n'êtes pas directement concernés par
cette réforme pourquoi avez-vous décidé
malgré tout de venir dans la rue
aujourd'hui on est confronté à la
réforme parce que ce qui dit pas c'est
qu'ils vont recalculer tous les toutes
les pensions de retraite et ça il le dit
pas c'est c'est dans le projet de loi ça
a été étudié il va il veut recalculer de
l'argent il y en a il peut il peut
sauver les retraites il est il récupère
les 100 milliards d'évasion fiscale
annuelle et il sauve les retraites alors
vous êtes venus exprès aujourd'hui pour
cette pour cette manifestation vous me
disiez que vous avez pris le bus exprès
d'où venez-vous et pourquoi avez-vous
fait un test
parce que c'est nécessaire qui est du
monde ici aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
êtes prêts à manifester de nouveau
combien de temps peut durer le mouvement
selon bah je sais pas parce que là
dès que le Conseil constitutionnel
parce que vous êtes au courant que le
riz a été a été déposé
donc
normalement il doit abandonner sa
retraite vous ce que vous espérez c'est
un réforme un référendum pardon
d'initiative oui c'est dans un premier
temps parce que le référendum
d'initiative populaire va demander à ce
qu'il y a un vote sur les retraites
après
mais pendant ce temps-là pendant 9 mois
il peut pas promulguer sa retraite un
dernier mot sur le sur le fond de la
réforme et qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
vous dites vous vous pensez qu'il n'est
pas possible de travailler au-delà de 62
ans vous avez déjà vous êtes déjà monté
sur des gestes d'âge vous êtes alors
quand tu entends le gouvernement qui
nous dit la police ils peuvent pas ils
peuvent pas travailler plus de 59 ans et
les autres il faudrait qu'ils
travaillent à 64 ans il se foutent du
monde ça s'appelle se du monde
les policiers ils font pas un boulot
aussi pénible
l'argument d'Emmanuel Macron est du
gouvernement c'est de dire on vit plus
vieux donc on doit travailler plus
longtemps qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
ça c'est un faux argument pourquoi parce
que les salariés les salariés vivent
dis-en de moins que les cadres et ça il
le dit pas et c'est c'est tout cela qui
vont prendre une claque ça veut dire que
selon vous il faut prendre en compte la
pénibilité c'est ça mais pas que la
pénibilité faut prendre c'est reconnu
par l'Europe que les salariés vivent en
moins qu'un cadre ou qu'un
ah lui il se fatigue pas hein en colle
blanc machin si dans sa chaise toute la
journée euh là il va recevoir là il y a
des millions qui vont être dépensés pour
recevoir le le dictateur d'Angleterre
Charles hein parce que ça devrait même
plus exister à l'époque il reçoit ça au
château de Versailles en plus voilà
Vincent pour cette réaction de ce
manifestant qui est donc en colère comme
il vient de le dire et qui donc continue
de battre le pavé jusqu'à la place de
l'Opéra et bien merci beaucoup Timothée
effectivement on l'a entendu oui on est
plus très bien très loin d'ailleurs du
Figaro apparemment sur ces images et on
savait pas d'où il venait mais il vient
effectivement de Trappes dans les
Yvelines bonjour jacolivier Martin
bonjour Vincent vous êtes le directeur
du de la rédaction du Figaro.fr
directeur adjoint de la rédaction du
Figaro et vous avez été vous êtes le
directeur éditorial du Big Bang
également de l'économie le Big Bang de
la santé qui sont deux grands événements
du Figaro de un événement économique et
vous êtes également un grand observateur
des innovations et c'est vous dire quand
même toutes les raisons et que j'ai de
me réjouir de vous avoir honoré de vous
avoir
à vos côtés
peut-être question
c'est une vraie forme qui a été voulue
par le MEDEF cette réforme des retraites
non absolument pas bon il y a le
pdforme même au début donc non c'est
alors le président dit que c'était une
réforme nécessaire voilà donc nécessaire
pour des raisons financières alors on
peut avoir calculer comme on veut mais
il y a quand même une équation
financière à un moment ou un autre dans
un pays qui a 3000 milliards de dettes
même si c'est pour économiser comme on
dit que 13 milliards et bah 13 milliards
c'est déjà 13 milliards de moins je veux
pas faire de mauvais esprits mais notre
excellent confrère Jean-Pierre Robin qui
n'est pas un militant CGT non absolument
que c'était une réforme qui visait aussi
à faire plaisir au marché et on l'a
quand même dit également aux instances
européennes et Bruxelles Oise alors bon
il faut il faut il faut décrypter les
propos de Jean-Pierre Robin qui est un
de mes confrères que je respecte
absolument faire plaisir au marché ça
peut être une des conséquences comment
on pourrait expliquer ça c'est à dire
que une réforme comme celle des
retraites ça vise à améliorer
l'équilibre des finances publiques
ça vise puisqu'on travaille un peu plus
à ajouter un peu de travail dans la
France qui est un pays angle compétition
internationale avec d'autres pays
d'autres entreprises qui sont partout
présentes donc tout ce qui peut
améliorer
la situation effectivement financière de
nos comptes publics ou en tout cas
évitez leur dégradation et tout ce qui
peut améliorer la compétitivité
effectivement ça peut plaisir au marché
puisque les marchés sur les marchés
quand on entend marcher il y a deux
types de marchés il y a le marché action
où les entreprises sont cotées c'est là
où on peut les investisseurs vont
décider de miser sur une entreprise ou
pas et donc là effectivement il y a un
ange de compétitivité et puis il y a
aussi l'inquiétude ou pas des marchés
vis-à-vis des finances publiques quand
la dette est monumentale quand les
déficits de se creusent oui ça peut
susciter d'inquiétude donc quand on tend
à corriger même marginalement ça on peut
limiter l'inquiétude effectivement des
marchés financiers une question qui est
donnée par une internaute ABP qui dit
deux grands il y a deux grands absents
de ces débats c'est la démographie donc
la natalité et le travail est-ce que
c'est le travail aujourd'hui qui est
rémunéré ou la capacité à générer du
cash vous avez moins de 20 minutes à
répondre à cette question monsieur le
directeur éditorial de Big Bang de
l'économie non mais je pense que
effectivement c'est c'est le c'est le
travail il faut pas il faut pas se
tromper on est dans une dans une réforme
alors je sais pas comment vous allez me
relancer mais enfin on est dans une
réforme
on est dans une réforme qui vise à
équilibrer un système des retraites une
réforme qui tient compte la démographie
j'entendais le manifestant tout à
l'heure la démocratie c'est une réalité
pendant très longtemps on a gagné un
trimestre de vie par année c'est plus
tout à fait le cas mais enfin on est
plus dans une situation
identique à celle de 1980 quand François
Mitterrand a passé d'un coup la retraite
de 65 à 60 ans la démographie a
considérablement évolué donc une réponse
démographique une réponse pour le
travail c'est ce que je dis aussi le le
travail est un peu plus je veux juste je
sais plus qui a dit ça mais je fais à
peu près sûr que c'est vrai que en 2030
on sera toujours le pays d'Europe où on
prendra en moyenne la retraite le plus
tôt donc on n'est pas dans un pays où ça
va devenir
faire du travail bon quand même pas
exagérer donc ça va rajouter peut-être
un peu de travail il y a plein de gens
qui vont sont satisfaire faut pas non
plus toujours ne regarder il y a des
gens où c'est difficile on a de la
pénibilité il y a des mesures
d'accompagnement qui a été mises en
place mais d'une certaine manière on
tient compte c'est une réforme aussi
effectivement pour ajouter un peu de
travail dans une France qui est sur ce
sujet là un peu à la traîne de ces
grands compétiteurs en tout cas ce qui
affiche en Europe et ailleurs dans les
pays occidentaux la plus forte
croissance je reprends la question à
poser cette internaute et qui dit mais
on veut justement repousser encore là je
la retraite je traduis mais est-ce que
le problème enfin il n'est pas à la base
c'est que on veut faire des réformes des
retraites sans quand même relancer faire
de relance une politique démographique
et d'une politique de natalité est-ce
que là il y a pas un problème parce que
on prend pas on traite pas plutôt les
symptômes et on s'attaque pas aux causes
alors autant on peut agir sur l'âge
légal des départs en retraite autant
c'est assez complexe d'augmenter le taux
de natalité en France faire des mesures
on n'est pas obligé de faire les mesures
de François Hollande qui ont mis sous
condition de ressources les allocations
familiales oui on peut on a une
politique on pourrait la relancer
effectivement elle est pas non plus
c'est pas on n'est pas non plus là
encore
on est un des pays d'Europe il y a une
qui a toujours l'une des politiques de
natalité la plus favorable c'est pas non
plus un hasard si le tonalité est en
France est supérieur à ceux d'autres
pays notamment les pays d'Europe du Sud
qui n'ont pas ces
politique de natalité aussi
incitative que que ce qu'on a en France
alors ceux-là étant
l'immigration c'est indiscutable et
l'immigration
beaucoup en France indiscutablement mais
oui je vous suis on pourrait relancer la
qualité après la qualité les enfants de
2023 le cotiserons pas avant 2050
probablement
c'est positif bien sûr oui c'est positif
si on pouvait relancer la natalité c'est
pas non plus que des mesures financières
c'est aussi l'évolution d'une société
voilà et c'est je pense qu'il faut tenir
compte de la situation actuelle si si la
natalité s'améliore dans les 15 ou 20
ans qui viennent et bien on reverra
probablement notre stratégie en matière
d'âge de départ en retraite on va faire
un petit tour par la place de la
Bastille c'est enfin pas à la place de
la bassine mais entre Bastille et opéra
retrouvé Vincent Rozon comment se passe
l'ambiance où vous vous trouvez et
d'ailleurs vous allez nous indiquer où
trouver exactement
alors déjà je me trouve quasiment au
même endroit qu'au début de cette
manifestation c'est à dire un peu plus
loin que la place de la Bastille qui est
au fond de cette cette boucle de
boulevard le boulevard Beaumarchais et
l'ambiance est assez calme beaucoup de
chants et surtout énormément par rapport
aux autres manifs je trouve énormément
de jeunes qui sont présents aujourd'hui
on le sait de nombreux lycées étaient
bloqué ce matin il y a en tout cas
énormément de jeunes dans cette
manifestation aujourd'hui par rapport
aux autres
aux autres manifestations qu'il y avait
eu jusque là mais vous voyez en tout cas
beaucoup de monde le cortège est déjà
arrivé en plus réplique moi je suis à
droite je suis quasiment au point de
départ en fait et il y a encore beaucoup
beaucoup de monde qui arrive puisque
tout au fond là-bas s'il y a la place de
la Bastille mais il y a encore des
camions de la CGT et de la FO Force
Ouvrière
merci beaucoup Vincent justement
jacolivier votre regard sur la
mobilisation de ce jour qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui vous fera et qu'est-ce qui
vous frappe d'ailleurs depuis le début
du mouvement alors un discutablement la
motivation la mobilisation est très
forte le projet était de la semaine
dernière il y aura peut-être entre 500
et 1 million de personnes dans les rues
c'est quelque chose de très significatif
c'est-à-dire que la colère ou le nom à
cette réforme aujourd'hui ne diminue pas
il y a une vraie mobilisation c'est une
stratégie qui politiquement
à un sens quand même assez fort c'est
vraiment le signe que les Français n'en
veulent pas c'est aussi le moyen avec
les grèves dont on va peut-être parler
qui sont en train de se multiplier de
tenter de faire plier le gouvernement de
le pousser à
retirer son projet c'est compliqué
puisque la loi est aujourd'hui adoptée
mais en tout cas ces politiquesment
extrêmement instructif ça montre qui a
cette colère et profonde et la grande
interrogation aujourd'hui c'est
finalement jusqu'où ça peut monter
et à partir de quel moment le
gouvernement ne va plus pouvoir entre
guillemets rester droit dans ses bottes
on a quand même pas vu alors j'ai pas
tous les souvenirs de l'après 95 je suis
pas sûr qu'on avait les manifestations
de ce type après l'adoption de la loi
sur les retraites
parce que j'ai une question à vous poser
par rapport à ça 2010
mais même de 2010 ou encore de 1995 1995
elle est fort mobilisations 2010 il y
avait des fortes mobilisation aussi mais
en 1995 on était les transports étaient
bloqués l'île de France qui était quand
même qui est poumon économique du pays à
l'arrêt les jeunes ne peuvent pas
comprendre mais à l'époque on comptait
beaucoup sur la poste il y avait pas les
emails
sauf si on était en voiture mais au prix
d'un embouteillage monstres
est-ce que justement le visage de la
crise n'a pas muté tout à l'heure
Jean-Yves Guérin disait mais finalement
il y a il y a beaucoup de grévistes dans
les transports il y en a moins qu'au
début du mouvement on continue de
finalement de pouvoir utiliser les
transports donc le grand blocage auquel
on a été auquel les syndicats auxquels
les forces politiques de gauche ont
appelé pour le 7 mars et appelle encore
aujourd'hui
lieu tant que ça par contre on a des
choses un peu plus sportadiques est-ce
que finalement le visage de la de ce
genre de crise n'a pas muté oui je pense
qu'il ressemble pas ce qu'on voit là
enfin en tout cas elle ne ressent pas au
blocage qu'on ait pu connaître en 95 ça
s'est absolument sûr en revanche on voit
tous les soirs des mobilisations dans
les villes de groupuscules de
manifestants spontanés assez
incontrôlable
et pas c'est pas très organisé qui sont
capables de
montrer leur accès de colère brûler les
poubelles surtout dans les villes où
elles ne sont pas ramassées et il y a
peut-être quelque chose qui ressemble un
petit peu à ce qu'on avait
vu avec la montée en puissance des
gilets jaunes c'est à dire une colère
spontanée qui pourrait peut-être ça
serait intéressant de voir ce qui va se
passer le week-end prochain qui pourrait
commencer à cristalliser les Français
et d'être un accès de colère je ne le
compare pas à 95 qui était vraiment un
grand blocage mais je pense qu'il y a
une mèche qui pourrait extrait qui est
déjà assez incandescente et qui pourrait
éventuellement
nous mener dans un forme d'inconnu et
quand on l'a vu il y a pas si longtemps
avec les gilets jaunes quand le
mouvement quand ses colères gagnent les
ronds-points aujourd'hui elles gagnent
les centres-villes mais c'est peut-être
ça le nouveau mouvement qui est en train
de s'installer alors là on rentre dans
une autre séquence où effectivement
d'un point de vue classique le
gouvernement et Emmanuel Macron ne
pourront pas puisqu'ils ont connu pour
en tout cas Macron les gilets jaunes ne
pas être extrêmement prudent pour
essayer d'éteindre ce genre d'incendie
question au directeur éditorial du Big
Bang c'est une question de incerter et
qui envoyait ça à l'emporte-pièce mais
justement je me suis dit en voyant ce
commentaire que j'allais vous poser la
question il dit mais toute façon vous
pouvez faire
toutes les toutes les manifestations les
grèves que vous voulez apparemment il
est favorable à la réforme des retraites
de toute façon les robots vont un jour
tous nous remplacer et donc la retraite
à 62 à 64 ans
alors moi c'est un sujet pour lequel sur
lequel je pourrais parler très longtemps
passionne mais vous êtes passionnant
quand vous en parlez donc c'est pour ça
absolument
bon alors il y a deux façons de voir les
choses on peut effectivement regarder
l'explosion des innovations
technologiques sur tous les métiers j'ai
fait une petite parenthèse ou arrêterez
parce que vous savez que je suis bavard
sur ces sujets là on te fait 150 ans que
on a mis en place des robots en tout cas
des outils qui ont aidé à décupler la
force physique pour des travaux qui
étaient des travaux plutôt jusque là qui
nécessitaient une énergie assez physique
aujourd'hui avec l'intelligence
artificielle on a parlé du phénomène
tchat j'ai pété et le GPT 4 qui vient de
sortir la semaine dernière là on
commence à avoir des sortes de d'aide
dans le travail intellectuel donc on a
des outils de travail pour nous aider à
décupler notre force physique et puis
aujourd'hui on commence à avoir des
outils qui nous aident et qui peuvent
remplacer une partie des tâches qui
n'étaient pas des tâches de ce qui était
des tâches de colle blanche en quelque
sorte donc oui ça ça va provoquer ça va
provoquer des substitutions de métiers
est-ce que le développement
technologique va permettre comme ça a
été le cas au début du 20e siècle il y a
des métiers qui ont disparu avec le les
machines mais il y a d'autres activités
qui sont développées qui ont permis de
créer beaucoup d'emplois jusque là on a
toujours eu un peu ce phénomène un peu
de substitution des métiers
disparaissent et de nouveau apparaissent
là c'est la grande inconnue c'est
l'immense inconnu alors sur les
retraites oui alors c'est l'autre c'est
l'autre côté alors est-ce que est-ce que
le travail en tant que tel est attaqué
par les nouvelles technologies ou en
tout cas est-ce qu'il y a on rentre sur
un phénomène de remplacement moi je
pense que si on se projette à 20 ou 30
ans moi je discutais encore avec un
prospectiviste pas plus tard qu'hier sur
ce sujet qui parlait d'une société
d'abondance en disant c'est
extraordinaire toutes les machines sont
intelligence artificielle ou les
machines les robots vont remplacer il y
aura une abondance de création de valeur
tout le monde sera riche et personne de
travaillera je sais pas si on va
là-dessus moi je pense qu'on y va pas
parce que c'est c'est probablement que
l'individu
elle ne peut pas même si j'ai envie de
prendre pour certains d'entre eux la
retraite assez tôt ne peut pas vivre de
loisirs uniquement bon je ne le crois
pas mais c'est une vraie question il y a
une vraie question technologique dans 30
ou 40 ans effectivement moi je pense que
on sera plus dans la même organisation
du travail
ça je le crois ça mériterait un débat de
mettre des gens face de nous qui ne
partage peut-être pas mais je crois que
c'est une réalité moi je crois que la
robotisation associée à l'intelligence
artificielle et l'intelligence
artificielle même sur des tâches
d'activité aujourd'hui du tertiaire ça
va modifier l'organisation du travail et
probablement le nombre
de postes disponibles si on n'est pas
capable d'en créer une nouvelle
est-ce que je voulais vous poser une
question alors là qui n'a plus rien à
voir mais
vendredi là pardon lundi prochain est
prévu le début de la visite du roi
Charles III en France première visite
d'État pour lui et en dehors de la du
Royaume-Uni
est-ce qu'il y a pas de changement de
prévu pour la visite quand on voit
toutes les situations blocages quand on
voit effectivement les les le
ressentiment qui a dans la dans la rue
est-ce que c'est bien raisonnable
je ne sais pas ce que je pense c'est que
si s'il y a une cristallisation très
forte ce week-end ça va un peu ternir
cette visite je voyais la presse
anglo-saxonne hier quelques médias qui
s'interrogeaient sur l'opportunité de
faire cette visite l'autre discussion
depuis ce matin de cette direction
est-ce qu'il faut faire pour la
symbolique ce grand dîner d'État à
Versailles et on parle de le rapatrier
éventuellement à l'Elysée ce qui
correspond plus
est pas très bonne je pense que ça va
donner ce qui moi ce qui me nave je vais
vous dire très franchement Vincent
skinnave c'est que les projecteurs
d'Europe entière et peut-être des
États-Unis vont se braquer lors de de
cette visite sur la France la France des
poubelles se Paris qui est quand même
totalement défiguré c'est c'est
franchement une honte aujourd'hui le
spectacle qu'on peut voir à Paris ça va
encore produire une image extrêmement
négative de notre pays
et ça je le regrette profondément la
Tour Eiffel le château de Versailles
l'Arc de Triomphe sont fermés
aujourd'hui là encore est-ce que il peut
y avoir un risque pour l'attractivité de
la France
à court terme dans les 48 heures ou 72
heures oui il y a pas de doute ça va pas
faciliter les choses non je crois pas la
chance en France c'est qu'on on a
souvent des mobilisations sociales donc
on sait qu'après ça se remet assez vite
dans l'ordre et puis les Français sont
quand même un peu plus merveilleux
accueillants ce pays est extraordinaire
vous avez parlé de monuments qui sont
exceptionnels Paris la plus belle ville
du monde surtout quand elle est propre
c'est moi le cas aujourd'hui
moi j'ai pas de doute que non non ça
on à Paris y compris l'ensemble des du
monde entier non j'ai pas je garde
encore une minute j'envoie quand même
retrouver Timothée délai ça standait un
peu autour de vous Timothée
oui c'est vrai qu'il y a quelques scènes
de tension éparses là nous nous trouvons
au niveau de la Porte Saint-Martin et
voilà la fumée qui vient de se dissiper
donc vous n'allez pas bien la voir sur
ces images filmées par Julia Leclerc
quelques quelques petits feux en fait
alors parfois des feux de poubelles
parfois autre chose c'est vrai que là il
y a eu une grosse fumée noire pendant de
longues minutes et les pompiers qui sont
intervenus avec du gaz carbonique et qui
ont éteint le feu qui était qui était
allumé à une centaine de mètres de nous
difficile pour moi de vous dire ce qui
était en train de cramer en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'il y a quelques
scènes de tension épars je vous parlais
tout à l'heure de ces jeunes tout de
noir vêtus que l'on trouve parfois en
tête de cortège nous en avons croisé
quelques-uns donc voilà quelques scènes
de tourner par des slogans anti
capitalistes et puis également une
vitrine d'un de d'un commerce qui qui a
été endommagée un MacDonald's également
que nous avons dont nous avons vu qu'il
a été détérioré donc voilà quelques
petites scènes de tension même si tout
reste quand même tout à fait maîtrisé
ici et vous le voyez le cortège qui est
en tous les cas vraiment très rempli
Julien va vous montrer donc là ce que
vous voyez au fond ce boulevard c'est la
place de la République où nous nous
trouvions tout à l'heure et donc vous
voyez ce boulevard Saint-Michel qui est
noir de monde on va avancer un petit peu
vous montrer voilà le boulevard
Saint-Michel ici vous voyez la porte
Saint-Michel pardon la Porte
Saint-Martin le boulevard Saint-Martin
je voulais voir Saint-Michel
Saint-Martin la Porte Saint-Martin ici
et derrière le boulevard Saint-Denis qui
lui aussi est noir de monde et qui
arrive ensuite sur le boulevard
Poissonnière donc un cortège qui s'étale
sur de sur de très longs de très longs
de plusieurs centaines de mètres donc
voilà énormément de monde en tous les
cas cet après-midi dans les dans les
rues de la capitale
merci beaucoup Timothée pour ces
précisions bah on va continuer à suivre
bien entendu la situation et vous prenez
bien entendu bien soin de VOUS pas de
risque inutile vous le connaissez la
consigne du relecte en chef on a une
idée de de l'impact sur l'économie de
ces de ces de ces jours de grève de ces
dégradations
c'est pas des moi j'ai pas le chiffre
exact mais c'est non c'est pas c'est
absolument pas énorme aujourd'hui il
faut bien quand même comprendre que
l'essentiel des gens qui sont en grève
ce sont des gens du public les
entreprises
assez il y a très très peu de grève et
de mobilisation donc l'économie
française tourne on se déplace il y a
même s'il y a des risques de pénurie qui
sont croissants et là ça aura
véritablement un impact sur l'économie
aujourd'hui on a on peut accéder
au carburant il n'y a pas de coupure
d'électricité massive non il y a une
France nombreuse qui travaille en ce
moment alors le commerce là j'entendais
dans les restaurants les cafés dans les
villes dans les centres-villes oui là il
y a un impact indiscutable et ça
regrettable mais on peut pas parler
d'une France aujourd'hui à l'arrêt ça
serait excessif de dire ça ce n'est pas
le cas oui effectivement c'est la même
l'un des l'un des phénomènes sur depuis
le début de ce mouvement on pensait
notamment le 7 mars qu'on aurait un
blocage et un rideau de fer général
devant le l'économie française et c'est
pas c'est pas le cas non il y a une
autre question qui est posée et ça
recoupe avec ce qu'on se disait tout à
l'heure sur
l'image de la France l'image
internationale de la France c'est ce que
ça présage pour les pour les pour les
Jeux Olympiques là c'est vrai c'est une
inquiétude qui monte notamment dans le
dans le chat mais qui en vient de façon
façon récurrente
quand on voit la façon dont sont gérés
les la faire les poubelles à Paris où
les également
la question du maintien de l'ordre là il
y a des vrais défis en tous les cas qui
sont posés
de maintien de l'ordre ça c'est
absolument certain sur les mobilisations
les manifestations la colère des
Français moi j'ose croire que les Jeux
Olympiques c'est une fête c'est une fête
pour tout le monde une magnifique fête
sportive une magnifique une magnifique
fête qui réunit le monde entier et je
pense que la France aura plutôt le cœur
à vouloir observer regarder présenter
une belle image de la France lors de ces
Jeux Olympiques j'ajoute alors il y aura
peut-être des tentatives parce que c'est
arrivé sur d'autres manifestations
sportives les tentatives de blocage en
tout cas je suis à peu près certain
c'est que si il y a une grève des
poubelles que Anne Hidalgo
réquisitionnera à toute vitesse pour
montrer un pari propre parce que là
quand même c'est une action militante
qui est menée pourtant pour ne en tout
cas ne rien faire pour améliorer la
situation je peux vous dire premier Jeux
Olympiques vu sa mobilisation depuis
quelques années elle fera tout pour que
ce soit ramassé et propre en tout cas on
prend les paris je reviendrai
effectivement un Hidalgo c'était
effectivement
c'était investi auprès de
Los Angeles d'ailleurs pour pour que
chacun ait une part du gâteau olympique
et donc à Paris en 2024 moi j'avais
encore une question qui alors qu'il y a
une autre question qui se positionne sur
sur le chat c'est à quoi sert de
travailler
une question mais justement quand on se
pose la question effectivement quand on
voit on voit les perspectives
technologiques que vous avez décrites
toute seule tout à l'heure et que on
voit effectivement enfin c'est c'est
quand même c'est une question qui qui
sont les questions quand même qui sont
soulevées au-delà de l'écume des
événements qui sont posés entre quand on
voit par une partie de la gauche qui
aujourd'hui parle de la semaine de la
semaine des quatre jours certains de
revenir à 32 heures et effectivement
avec les innovations technologiques et
puis quand même quand on voit que
souvent les les rémunérations rémunèrent
plus souvent le les placements parvient
sur le débat capital travail mais
que souvent le travail en tant que tel
ouais là aussi il faut être il faut être
assez nuancer j'ai envie de dire quand
on voit que
c'est qui qui se met à travailler
puisqu'il se fait des tâches il remplace
en partie les activités humaines j'ai
envie de dire du capital c'est le
capital qui se met au travail sans
mauvais jeu de mots une fois qu'on a dit
ça
non le derrière le capital c'est c'est
l'investissement et derrière
l'investissement c'est la création de
travail donc c'est trop caricatural
d'opposer capital et travail c'est plus
possible aujourd'hui c'est en tout cas
il y a une relation extrêmement étroite
entre le capital et le travail c'est
voilà il faut arrêter toujours de
simplifier à outrance
la situation
je terminerai par cette relance c'est
des questions qui étaient posées c'est
est-ce que finalement c'est le travail
aujourd'hui qui est rémunéré ou bien
dans le travail la capacité à faire
générer du cash c'est ça la question non
je crois pas je pense que il y a des
actionnaires qui ont un objectif
de générer des profits il y a le
président Macron là exprimé hier
il y a une tentation avec notamment les
rachats d'actions de distribuer de
l'argent aux actionnaires alors sur
votre positif qui va être réinvesti
parce que l'actionnaire fait le
réinvestir mais ou sinon qui peut être
effectivement épargné et là c'est pas
forcément positif mais le capitalisme ce
n'est pas que cela l'essentiel des
profits des entreprises et réinvestir
réinvestis pour créer plus d'activités
pour investir dans des machines des
machines qui sont pilotées par des
individus enfin je pense que je veux pas
être naïf je ne suis pas naïf mais je
trouve que c'est caricatural d'opposer
systématiquement profit et travail
capital et travail voilà je pense que il
y a une relation
étroite le capital permet
l'investissement permet la prise de
risque et permet de créer des emplois un
immense merci jacolivier d'être venu sur
les dans les studios du Figaro est passé
autant de temps pour nous répondre pour
répondre aux internautes et pour nous
éclairer sur ces différents enjeux avec
autant de fou autant de passions je
rappelle au dessus de ce player
que il y a le live texte du Figaro et
qui est alimenté par tous les
journalistes du figaro.fr qui sont pour
beaucoup sur le terrain sur le terrain
où se trouve également les journalistes
de Figaro live va commencer par Timothée
et Julien Leclerc Timothée apparemment
là aussi il y a eu un peu de casse
autour de vous
oui un peu de casse Vincent
malheureusement vous le voyez cette
ancienne c'est enseigne pardon de ce
McDonald's qui a été largement endommagé
par certains manifestants ça s'est passé
lorsque la tête de cortège tout à
l'heure il y a quelques minutes et
passer ici vous voyez ici des petits des
petits des petits feux et les pompiers
les sapeurs-pompiers de Paris et qui
sont très vigilants parce que c'est vrai
que ce qui est assez significatif depuis
quelques minutes maintenant c'est
vraiment cette odeur cette odeur de
fumée de carboniser qui voilà qui se
fait vraiment ressentir depuis plusieurs
minutes maintenant parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de petits feux qui sont lancés
ici ou là vous le voyez ici c'est le cas
également à une dizaine de mètres de moi
et puis aussi des encarts publicitaires
je vous en parlais tout à l'heure en
voici un par exemple qui a été voilà
défoncé par par certains manifestants
lorsque le la tête de cortège est passé
un peu plus loin devant également un feu
de fumée cette fumée noire voilà parce
que souvent ce sont des poubelles
notamment qui sont qui sont incendiés et
donc je vous le disais cette odeur assez
désagréable cette odeur de carboniser
qui se fait largement ressentir ici de
nous trouvons nous venons de passer le
boulevard Sébastopol nous sommes sur le
boulevard Saint-Denis et donc voilà nous
sommes en train d'avancer d'avancer vers
le boulevard Haussmann qui permettra
ensuite d'arriver sur cette place de
l'Opéra le cortège qui poursuit son
avancée faut dire que le parcours
aujourd'hui est assez conséquent c'est
près de 4 km que les manifestants et
bien vont marcher donc voilà le cortège
qui continue qui ne s'arrête pas c'est
vrai que souvent les forces de l'ordre
sont obligés d'arrêter le cortège de
temps en temps pour et bien réguler le
flux là le flux qui est assez continue
pour le moment en tous les cas et vous
les voyez c'est nombreux drapeaux qui
est bien qui qui
flotte dans le dans le sol dans le dans
le dans le ciel pardon des rues de la
capitale cet après-midi parce que voilà
ce cortège on le on l'a dit on le répète
et très fourni cet après-midi
à mon cher Christophe Cornavin merci
beaucoup Timothée pour ses précisions
vous me le disiez ça s'en va ouais la
situation s'emballe un petit peu à Paris
là moi je viens d'avoir des des des
premiers des derniers messages là qui
viennent de la boucle police et qui nous
font état notamment de barricades en feu
au croisement de de l'axe Sébastopol et
de la rue Saint-Martin donc c'est un
petit peu derrière de là où se trouve
c'est non c'est le c'est justement le
l'endroit où se trouve effectivement
Timothée et voilà
les pompiers sont en train d'intervenir
pour éteindre l'incendie et dans la même
temps
là il y a
exactement deux minutes
la porteur de police fait état d'attaque
d'une supérette et de jette dans ce
genre incendiaire dans une banque
boulevard Bonne-Nouvelle donc les forces
de l'ordre à nouveau interviennent on
est je pense sur une
pour la première fois depuis le début du
mouvement sur une manifestation de la
terre syndicale qui qui est en train de
déraper très clairement
on a eu ben voilà on voit l'incendie de
palette bon pour l'instant c'est pas
encore
le grand soir mais c'est des scènes
qu'on n'avait pas encore vu
pendant les 9 les 8 premières journées
nationales d'action
contre la contre la réforme des
retraites on avait vu quand même on
avait vu des violences notamment au
niveau de la place Vauban lors des
toutes premières journées de
mobilisation oui mais oui mais on était
là on est vraiment sur un cortège qu'on
appelle dynamique c'est à dire
parasablement statique c'est à dire un
cortège qui est qui part d'un point A
en l'espace la Bastille et qui rejoint
opéra et normalement
les services d'ordre des différents
syndicats avec une présence extrêmement
fournie exceptionnellement nous fournis
la préfecture de police il y a plus de
5000 policiers et gendarmes pour assurer
le la sécurité de cette manifestation
aujourd'hui c'est quand même là on sent
qu'il y a une gradation une nouvelle
gradation qui a été atteinte dans la
dans la dans la violence
c'est aller à
gressendo assez vite parce que la
manifestation faisait partie avec un peu
de retard ok au bout de 45 minutes il y
a eu un pro de premier accrochage entre
des casseurs et des forces de l'ordre
très rapidement la vue et nos nos
journalistes sur place l'ont constaté
des notamment des enseignes de
restauration rapide
ont été la cible de d'actes de
vandalisme de Jette pierre avec
qui ont été soit étoilés soit voir
brisés donc on a cette barricade en feu
on a cette banque attaquer et il faut
bien se rendre compte que là le cortège
est parti il y a allez une heure une
heure et demie quoi donc
par rapport à donc 14h30 c'est bien tout
ça va faire bientôt 2 ans après on sait
que ça va crescendo cette histoire c'est
que à mesure qu'on s'approchera et de du
point d'arrivée et
de la de la fin de la manif et sa
dislocation et de la tombée de la nuit
ça va ça risque de prendre une forme une
forme que les que les services de
renseignement redoutaient désirs dont on
avait anticipé ma question effectivement
c'est les forces de l'ordre sont
toujours autant sur les dents et ça et
vous glisser sur des services de
renseignement ah oui non non vraiment
sur les dents hier j'ai eu des donc
différents interlocuteurs qui sont des
analystes du renseignement ministère de
l'Intérieur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui absolument Vincent je confirme tout
à fait ce que vient de dire tout ça
c'est vrai que ça se tend un petit peu
ici vous l'avez vu sur ces images de
Julien Leclerc des abribus par exemple
ici abîmés également là on va vous
montrer donc les pompiers les
sapeurs-pompiers de Paris qui sont en
train d'intervenir l'assassin se passe
rue Saint-Denis donc une rue
perpendiculaire à ce à ce boulevard
Saint-Denis et donc les pompiers qui
interviennent parce qu'il y a toujours
ses feux épars et vraiment cette cette
mauvaise odeur cette odeur de de cramer
dans les rues de Paris en fait ce qui se
passe c'est qu'il y a un cortège qui
précède le cortège syndical le cortège
syndical se trouve derrière nous le
premier cortège j'allais dire et devant
nous avec donc des des hommes en noir
qui cassent du mobilier urbain qui
mettent le feu à des poubelles ou bien
voilà à des mobiliers qu'il trouve sur
le dans la rue et donc voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jamais assez ce n'est pas une ce n'est
pas un mouvement politique mais c'est un
mode opératoire c'est un mode d'action
un mode de guérilla urbaine
qui est extrêmement bien organisé
avec des gens qui se connaissent et qui
échangent
notamment via les réseaux cryptés une
fois qu'ils sont sur le terrain il
travaille au coup de sifflet au claquant
de claquement de demain pour
suivre un seul dessin qui est celui de
d'affronter les forces de l'ordre et de
casser tout ce qui peut ressembler peu
pro à des symboles de l'État ou du
capitalisme on les voit la méthode est
toujours la même c'est à dire que
généralement il se dissimule dans un
premier temps Paramé les manifestants
après il se décilouette c'est à dire
qu'il il se met en il se met en noir et
puis après une fois l'action passé il se
remette en normal si j'ose dire en 15
jours enfin en tenue normal et ils ont
une stratégie que les techniciens
appellent celle de la recomposition
perpétuelle c'est à dire que il ne ils
sont à géométrie variable et ils sont
tout le temps en mouvement c'est à dire
qu'on a du mal à les forces de l'ordre
ont un mal fou à les techniques et à les
aller
prendre en taille et aller mettre dans
un coin pour procéder aux
interpellations généralement et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'on a remarqué pendant
les deux dernières manifestations seules
les novices ceux qui ne sont pas
aguerris à ces techniques de guerrière
urbaine à savoir les les étudiants qui
se font entraîner par les mouvements de
l'ultra d'ultra gauche qui sont
manipulés par l'ultra gauche c'est cela
qu'ils sont interpellés
il y a une chose qu'on comprend pas
effectivement que sont eux qui se font
interpellés mais que les services de
renseignement n'arrivent pas à
identifier ses activistes alors que on
les a vu notamment dans la lutte contre
le terrorisme ça va aient quand même
être
identifié assez en amont
un certain nombre de de profils
dangereux là on comprend pas trop
ces activistes n'arrivent pas à être
identifiés
non pas par la police mais par les
services de renseignement parce qu'on
sait quand même qu'on les voit souvent à
l'oeuvre je pense je pense qu'il y a
deux choses la première chose c'est que
pendant très longtemps
mais ça date maintenant elle n'est pas
cassée en sienne je pense notamment
jusqu'à jusqu'en 2018 peut-être pas plus
tard mais avant c'était il y avait une
réticence à procéder à des
interpellations à aller au contact et
interpeller les gens
et donc évidemment dans ces cas-là c'est
très difficile comme interpelle personne
de savoir qui derrière le masque
maintenant c'est un peu évolué on va les
forces de l'ordre vont au contact
mais comme je le disais et j'en parlais
encore hier avec des spécialistes du
maternel mais pourquoi diable une fois
qu'on a conseillé qui sont deux trois
mille on se connaît leur leur bassin
leur lieu de vie ça vaut un règne ils
sont à ils sont ils sont à Nantes ils
sont à Grenoble enfin c'est exactement
où ils sont pourquoi finalement ne pas
les interpeller et les frapper d'une
interdiction de paraître comme on peut
le faire avec des supporters violents
dans des stades de foot ou ce qui
s'était fait au moment des gilets jaunes
ou ce qui s'est fait au moment des
gilets jaunes et en fait c'est que
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
c'est que
on a une fin les services de l'État ont
une visibilité quand même relativement
faible de qui ils sont vraiment c'est à
dire que
très peu d'entre eux se font se font
interpeller
il y a évidemment quelques leaders qui
sont qui sont suivis et qui font le
traitement d'une l'objet d'une de d'un
suivi particulier avec une fiche s ils
sont inscrits au fichier d'herpès des
personnes reçoivent chercher etc mais la
majeure partie de ces jeunes
blackblockers qui sont donc je le répète
à géométrie variable et qui sont
vraiment difficilement saisissables
d'ailleurs on voit pas forcément
énormément d'interpeller parmi les les
meneurs c'est souvent ceux qui courent
le moins vite ou les moins expérimentés
qui et donc du coup c'est très difficile
de c'est très difficile d'anticiper leur
action d'autant plus que
pendant très longtemps les mouvements
d'ultra gauche est un filtré et pouvait
être suivi dans leur action parce qu'on
savait à peu près ce qu'ils allaient
faire maintenant avec les réseaux
filtrés et les réseaux elle part dans
les réseaux cryptés et les réseaux
sociaux une grande grande spontanéité
qui fait que c'est très difficile de
prédire en amont très longtemps avant ce
qu'ils vont faire donc c'est une
équation c'est un vrai casse-tête pour
la police Timothée à vous trouver alors
Timothée on a perdu les images
effectivement ça bloque parce que
justement ça bouge beaucoup là où il se
trouve dès qu'on aura de nouvelles
images on pourra la voir peut-être qu'on
a Vincent roseron si nous entend
l'appareil il y a un problème de blocage
on va se retrouver effectivement si
prouve qu'il y a du monde et il y a
beaucoup de mouvements là où
là où on se trouve vous voyez ces images
là en direct on est sur les grands
boulevards on est à proximité du célèbre
Grand Rex grand cinéma qui se trouve sur
le boulevard Bonne-Nouvelle c'est là où
on vient d'assister on vient de voir une
charge on voit également sur les images
qui me parviennent mais un peu pixelisé
c'est-à-dire un peu figé et dès qu'on
les a en meilleure définition on voulait
montrera mais également des des départs
de feu au milieu de la au milieu du
de la place de en tout cas des Grands
Boulevards
pour reprendre la question que je
voulais vous poser
on voit les Black Blocs on a parlé des
gilets jaunes vous en parlez dans
l'article qui paraît dans l'édition
papier enfin en tout cas PDF du Figaro
parce que on n'a pas eu le plaisir
d'avoir des édition papier ce matin mais
elle est accessible donc vous pouvez la
retrouver on voit ces images avec les
départs de feu donc au milieu des Grands
Boulevards on va savoir on va essayer de
savoir en quoi qu'elle est qu'est-ce qui
est en train de de brûler mais en tous
les cas c'est toujours des images
spectaculaires alors ce qu'on se dit
toujours d'ailleurs un parenthèse mon
cher Christophe c'est que avec ce genre
d'image faut toujours faire attention à
l'effet de loop mais d'après ce que vous
disiez c'est ça qui m'intéressait c'est
que vous avez toujours mis en garde par
rapport à ces images jusqu'à présent là
les informations que vous vous donniez
c'est que à côté des images extrêmement
calme
que l'on que l'on que l'on peut voir et
comme ces images de cortège il y a quand
même pas mal de points de tension voilà
en fait il y a quand même un ferment de
violence qui qui apparaît c'est c'est
manifeste
on peut pas encore présager de l'issue
de cette de ce rassemblement c'est
simplement qu'il y aura qui a déjà un
monde un monde considérable on a vu à
travers le pays les
le la mobilisation et est extrêmement
forte la radio qui les a les les tout
autant on a parlé de l'Orient on a parlé
de Rennes aussi où il y a eu des
incidents en queue de manif là où le 11
septembre le 11 février pardon il y
avait eu trois CRS dont un grièvement
blessés par des cocktails Molotov et et
à chaque fois la volonté c'est c'est de
s'affronter avec les services d'ordre ce
que veut absolument éviter le préfet de
police avec ces nouvelles méthodes de de
de maintien de l'ordre à savoir
et il répète à chaque fois qu'il le peut
l'idée c'est d'essayer de faire en sorte
que les policiers soient le moins
visible possible pour ne pas susciter
d'action
de de violence de la part des des
casseurs qui ne sort pas de chiffon
rouge mais en revanche ils sont
extrêmement réactifs ils sont en dans
les rues adjacentes extrêmement réactif
et prêt à interpellé je vous propose
justement de retrouver Timothée délai
qui est à côté de ces scènes que l'on
est en train de voir
Timothée
la
c'est de plus en plus tendue d'après ce
qu'on est en train de voir
oui Vincent c'est de plus en plus tendu
même si ça reste relativement maîtrisé
mais c'est vrai qu'à de plus en plus de
mobiliers urbains détériorés on va
demander à Julien Leclerc de vous
montrer par exemple ce feu imposant qui
a été qui a été allumé là avec ses ce
sont des cagettes en bois qui ont été
assemblés au milieu de la route et qui
ont donc
été mis en feu par ces fameuses hormones
noires que vous avez peut-être aperçu
également sur ces sur ces images nous
sommes au niveau de bonne nouvelle donc
nous progressons toujours entre la Place
de la République et la place de l'Opéra
même si il reste encore quelques
plusieurs même centaines de mètres à
parcourir avant d'arriver sur la place
de l'Opéra on va continuer d'avancer sur
cette sur cette sur ce boulevard vous le
voyez des hommes en cagoulées des amants
noirs c'est vrai qu'on sent qu'il y a
une tension il y a du mobilier urbain je
vous le disais qui a été détruit
toujours une odeur très désagréable
cette odeur de de cramer on a vu
également tout à l'heure et bien une
charge de la part des forces de l'ordre
qui ont tenté de disperser des
manifestants un nouveau feu là-bas comme
vous le montre à l'instant Julien
Leclerc c'est vrai que voilà on sent que
ça se ça se tend on est loin de cette de
cette bonne ambiance j'allais dire que
l'on vous décrivez tout à l'heure il
faut dire qu'il y a vraiment deux
ambiances très différentes parce que à
des centaines de mètres de là le cortège
syndical lui se déroule dans une
ambiance plutôt plutôt calme mais c'est
vrai que dès que l'on se dirige vers
l'avancée vers l'avant du cortège tout
de suite on voit que là c'est c'est
beaucoup plus tendu pour nous rendre ici
nous avons emprunté des rues des rues
adjacentes et nous avons vu et bien des
CRS qui étaient en train de de bloquer
la rue de prépa de se préparer à une à
une éventuelle intervention avec avec le
casque vous savez que c'est toujours
assez significatif lorsque les CRS ont
sorti le casque au lieu du calot c'est
que voilà malheureusement la situation
se tend avec le casque avec le bouclier
et puis quelques investives et quelques
investis pardon également de la part de
certains manifestants du type vous êtes
des collabos à l'égard donc des des
forces de l'ordre donc la situation ici
qui se tend même si ça reste pour le
moment maîtriser merci beaucoup Timothée
vous restez sur place on vous reprend
dès que la situation
évolue et on continue de suivre ça au
plus près il y a d'autres images
effectivement on voit bien que les
l'ambiance parfois est plus calme sur
d'autres images dans tous les cas celles
qui sont tournées par Vincent roseron
qui lui se trouve un petit peu du en
arrière du cortège voilà vous les voyez
si major direct avec notamment Force
Ouvrière je sais pas si Vincent nous
entend parce que là il y avait également
aussi beaucoup de monde et des problèmes
de problèmes de réseau
Vincent si vous entendez je tente ma
chance allez Vincent si vous nous
entendez comment ça se passe autour de
vous
oui je vous entends Vincent
effectivement alors ça se passe dans le
calme comme vous l'avez dit dans une
ambiance festive les cortèges les
différents syndicats commencent à peine
à passer alors ça a commencé tout au
début bien sûr par le cortège de l'Inter
syndical et ensuite il y a eu plutôt les
cortèges étudiants et là il faut le
premier syndicat on va dire à passer
vraiment et ça se passe dans la bonne
humeur on a vu beaucoup de voilà de sono
d'ambiance festive on va dire rien à
voir avec toi en tout cas les images que
semblent proposer Timothée délaime et
Julien Leclerc de leur côté à l'arrière
on est loin de ces scènes là tout le
monde manifeste on va dire dans la voilà
on va dire dans la joie et ça se passe
en tout cas très bien le seul petit
moment un peu pas forcément de tension
mais assez remarqué ça a été quand les
pompiers sont venus manifester aussi et
les pompiers bah quand ils viennent de
manifester bah ils étaient abonnés
pétards partout et du coup ça fait des
très grosses explosions et ça a un peu
surpris les gens mais à part ça sinon
tout est très calme merci beaucoup
effectivement de salles de ambiance à
revoir d'ailleurs les images autour de
Timothée délai mais Julien Leclerc ou
bien plus exactement les images nous
notamment de nos confrères d'assieu
cette presse qui montrait également pas
mal de tension là pour l'instant celle
que vous voyez c'est les images de l'AFP
et effectivement on voit une ambiance
calme et je sais gré à Vincent roserand
de ne pas avoir employé le mot tarte à
la crème de bon enfant mais c'est tout
comme
question est-ce que les gilets jaunes
sont de retour
non on peut pas dire véritablement
qu'ils sont retours on peut on peut ils
ont envie de revenir mais ils n'ont en
aucune manière la main sur le mouvement
ni de près ni de loin
il y a quelques quelques semaines on
voyait qu'ils essayaient de revivre de
revivre de faire un retour aux sources
en retournant sur les ronds-points la
mayonnaise a pas véritablement pris
là parfois
on les voit s'agréger en fait c'est donc
les plus radicaux des gilets jaunes on
les voit s'agréger au casseurs de
l'ultra gauche donc ce qui nous fait un
millier de des métiers potentiels en
général notamment pour pour Paris en
tête de cortège ça devient désormais une
tradition à mesure que se déroule ces
journées nationales d'action
mais en fait ce qui se passe c'est que
la terre syndicale pour l'instant n'a
absolument pas ne baisse pas la garde et
ne lui laisse pas la rue au gilet jaune
qui sont pas structurés
qui n'ont pas de qui n'ont quasiment pas
de de coordination donc voilà je pense
qu'il y a une volonté des gilets jaunes
de revenir mais en revanche il peut y
avoir en revanche une forme de je sais
pas si on peut
giletisations du mouvement plus global
avec des des en revanche des gens qui
n'en n'osent pas le gilet jaune mais qui
ne
ne parle pas forcément que des retraites
de la réforme des retraites dans les
dans les mots d'ordre où ils veulent
tout cramer ils lutte contre ils
appellent le blocage social mais c'est
ça peut être pour les salaires ça peut
être pour cette France qu'on a décrite
déjà des déclassés cette phrase des
sous-préfecture qui semblait avoir été
oubliée par le par le pouvoir central et
et et et notamment Emmanuel Macron qui
incarne qui incarne beaucoup la la
colère des gens
des
manifestants lancent
Timothée d'Hélène des feux d'artifice
[Musique]
sur les forces de recevoir une photo
figurez-vous de
de
mortier artisanaux et de pétards qui
viennent d'être saisis sur un sur un sur
un manifestant donc c'est à dire qu'en
fait il faut quand même savoir que pour
éviter que
c'est des gros c'est des gros gros
mortiers et des gros gros pétards
pour pour évidemment cibler les forces
de l'ordre et personne d'autre et
normalement il y a eu 2000 personnes qui
ont été fouillées avant la manif il y a
eu cinq personnes interpellées ce qui
est pas énorme mais a priori déjà l'idée
c'était de procéder à un filtre avant
que les gens puissent rejoindre ce
cortège manifestement il y a toujours
des des casseurs qui arrivent à se à se
glisser dans les mailles du entre les
mailles du filet voir il y en a qui on
l'a déjà vu près positionne des armes de
fortune sur le parcours le matin avant
que et qui s'en empare quand même le
parcours
si évidemment que les forces de l'ordre
puisque nous avons pris l'antenne à 7h45
je voyais place de l'Opéra les déjà les
premières mairie qui est en train
d'inspecter et bien sûr qu'ils
inspectent les lieux mais il faut quand
même considérer que là on part de on
part de on part de la Bastille on fait
bâtir et République République opéra
alors après ça peut être je pense pas
que chaque centimètre carré donc
évidemment il y a comme un ratissage
pour essayer de de nettoyer le le
périmètre moi ce matin je suis arrivé
aussi assez tôt et j'ai vu que les
éboueurs notamment ont
repris du service alors aux alentours de
la place de l'Opéra et dans un périmètre
de 150 mètres enfin je devrais pas le
dire parce qu'autrement après les les
casseurs vont essayer de de
d'enflammer un peu plus loin mais voilà
le gars engage qui sont plutôt sur le
terrain
mais en tout état de cause voilà il y a
quand même un travail de prépa
préparatoire qui est fait pour éviter la
casse mais voilà bah la preuve c'est que
sur cette photo là moi je vois c'est
pétards et cet individu d'ailleurs qui a
été interpellé en position de ces engins
de mortier
je voulais vous poser une autre question
à la qui est un peu connexe puisque là
c'est plutôt des violences contre les
forces de l'ordre qu'on est en train
qu'on a vu
mais il y a beaucoup de vidéos qui ont
circulé sur les réseaux sociaux beaucoup
de vidéos qui ont choqué qui mettent en
cause les agents des braves est-ce que
les enquêtes sont en cours
alors sur les agents des braves façon
les agents des braves c'est un peu comme
les bacs
c'est des unités d'intervention
comme l'acronyme le dit de répression de
l'action violente donc c'est des unités
qui ont vocation elle est au contact et
à interpeller
les gens qui font des exactions
évidemment il y a une enquête qui est
notamment en cours
qui vise alors je sais pas si c'est des
gens des braves mais je pense que c'est
des policiers qui avaient qui ont été
mises en cause après
qu'un manifestant a reçu un coup sur les
sur les grands boulevards mais il faut
il faut faire attention avant de juger
ces images parce que les vidéos qu'on
voit ne durent que quelques secondes et
le travail de la police c'est d'essayer
de notamment de la police de police et
c'est de circonstanquer l'intégralité de
la scène et pour l'exemple par exemple
de cette de ce de de se manifestants qui
a reçu un violent coup
et qui a semblé à être complètement
groggy chaos sur la sur la route on
s'est rendu compte après enquête que ce
même manifestant finalement avait été
pris en charge sur place par les
policiers qu'il avait été relevé et que
on l'a retrouvé genre une demi-heure ou
trois quarts d'heure plus tard de
nouveau parmi les manifestants et de
nouveau à l'action en train de d'essayer
de commettre des méfaits parce qu'il
faut j'ai oublié de rappeler qu'il avait
dans sa main un pavé pour essayer de
casser un abribus ou un casque à jour là
je ne sais plus mais en tout cas il
avait une il voulait il était dans une
logique de deux casse ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que il n'y a pas et le
préfet de police l'a dit et on peut en
être témoin quand même à chaque fois que
il n'y a pas d'intervention préventive
c'est hyper important de le souligner il
y a que des appels qu'on interpelle pas
des gens
dans l'hypothèse où il pourrait
commettre quelque chose les seules
interpellations qui ont lieu sont des
interpellations
quand les actions est commise ça c'est
une première chose de la même manière
que il y a beaucoup de polémiques sur ce
qu'on appelle les Nass vous savez quand
les gens sont
enfermés par des par des par un cordon
de CRS ou de gendarmes mobiles sur un et
en fait on a vu hier soir d'ailleurs
juste à côté du juste à côté d'ici dans
le 9ème arrondissement vous voyez les
policiers et envoyer des manifestants
des policiers d'un côté des policiers de
l'autre voilà ça c'est des NAS mais
alors en fait il y a deux types de Nas
vous avez ce qu'on appelle la NAS
judiciaire
qui en fait est une nasse qui vise juste
à bloquer un casseur qui vient de faire
un groupe de il y a une vingtaine de
personnes qui viennent de mettre le feu
à c'est quoi un abribus
une voiture ou des poubelles etc ils
sont bloqués sur un mur le temps que les
services interpellateurs viennent et les
emmène pour les mettre en garde à vue ce
qu'on appelle une naze judiciaire ce qui
est tout à fait prévu tout à fait légal
et une deuxième type de Nas qui a une
nasse de maintien de l'ordre c'est à
dire que si tout d'un coup la tension
monte soudainement dans une partie de la
manifestation le préfet de police est
tout à fait en droit de
de figer
la scène pendant pendant quelques
minutes
pour que pour que pour que les forces de
l'or puissent procéder à
un rétablissement du calme et faire des
vérifications d'identité et ces gens là
généralement repartent il n'y a pas de
garde à vue à ciel ouvert comme le
laisse entendre notamment des certains
syndicats de magistrats ou de
mouvement d'avocat Syndicat de la
magistrature pour pas le nommer par
exemple Vincent fontaine membre qui est
cette intervenir c'est l'excellent
Christophe Cornavin qui suit les
questions de police et spécialisée de
renseignement intérieur la meilleure en
France le meilleur en France et il
travaille au Figaro au service société
question récurrente question tarte à la
crème Christophe quelle est la doctrine
en termes de maintien de l'ordre à
l'heure actuelle en fait la document est
dans le reste du pays mais généralement
Paris
transpire sur le reste des grandes des
grandes villes de France dans ce domaine
tout à fait l'idée c'est la doctrine
elle est simple c'est le Servette c'est
une doctrine qui a été mise en place
parce qu'on appelle le schéma national
du maintien de l'ordre qui vise un à
mettre un petit peu maintenant plus de
distance entre
les forces de l'ordre et les
manifestants c'est à dire que
pendant les défilés d'ailleurs on le
voit de manière vraiment manifeste vous
voyez des rues de Paris vous voyez
uniquement des manifestants et vous avez
presque l'impression que il n'y a pas de
policiers
alors qu'il y en a peut-être jamais eu
autant il y a 5000 hommes autour de
cette manifestation ce qui est tout à
fait considérable mais ils sont dans les
rues
adjacentes les rues annexes et eux sont
une interviendront que si il y a de la
casse c'est à dire pendant trop
longtemps les forces de l'ordre
utilisaient ce qu'on appelle des
techniques de flancardage des
flancardelles et les manifester
voilà ils ont disparu le préfet de
police d'ailleurs de leur a donné la
consigne parce qu'il applique le schéma
national du maintien de l'Empire vous
sortez du décor vous ne vous voit pas et
en revanche
il leur a donné comme consigne
extrêmement réactif en 4K ce qui est une
prise de risque d'ailleurs pour le
pouvoir politique et pour le préfet
parce que le thème parce que le delta
entre la casse et l'interpellation il
faut qu'il soit vous a plu petit
possible c'est à dire que en fait c'est
une question de minutes même pas c'est
un changement par rapport à ce qu'on
appelait la doctrine l'Allemand qui elle
était une doctrine où on allait au
contact c'est ça alors
la
doctrine l'allemand en fait elle a été
dictée par une d'autres circonstances
c'est à dire que
là on voit que c'est une manifestation
qui est encadrée par des syndicats il y
a un service d'ordre
tout ça est assez discipliné pour
l'instant
l'allemand le préfet l'allemand lui il
était face
à des à des amateurs c'est en tout cas
des novices de la de la manifestation
les gilets jaunes et qui allaient de
manière désordonnée dans les rues
faisaient des cortèges sauvages et à la
différence des syndicats et des
manifestants habituelles
les gilets jaunes allaient au contact
des forces de l'ordre
ils font ça sur les forces de l'ordre et
d'ailleurs les premières les premières
manifestations avec les gilets jaunes
les forces de les forces de l'ordre
étaient complètement déconcertées par
ces
manifestants du troisième type qui
venaient se frotter à eux
ils savent pas trop quoi faire donc
et c'est après que que les tensions les
heures se sont se sont exacerbées que le
préfet allemand d'ailleurs en 2019 a
décidé de mettre en place c'est la
brigade de répression de l'action
violente motorisée les braves Mike
pour pour pouvoir essayer de remettre un
de l'ordre dans dans les rues de Paris
quelle est la différence entre entre les
braves Mike justement et ceux qu'on
avait appelé les Voltigeurs qui ont été
corps qui a été supprimés après la mort
de Malikou c'est qui arrête une des
principales différences parce que les
Voltigeurs 1990 enfin dissous en 1986
après la mort de manicousikine
était effectivement à moto ils étaient
deux à moto et il y avait donc le pilote
et
l'opérateur derrière qui avait une
le matraque pour pour
frapper quand les gens
pour essayer de contenir ou en tout cas
de disperser violente mais la différence
c'est que à l'époque les Voltigeurs ne
descendaient pas de moto et et il
frappait à la volée
tout en roulant dans les classes la
consigne est quand même assez claire
c'est que
les braves Mike les braves aiment sont
là pour là on voit là on voit les
rejeter
ils sont en train de ramasser tous les
tous les projectiles de fortune il a la
charge voilà la charge directe
c'est qu'il faut pas que la colère se
cristallise il faut pas que le mouvement
les les blagues bloqueurs puissent
puissent se former donc l'idée c'est
comme on le dit comme le disent les
techniciens de grand public c'est de
c'est de briser le bloc
désolé des retours effectivement des
tout d'un coup et tout d'un coup il y a
effectivement ce qu'on appelle des bons
françaises les forces de l'ordre
font des bons offensifs pour briser les
blocs
qui sont assez violent là comment ça se
qui a presque se regroupe ou se disperse
c'est ce qu'on va dire c'est cette
technique de recomposition permanente
qui s'éclate et puis après ils vont se
remettre en ils vont se remettre en bloc
pour repartir à l'assaut mais pour
revenir sur les braves Mike en fait la
difficulté l'idée c'est que les les à la
différence entre du genre de 86 que il
descente de moto ils ne sont plus sur la
moto ils sont juste là pour
ils sont juste là pour
faire du matin de l'ordre pour être
projeté là où il y a les incidents plus
rapidement possible mais il ne reste pas
sur la moto apparemment là il y a des
interpellations sont en cours alors
effectivement là on voit que c'est dans
des d'autres rues qui sont des rues
adjacentes au boulevard grande-nouvelle
c'est tendu quand même là c'est tendu en
fait ce qui se passe c'est que là on
voit qu'il y a des il y a des il y a des
éléments violents dans les rues de Jason
qui aimerait bien rejoindre le cortège
principal et
les policiers les en empêchent mais là
ils sont tous on voit que ils sont beaux
il y a un certain nombre qui sont en
train de décider de rentrer sur les bras
sur le boulevard mais il y a aussi des
gens des grands boulevards qui les
attaquent les attaques de de part et
d'autre donc là c'est une course assez
dans une situation assez assez compliqué
ils sont quand même en nombre on voit
que ils arrivent à bien maintenir l'axe
mais ils sont entre deux feux là parce
qu'il a dans un mois devant et derrière
merci beaucoup Christophe pour toute ces
explications
[Musique]
apparemment si la situation en est à ce
moment-là à l'heure du thé on imagine ce
que ce sera à l'heure de l'apéritif je
parle pas du dîner et de l'after on va
retrouver Timothée Delam qui se trouve
justement à proximité de ces scènes
parce que ce sont les images de Julien
Leclerc quelle est la situation à
l'heure actuelle apparemment c'est
extrêmement tendu Timothée
oui Vincent je vous confirme
c'est très tendu alors c'est assez
évident tellement tendu que ça doit être
c'en est haché merci
Timothée effectivement 14
interpellations nous indiquent à
l'instant
Christophe Cornavin on va alors que
effectivement on voit encore cette
charge
boulevard sur les grands boulevards on
va retourner un petit peu derrière avec
Vincent roserand et là effectivement
l'ambiance est beaucoup plus calme
[Musique]
une autre une autre journée de
mobilisation qui pourrait arriver plus
tard selon ce que décideront les
syndicats de Raphaël ce sera à 19h à
priori l'interdire se réunit pour donner
l'information dans ce qui se passera
après cette journée de mobilisation en
tout cas tous nous aussi qui étaient
tous très déterminés et beaucoup d'entre
eux m'ont dit qu'effectivement ce n'est
pas tant les retraites maintenant mais
c'est aussi la personnalité de Macron et
son interview hier midi qui est assez
mal passé et qu'il a on va dire sur
motivé à venir faire la manifestation
aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup Vincent 800 000 personnes
à Paris c'est le chiffre de la CGT en
attendant d'avoir suivi de la police
mais c'est en tout cas ce que ce que
revendique la centrale syndicale
centrale connaît bien en tout cas
chers concert Sophie Ravinel bonsoir
Sophie merci de nous avoir rejoint vous
étiez sur le terrain quel était on voit
deux salles de ambiances là en ce moment
vous quel était l'ambiance là où vous
étiez et bien écoutez moi j'ai remonté
tout le cortège puisque mon rôle ici
c'est de suivre les responsables
politiques ceux de la nupette en
particulier
j'étais avec eux depuis 13h aujourd'hui
je suis restée jusqu'à mon retour là au
Figaro où j'ai juste je suis passé
devant les forces de l'ordre qui ouvrent
le cortège et donc j'ai remonté tout ce
cortège à peu près pendant une heure
avec évidemment j'ai suivi de loin des
des charges au niveau de bonne nouvelle
avec
absolument et
[Musique]
bien de carnaval évidemment de défouloir
et qui traduisait bien les voilà qui
traduisaient bien les tensions depuis
jeudi dernier depuis le choix du 49-3 et
et la suite
voilà pour l'ambiance effectivement
continue de suivre pendant que ce temps
là ce qui se passe donc dans le cortège
effectivement une tension beaucoup plus
forte que lors des précédentes
mobilisations 800.000 personnes
revendiquées par la CGT en ce moment à
Paris on attend les résultats officiels
mais ce qu'on sait c'est que de toute
façon
l'ambiance la mobilisation non seulement
ici à Paris mais derrière dans le reste
du péril et plus forte à tous les mois
que la semaine dernière et fait partie
des plus fortes mobilisations on atteint
les résultats définitifs en tous les cas
les estimations les chiffres officiels
ce qui ne fait pas forcément les
chiffres réels qu'ils soient donnés par
les syndicats ou qu'il soit donné par
les autorités quelle est l'ambiance
puisque vous êtes notre nuit passologue
ici quelle est l'ambiance
la faction c'est-à-dire
importante de la nipples c'est à dire à
la France insoumise et bien écoutez
toutes les propos des parlementaires qui
étaient présents sur le point la main de
la nupa et sur celui des insoumis comme
d'ailleurs sur celui des communistes
avec Fabien Roussel c'est évidemment
celui des violences policières c'est le
thème qui monte depuis plusieurs jours
j'étais il y a deux jours devant le
commissariat absolument de points ouvrez
les guillemets les violences policières
la dénonciation de ces violences
policières elles sont tout de même s'il
y a des guillemets documentés ces
violences elles sont deux parts et
d'autres évidemment mais il y a des
débordements qui sont d'ailleurs
reconnus par les syndicats de police la
question j'en profite pour signaler
d'ailleurs que Mathieu Valley qui est
secrétaire responsable d'un des
syndicats commissaires de police sera
notre invité à partir de 18h30
de les réentendre on a vu des des choses
qui selon moi et je ne suis pas du tout
à la base de Christophe campa notre
confrère qui s'occupe justement des
colisses des questions de police justice
mais des débordements individuels sur
lesquels donc les élus de la nupes ont
les yeux braqués et donc leur propos
sont forts très forts et on entendait
Fabien Roussel appeler dire d'Emmanuel
Macron qu'il était le président casseur
on entendait Jérôme Gadge le socialise
député appeler solennellement à la
responsabilité du gouvernement on
entendait évidemment Yannick Jadot aussi
l'écologiste marine tonde de liesse
crétinationale de LV tous étaient
unanimes pour dénoncer ces violences
policières et pour appeler le président
au retrait de la réforme parce que c'est
pour eux la seule solution pour essayer
de faire baisser les tensions dans le
pays alors la thématique donc une
thématique qui fait l'union à gauche
donc c'est la dénonciation de ce qu'ils
appellent les violences policières on a
entendu d'ailleurs Fabien Roussel
revenir sur cette question et appeler
d'ailleurs au calme de part et d'autre
tout à l'heure c'était à 15h en direct
sur le sur le finance
vous répondez d'une certaine manière à
ma question qui était de jusqu'où ira le
soutien aux manifestations non déclarées
aux actions radicales la violence
comprise c'est-à-dire là la violence à
l'égard des polices le soutien par qui
par par
la nups
en général et la France insoumise en
particulier
la France insoumise considère
contrairement à ce que dit le Premier
ministre et le ministre de l'Intérieur
que sur tout minuser l'intérieur pardon
excusez-moi donc Gérald Darmanin que ces
manifestations non déclarées ne sont pas
pour autant illégale qu'il n'est pas
interdit d'y participer alors je crois
qu'il y a effectivement un débat
juridique mais une jurisprudence aussi
sur le sujet
anisti International s'est exprimé
c'était un vieux débat en France en tout
cas pour la nuit pêche pour les élus
parlementaires la participation à sa
manifestation n'est pas d'ordre illégal
ce qui est illégal évidemment
les actes de violence ce sont les appels
au meurtres ce sont évidemment
alors ça évidemment quand elles ne sont
pas déclarées quand c'est les
organisateurs mais je parle de ceux qui
participent et donc il y a pas de
condamnation en tant que tel il y a
évidemment des appels au calme de tout
le monde y compris des élus de la France
insoumise évidemment
à la non-violence mais pour autant ils
comprennent ils vont pas appeler à la
violence parce que sinon évidemment tout
le monde leur tomberait dessus et et et
ceux de la nups plus modérée les
premiers donc évidemment que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon a toujours appelé à la
révolution citoyenne à la Révolution par
les urnes les seuls en France qui
appellent à la violence ce sont des
factions d'extrême gauche très isolés
est-ce que il y a justement
par exemple ça c'est quelque chose qu'on
voit dans le moment syndical il y a une
crainte justement qu'il y a une partie
qui sera radicaliste qui récupère une
partie de la du militantisme par rapport
à un sommet qui parfois n'est pas assez
radical est-ce que il y a une crainte
comme ça la France insoumise de se faire
déborder sur sa gauche pas vraiment
disons que il savent qu'ils peuvent être
débordés par leur gauche et par le CNT
les anarchistes qui chantaient
l'international en disant l'Indio ni
maître ni Jean-Luc à la place de tribun
mais ça c'est assez anecdotique on peut
parler aussi des lignes noires des
totaux des autonomistes qu'il a n'ont
aucun rapport aucun lien volontaire avec
l'institution
la disons que la ligne de fracture elle
est plutôt me semble-t-il et c'est ce
que me confirme certains dans de Paris
d'autre c'est le fait que les insoumis
considèrent que les manifestations organ
par les syndicats ne sont pas
suffisantes pour faire basculer
l'opinion et que cette
disons c'est cette ligne progressiste
incarnée par la CFTC mais qui travaille
la CFD
absolument mais absolument mais
majoritairement évidemment Laurent
Berger et bien que leur façon de vouloir
travailler à la table du gouvernement et
de vouloir absolument contenir contenir
contenir les débordements et là je ne
parle pas de violence mais je parle de
de débordement
spontané voilà de s'y opposer et bien
neide pas à cette révolution citoyenne
et il me semble que la ligne de fracture
en gros est-ce que cette fracture c'est
une on pourrait dire c'est une fracture
entre une ligne Mélenchon et une ligne
Laurent Berger oui et d'ailleurs
Jean-Luc Mélenchon l'a dit dans son blog
en Février il parlait ce qui a
d'ailleurs beaucoup agacé le secrétaire
national communiste de cette ligne
Philippe Martinez Laurent Berger pas
bien Roussel contre la sienne et donc
cette fracture là qui est importante et
qui me semble-t-il illustre quelque
chose des tensions qui peut y avoir mais
aujourd'hui ces tensions elles sont
relativement marginales parce que là
tout le monde a vraiment les yeux
tournés ils sont tous je dois dire
inquiets accusant le chef de l'état
d'être lui le bout de feu le responsable
et surtout par les propos qu'il
adminèrent et là notre correspondant
tout à l'heure je ne sais plus qui de
nos super journalistes qui est dans la
rue parlait en expliquant voilà ils le
sont tous mais en tout cas un
particulier et expliquant que voilà de
fait l'interview hier de Emmanuel Macron
l'interview pour eux juger hors sol
était a été un déclencheur de tension
[Musique]
Jean-Luc Mélenchon ne craint pas que le
renne soit gagnant de la séquence
il craque à force de le dire ce soit le
cas voilà
il craint que et la nuit pêche avec lui
qu'a force que ce soit une sorte de
prophétie auto-réalisatrice je j'ignore
absolument nous avons une partiel
aujourd'hui à la frontière espagnole
enfin dimanche on verra bien ce qu'il en
sortira avec une députée insoumise dont
la l'élection a été invalidée non pas de
sa faute mais en raison d'autres
concurrents madame taurine et donc on va
voir ce qu'il en est du score du
rassemblement national c'est évidemment
un risque mais moi ce que je vois
surtout c'est les chiffres donnés par
les syndicats
d'inscription dans leur rang d'achat de
cartes et de de
disons du fait que c'est les syndicats
ont fait la preuve ces deux derniers
mois de leur capacité de nouveau à
imposer à être une opposition face à
Emmanuel Macron et on me dit dans ses
rang radical que ça va renforcer aussi
disons indirectement les rangs de la
gauche face au RN et que ça peut un peu
modifier la donne quel est le calendrier
des prochaines étapes pour les insoumis
en particulier pour la nuit place en
général et bien écoutez le calendrier
c'est le Conseil constitutionnel parce
que tout le monde attend la réponse sur
le rythme donc le référendum
d'initiative partagée qui a été déposé
lundi dernier au Conseil constitutionnel
Laurent Fabius aujourd'hui est un
faiseur non pas de roi mais d'échapper
entre guillemets parce que on me dit y
compris au sein de la majorité
présidentielle si le le
plfsr ou RSS le projet de loi qui porte
la réforme des retraites était jugée non
constitutionnel voilà si ce projet doit
constitutionnel ce sera une sortie un
petit peu indirecte qui rendrait service
à certains et en tout cas là aujourd'hui
les espoirs de certains mais pas de tout
au sein de la nuit Pesse porte sur ce
référendum d'initiative partagé 17h on
avait promis de vous lâcher à cette
heure là et ben chose promise chose
qu'on tient nos promesses on va
retrouver merci beaucoup à vous aussi on
va vous lire avec plaisir on va dire
toutes vos dernières infos on va
retrouver Vincent roseron qui se trouve
lui dans le cortège de
syndical Vincent quelle est la quelle
est la situation comment ça se passe
autour de vous
[Musique]
on n'a pas eu la réponse de Vincent on a
eu la réponse en images et les images
étaient éloquantes effectivement dans
cette partie du cortège les choses
étaient assez calme
allez on va le dire assez bonne enfance
bonjour Romain coursier enfin
tout à fait c'était un plaisir donc on
va pas faire partager ce plaisir
j'espère à nos internautes vous restez
avec nous parce que justement
romain est en train de suivre ce que
vous dites à la fois sur le chat du
Figaro à la fois sur le chat de YouTube
et à la fois sur les réseaux du Figaro
et sur l'ensemble des réseaux sociaux
quel est l'ambiance sur les réseaux mon
cher romain
alors sur sur No Life puisque vous en
parlez l'ambiance et assez partagée
entre on va dire des gens qui
encouragent la manifestation on a
notamment des gens qui ont encouragé
depuis le Québec ou depuis le Japon
c'est un petit peu le truc la magie
d'internet on a eu l'Autriche aussi donc
ça on les a beaucoup et de l'autre côté
on a des forcément des internautes un
peu plus critiques envers les
manifestants qui eux sont même alors
chacun fait ses petits calculs sur
est-ce qu'on a besoin de faire des
économies pour financer les retraites
etc chacun y va de son expertise c'est
c'est le lot des tchats des chats comme
ça sur sur Youtube et sur notre sur
notre site Internet et c'est pas un chat
GPT parce que c'est des vrais gens qui
sont des personnes c'est vrai personne
qui sont en train et qu'on salue vous
continuez justement de commenter et de
nous dire alors on voit effectivement
génie qui nous dit vive les manifestants
d'autres qui étaient effectivement
extrêmement critiques qui est dans ces
deux communautés qui sont les plus
mobilisées alors les opposants à la
réforme des retraites sont de très très
loin les plus mobilisés ceux qui font le
plus de bruit et comme on se le disait
un petit peu ce matin ils peuvent
s'appuyer déjà 1 sur les images qu'on
voit là des manifestations monstres
alors que on n'a pas vu de on n'a pas vu
de manifestation pour la réforme des
retraites on en est on en est pas encore
là donc eux ils peuvent s'appuyer sur
ces images de grosses manifestations
évidemment sur les affrontements les
face-à-face et je vous ai fait quelques
petites captures d'écran pour qu'on
fasse un petit peu un tour de France des
manifestations là on est directement à
Nantes donc gros affrontement entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre alors
effectivement on la voit pas encore en
régie finale ça va arriver voilà nous on
avait la chance de la percevoir on avait
l'avant écran exact vous me donnez les
informations que départ en tout cas là
ce que ce que ce que vous vous voyez à
l'écran c'est ce plan où on voit
manifestant à peu près 50 mètres d'un
vraiment d'un barrage de police et une
rue entre les deux joncher de détritus
on sent que on sent qu'il y a eu un
petit peu de un petit peu de casse à ce
niveau là il y a pas canon où ça où ça
manifesté ou c'est un petit peu chauffé
il y a aussi d'autres villes qu'on va
voir dans un instant notamment alors il
y a il y a un petit peu partout je vous
le dis il y a alors là c'est Lorient
c'était une des premières images de la
matinée ou des manifestants ont entre
guillemets sont parvenus à mettre le feu
sur dans le commissariat en tout cas
juste devant le commissariat de police à
l'intérieur sur la dans la cour en fait
du commissariat donc pas pas à
l'intérieur mais donc des images assez
impressionnantes
donc ça c'était à l'Orient maintenant on
va à Rennes traditionnelle un
manifestation exactement Lorient Rennes
c'est ce qui explique justement
on voit clairement les manifestants
jeter des projectiles notamment des
pavés sur sur les forces de l'ordre
d'une vraiment une pluie de projectile
effectivement Rennes Rennes la rouge
comme certains l'appellent ou les
manifestants sont en nombre et sont très
motivés
quand je vois la France je m'inquiète
quand je vois l'étranger singulièrement
les Anglo-Saxons je me les taux dire
anglo-saxons je me rassure nous dit
Julien Jones alors écoutez on prend
effectivement votre commentaire mais
c'est vrai que il y a une inquiétude
également qui monte en tous les cas sur
les sur les réseaux quand on voit un peu
toutes les images de tension et de
violence comme ça si actuellement c'est
en direct on va retourner sur les les
réseaux sociaux apparemment à Marseille
il y avait du monde sur la Canebière le
vieux port là c'est c'est ça qu'on voit
le vieux port noir de monde et
complètement la Canebière mais c'est pas
loin le vieux port c'est là on est sur
le Vieux-Port on est d'accord
donc on est on est donc sur le vieux
port effectivement noir demande pour
pour cette journée de mobilisation et on
a entendu alors ce qui est typique à
Marseille quelque chose presque enfin
normalement dédié à l'Olympique de
Marseille tel que nous sommes les
Marseillais aux armes aux armes et ben
là c'était pour ma manifester contre la
réforme des retraites on va continuer à
regarder ce qui se passe sur les réseaux
sociaux mais on va aller tout de suite
on va retourner boulevard de bonne
nouvelle à Paris où se trouve Timothée
délène les images on les voit tout en
les commentant et tout en commentant la
situation Timothée et c'est extrêmement
extrêmement tendu
oui Vincent je vous confirme une
situation très très tendue depuis de
longues minutes maintenant vous le voyez
sur ces images là c'est un CRS qui est
en train d'évacuer un Vélib qui s'est
retrouvé je sais pas vraiment comment au
milieu de la route au milieu du
boulevard au cours de cet instant de
grande grande tension que vous avez vu
nous nous situons à l'angle en fait
entre la rue du Faubourg de Montmartre
et le boulevard Montmartre donc à
quelques centaines de mètres de la place
de l'Opéra et vous l'avez certainement
vu sur ces images de Julien Leclerc tout
à l'heure
de nombreux manifestants qui s'en sont
pris aux forces de l'ordre qui leur ont
lancé notamment des projectiles
et des et des fumées et des fumées dans
la en leur direction et donc voilà des
feux d'artifice pardon je cherche le
terme on leur direction et donc les
forces de l'ordre qui ont répliqué par
plusieurs charges il y a eu plusieurs
interpellations sous nos yeux il y a eu
également des des tirs de gaz
lacrymogènes là c'est une
en ce moment même si ça reste tendu même
si tout le monde s'observe un petit peu
et vous le voyez le cortège qui est plus
que jamais totalement scindé en deux ce
qui se passe en fait c'est que l'avant
du cortège a fini par par passer
cet angle là entre cette rue du Faubourg
de Montmartre et le boulevard Montmartre
en revanche le cortège des syndicats lui
se trouve loin loin derrière vous le
voyez Julien est en train Julien Leclerc
à la caméra est en train de remonter le
boulevard de Montmartre il vous a montré
donc ce cortège des syndicat mais qui
est complètement bloqué à cause de ces
moments de tension là vous le voyez à
nouveau les forces de l'ordre qui sont
en train de de se déployer et qui sont
la cible de projectile depuis de longues
minutes là vous l'avez vu un pétard qui
vous l'avez entendu un pétard qui qui
vient de d'éclater également des abribus
dont les vitrines sont complètement
brisées et vraiment un moment de de
grande grande tension on a vu certaines
personnes qui se qui ont quitté quitté
les lieux certaines personnes qui sont
venues manifester pacifiquement et qui
subissent et bien la violence de de
certains qui sont venus sans prendre aux
forces de l'ordre immobilier urbain et
qui ont donc décidé de quitter les lieux
et voilà faible à calmer pour le moment
mais le cortège qui est complètement
complètement arrêté et c'est précisément
ce que vous décrivez tout à l'heure
Christophe Cornavin les forces de
l'ordre qui se trouvent dans les rues
adjacentes en l'occurrence la rue du
Faubourg de Montmartre et vous le voyez
sur ces sur ces images très clairement
ils sont positionnées ils ont évidemment
sorti le casque le bouclier certains
également une une matraque pour procéder
aux interpellations et donc il se
tiennent prêt à intervenir en cas
d'éventuelles d'éventuelles débordements
là le le cortège à l'instant qui reprend
les manifestants qui vont peut-être
enfin passer ce ne de tension mais c'est
vrai que c'est c'est très très tendu en
ce moment et on reste évidemment
vraiment très vigilant si beaucoup
Timothée vous restez vigilant et surtout
vous restez prudent merci beaucoup pour
ces précisions romain
ces images en les a on les voit donc à
Paris en ce moment on les a vu également
dans d'autres régions c'est ce que vous
disiez on fait peut-être on continue le
tour des des réseaux sociaux d'autres
images qui ont et qui ont été qui ont
marqué oui et alors juste avant que que
je puisse descendre alors très bien là
on voit tout de suite donc ça c'était ce
matin le blocage du périphérique à
Toulouse vous voyez donc mes situations
qui avait bloqué les rues en enflammant
là encore quelques palettes et autres
poubelles et j'ai pas eu le temps de
vous faire la capture d'écran
mais mais juste avant juste avant que je
descends il y avait à Paris pour le coup
un policier qui a été filmé
en train de perdre connaissance suite à
un projectile en pleine tête donc voilà
ça confirme évidemment les images qu'on
voyait avec Timothée et alors mais sur
les réseaux
d'ailleurs en direct voilà sur les
réseaux sociaux ce matin c'était
effectivement qui aurait des
manifestations qui auraient des
réactions de Gérald Darmanin ça a été le
cas mais ce qui a fait le plus parler ce
qui a même été en top tweet pendant
quelques instants en tout cas pendant
quelques minutes ça a été une séquence
qui est un peu mis de l'huile sur le feu
qui avait fait énormément réagir c'est
une séquence de montre alors je sais pas
si vous y connaissez en montre Vincent
et bah c'était la montre d'Emmanuel
Macron on le voit à l'image alors
Emmanuel Macron pendant son interview à
retiré sa montre
sous la table de façon un petit peu
cachée et certains comme certains
comptent notamment
des comptes insoumis
on voilà on profitait de là exactement
profiter de la séquence mais
actuellement à 80000 euros au moment où
il parlait de gens qui touchent le SMIC
et on essaye de faire un contre-feu du
côté de renaissance et c'est un membre
de Renaissance dont j'ai pris j'ai pris
le tweet qui dit qu'en fait c'est parce
que ça monte voilà taper taper sur la
table qu'il a qu'il a retiré et d'autres
confrères ont essayé de tirer les choses
au clair en disant que la montre était
effectivement une montre de luxe à 2500
€ et non pas à 80 000 € comme ça avait
été comme ça avait été rapporté par par
les parties de gauche en tout cas c'est
une séquence qui a vraiment qui a
vraiment mis de l'huile sur le feu sur
ce jour de manifestation alors justement
donc cette interview me demandait est-ce
que c'est donc c'est vrai la montre et
ben effectivement romain vient de donner
toutes les explications enfin en tous
les cas toutes les informations qui nous
sont parvenues sur ce débat c'est un
petit affaire qui a eu comme ça dans la
prime de guerre
mais est-ce que c'est anecdotique ou
symbolique le débat est lancé merci
beaucoup
romain pour avoir fait la météo des
réseaux sociaux vous faites depuis ce
matin très tôt il va falloir un moment
aller se reposer merci beaucoup on va
retourner sur le
sur le terrain je ne sais pas si Vincent
roseron lui nous entend et pour
l'instant on a personne me dit ton si on
a quand même des images il ne se passe
jamais rien
il se passe effectivement à partager
avec qui est assez calme mais Sylvain
montant et donc
justement
Vincent quelle est l'ambiance autour de
vous
et bien comme depuis le début de cette
manifestation de mon côté en tout cas
l'ambiance est très calme en tout cas
j'ai commencé à avancer pour quitter le
point de la Bastille en fait d'où la
manifestation a débuté derrière moi du
coup il y a maintenant plus de 3h et je
suis avec la CGT et le cortège arrive
petit à petit au niveau de République
voilà nous arrivons au niveau de
République pour cette manifestation
toujours une ambiance dans le toujours
dans le calme avec beaucoup d'élus
croisés tout au long du parcours on est
passé là juste à côté au niveau des des
parties communistes puisque chaque
partie est présent le long tous les
partis qui forcément qui participent à
la manifestation sont tout au long de ce
parcours on les a croisé on a évoque
forcément toujours beaucoup beaucoup de
manifestants toujours une foule assez
dense et on avance du coup jusqu'à opéra
merci beaucoup Vincent ayant continue de
suivre la
ce cortège également ce qui se passe en
tête de cortège avec une tension qui est
plus forte cette fois-ci que les fois
précédentes et on le voit bonjour haute
barietty vous suivez les questions
d'éducation et de jeunesse au service
société du Figaro
effectivement on voit aussi une
population un peu plus jeune non pas sur
les images qui nous parviennent sur le
player mais sur d'autres images qu'on
est en train de voir justement la
jeunesse militante et politique et
particulièrement mobilisée en ce moment
alors je pense que vous avez eu tout à
l'heure mon collègue Christophe du
service société aussi qui est viré
exactement et qui vous a sûrement dit
que dans tous les incidents qui éclatent
en ce moment chaque soir depuis
l'utilisation du 49-3 on voit une
jeunesse qui se mobilise une jeunesse
plusieursaine plus politisée peut-être
que celle des gilets jaunes mais
vraiment une jeunesse c'est plus un
mouvement finalement de jeunes qu'un
mouvement vraiment étudiant ou lycéen on
voit évidemment des répercussions de de
de cet engagement de la jeunesse dans
les lycées dans les universités on y
reviendra sûrement mais on le voit
surtout dans les manifestations que vous
voyez là à l'écran et puis le soir quand
des incidents éclatent comment se se
passe le blocage des facs on a vu des
facs qui habituellement n'étaient pas
bloqués notamment la faculté d'Assas à
Paris qui est-ce qui bloque sont les
étudiants Assas alors c'est vrai que
c'est une spécificité de cette 9e
journée de mobilisation il y a des facs
des campus qui d'habitude sont rarement
bloqués qui le sont vous citiez à ça je
pense aussi à Dauphine je pense aussi à
Lyon 3 je pense à le ns Lyon donc c'est
vrai des des campus qu'on veut bien
croire parce que là effectivement c'est
quand même des campus qu'on a moins
l'habitude de voir
que de Léa ça c'est vraiment une
première façon ça fait vraiment
longtemps alors c'est difficile de
savoir exactement qui sont les personnes
qui bloquent ça je vous invite
d'ailleurs à suivre le travail que font
mes collègues du Figaro étudiant qui qui
étaient sur le terrain toute la journée
pour suivre ça mais il y a à la fois une
partie d'étudiants eux-mêmes bien sûr et
puis il y a toujours des éléments
extérieurs ça c'est un classique qui
viennent se rajouter parfois des
demandes des syndicats et puis parfois
des d'autres militants qui viennent et
qui sans être étudiants comment
d'ailleurs les étudiants de droite dans
ces cas-là réagissent ils courent comme
d'habitude ils courent la tête non
attendant que je pense évidemment je
pense qu'il rappelle que le blocage
n'est pas quelque chose de normal enfin
c'est à dire qu'il y a d'autres et
d'ailleurs les les militants les plus
modérés le disent il y a d'autres
manières de faire entendre sa colère que
de bloquer sa fac et d'empêcher les
autres de travailler il peut avoir des
rassemblements il peut avoir des
âgés qui sont mis à dispositif qui sont
faites dans des locaux qui sont parfois
mis à disposition par les établissements
enfin voilà il y a toutes sortes de de
moyens pour faire entendre sa voix le
blocage en étude mais c'est pas
forcément le plus légal
la mobilisation est-elle forte
aujourd'hui dans l'enseignement alors
dans l'enseignement de manière générale
donc sur les sur l'enseignement
supérieur c'est assez difficile à
chiffrer le ministère d'ailleurs
l'enseignant supérieur ne donne pas de
chiffres parce que en fait il y a
vraiment une différence est-ce que un
campus bloqué un site bloqué ça veut
dire toute une fac bloquée il y a des il
y a des établissements qui étaient
bloqués ce matin et d'autres pas il y en
a ces partiels complets bref en revanche
dans l'enseignement on a des chiffres du
ministère de l'Éducation nationale sur
les profs notamment je les rappelle vous
en avez sûrement déjà parlé mais
aujourd'hui selon le ministère aussi 21
ans encore mieux on est à 21% selon le
ministère de d'enseignants grévistes
avec 23% dans le premier degré les
écoles et 19% dans le second degré les
collèges et les lycées ça ce sont les
chiffres du ministère c'est en deux ça
de ce qu'annonce les syndicats alors
c'est ça qui est intéressant alors
est-ce que c'est deux choses c'est de ça
c'est quand même ces syndicats mais
est-ce que ce qu'annonce ces syndicats
étant de ça de ce qu'on observe
habituellement ou non
alors
si la question est de savoir si là c'est
la plus forte mobilisation de
l'éducation nationale la réponse est
clairement non la plus forte
mobilisation des enseignants selon les
chiffres du ministère mais on voit aussi
les appréciations des syndicats c'était
la toute première la toute première
journée parce que on a observé la même
tendance dans les transports sont des
secteurs qui se mobilisent surtout sur
ce genre de cause sur ce genre de
dossier et là on voit que même dans un
secteur qui se mobilise massivement
habituellement là encore il y a moins de
moins de mobilisation alors il y a
plusieurs éléments d'abord le neuvième
jour de mobilisation pour certains ce
n'est pas anodin sur la fiche de paix
évidemment ensuite il y a forcément un
peu de lassitude qui s'installe même si
je pense que les intervenants mes
collègues qui étaient avant moi sur
plateau l'ont dit aussi le 49-3
l'utilisation du 49-3 par le
gouvernement à l'Assemblée nationale
constitue vraiment un vrai virage il y a
plusieurs profs étudiants voilà auprès
desquels on comprend qu'ils étaient
prêts à voilà que ça s'essoufflé un peu
et que là ça a redonné un nouveau un
nouveau souffle au mouvement puisque il
n'est plus en question de retraite
peut-être pour certains que d'opposition
au gouvernement quel est l'impact de la
réforme pour les enseignants alors pour
les enseignants ça les fait partir par
partir plus tôt comme comme certains
l'âge de légal de départ à la retraite à
64 ans et puis un taux plein à 43 ans un
peu comme d'autres professions ceux qui
sont opposés disent que voilà c'est trop
fatiguant pour eux d'être devant des
classes surtout des classes un peu
bondées aussi tard après dans le cas des
enseignants il y a deux choses il y a
évidemment la protestation contre la
réforme des retraites mais il y a aussi
beaucoup d'autres éléments de
protestations en ce moment il y a un
climat très tendu entre syndicat
enseignants et le ministère je sais pas
si vous avez vu passer ça mais il y
avait il y a quelques jours quelques
semaines une réunion sur le pacte ce
qu'on appelle le pacte c'est ce qui est
en train d'essayer de mettre en place
paper Ndiaye des nouvelles missions
qu'on trouve une rémunération pour les
enseignants et tous les syndicats ont
quitté la table des négociations et
internautes AB risque-t-on des
perturbations dans l'organisation des
examens et concours à venir alors bonne
question déjà on peut se poser la
question de ce qui s'est passé lundi et
mardi puisque je le rappelle si vous
n'avez pas d'enfants de frère de sœur
d'amis concernés le bac ça a commencé
cette année dès le mois de mars c'était
lundi et mardi les épreuves de
spécialité pour la première fois donc la
question c'est vraiment posée on a
vraiment travaillé toute la semaine
dernière pour savoir si oui ou non ces
épreuves allaient être perturbées on
sentait une profession les enseignants
très divisés avec certains qui disaient
le 49-3 c'est un c'est un grand nom il
faut se mobiliser même pendant le bac et
beaucoup d'autres qui ne voulaient pas
perturber les élèves dans la préparation
de de cet examen et finalement ça s'est
plutôt bien passé là il y a des épreuves
du bac c'est la première année que les
épreuves du bac sont si tôt pour
l'instant elles sont elles sont pas
touchées plus que ça non lundi et mardi
ça s'est bien passé il y a eu des
rassemblements il y a eu des choses des
choses organisées mais il y a pas eu de
grosses perturbations dans
l'organisation de ces épreuves
d'ailleurs à un syndicat me disait que
le problème de de bloquer des épreuves
c'est que ça retourne l'opinion publique
contre vous ce qui n'est pas forcément
le l'idéal pour un mouvement comme
celui-ci on va revenir il y a d'autres
questions qui sont posées je voudrais
qu'on aille justement retourner sur les
grands boulevards avec Timothée délai la
situation ne s'est visiblement pas calmé
Timothée comment ça se passe autour de
vous
oui et bien vous l'avez dit Vincent
c'est très tendu toujours vous voyez
cette cette colonne de CRS là qui est en
train de remonter les grands boulevards
parce que le cortège a j'allais dire
enfin fini par par reprendre sa marche
en avant et là ce qu'il est ce qui est
en train de se passer et bien c'est que
le cortège syndical celui qui manifeste
pacifiquement depuis tout à l'heure
étant en train d'arriver on va demander
à Julien Leclerc de vous montrer ce
cortège avec par exemple ce ballon
solidaire avec les drapeaux
traditionnels des syndicats par exemple
la CGT que j'aperçois que j'aperçois là
suite dry également et donc ça c'est le
cortège syndical qui est en train
d'arriver je vous parlais de
manifestation pacifique il suffit que je
dise cela pour qu'un projectile soit
lancé en direction des forces de l'ordre
sous mes yeux à l'instant mais c'est
vrai qu'il y a vraiment vraiment une
manifestation deux ambiances cet
après-midi ce que vous voyez là devant
vous et bien c'est le premier cortège
parce que le cortège vous le rappelle a
été coupé en deux par les forces de
l'ordre à cause de ces moments de
tension le premier cortège qui lui est
donc passé il y a quelques minutes
devant nous et voilà toujours ces scènes
de de grandes tensions vous voyez les
CRS qui ont sorti le bouclier le casque
et vous voyez également c'est camions de
CRS avec voilà c'est leur phare que l'on
voit allumer en fait nous sommes à la
fin de ce boulevard de Montmartre et
nous sommes en train de bifurquer
boulevard des Italiens et donc c'est ces
quarts de CRS qui ont pour objectif
d'empêcher le cortège de quitter le
périmètre déclaré en préfecture afin que
voilà les manifestants empruntent bel et
bien le boulevard des Italiens et non
pas le boulevard Haussmann et qui se
dirige donc vers cette place de l'Opéra
la place de l'Opéra qui se trouve
maintenant à une à une centaine de
mètres peut-être 200 mètres de l'endroit
où nous trouvons actuellement alors que
vous l'entendez c'est vrai que c'est
très particulier parce que là nous nous
trouvons vraiment à la jonction entre
les deux cortèges donc il y a d'un côté
beaucoup d'infectif contre les forces de
l'ordre et de l'autre et bien ce cortège
qui manifeste davantage pacifiquement et
qui est en train maintenant de nous
rejoindre
si beaucoup Timothée pour pour ces
précisions ici ça permet un autre qui me
demande et qui fait cette remarque
également il l'éducation nationale comme
notre système de santé est à bout de
souffle est-ce que c'est pas à cause de
la dévalorisation de ces métiers alors
c'est vrai je le disais à l'instant
avant qu'on entende ce qui se passe un
peu dans la manifestation qu'il y a une
vraie grogne enseignante en ce moment et
notamment une guérison de cette grogne
c'est que les enseignants disent que ils
se sentent dévalorisés et que leur
métier n'attire plus pour plein de
raisons et notamment sur ce côté de
dévalorisation qu'il ressente et ça
c'est vrai que c'est un chantier un
énorme chantier pour le gouvernement
parce que s'il n'y a plus de prof de
main dans les classes les élèves
n'apprendront plus
le ministère
qu'est-ce qui fait pas pendent
pas alors si de ce qu'on comprend pas
écoute rencontres d'ailleurs ça avait
été salué au départ par les syndicats il
saluait vraiment une amélioration selon
sur la forme par rapport au précédent
ministre Jean-Michel Blanquer mais après
il applique le programme de d'Emmanuel
Macron et les syndicats nouvelles les
syndicats ne veulent pas les problèmes
d'Emmanuel Macron et ça c'est sûr que
c'était un problème qui risque de de se
poser à plus long terme
question
est-ce que la jeunesse
que l'on voit dans tous les cas
dont certains de ses membres sont en
train de manifester s'intéressent de
plus en plus
à cette réforme ou c'est le juste le
fait d'une minorité
on voit en tout cas et c'est ce que
disait tout à l'heure mes collègues du
figure étudiant que c'est vraiment cette
fois-ci il y a beaucoup plus de jeunes
que dans d'autres journées de
mobilisation après comme je vous disais
tout à l'heure on comprend que
évidemment la retraite concerne certains
après pas tout le monde certains disent
ça me paraît un peu loin mais d'autres
sont vraiment déjà mobilisés là-dessus
mais c'est quand même plutôt la question
du 49-3 de l'utilisation de ce 49-3 qui
a déclenché peut-être plus de
mobilisation de la jeunesse plus en
termes d'opposition au gouvernement et à
ce qui représente plutôt que sur la
réforme de la retraite en elle-même
alors je m'adresse des gens qui en soi
s'expriment sur le sur le chat avec des
termes extrêmement violents toutes les
opinions et tous les points de vue sont
encendables et défendable mais par
contre il y a une charte de modération
donc tout ce qui est les insultes les
appels à la violence seront en vertu de
cette charte automatiquement
systématiquement banni et je demande au
modérateur de le faire et pour le reste
il n'y a aucun problème pour les
expressions de d'opinion
la question il y avait plein de
questions à cette internaute nous dit de
moi est-ce qu'il y a des soignants
est-ce qu'il y a des pompiers des
soignants suspendus alors ça c'est sur
d'autres questions qu'il y a dans les
manifs mais ça on va justement essayer
de voir se renseigner est-ce que ce
genre de revendication se trouve dans
ces dans ces manifestations pour
l'instant ce qu'on a vu c'est
essentiellement des slogans autour de la
réforme des retraites pour les
enseignants est-ce que aujourd'hui il y
a d'autres choses à l'agenda quelles
sont les priorités en tous les cas les
principales revendications du corps
ensemble
cette cette partie de la revalorisation
salariale avec à la fois une
revalorisation salariale
inconditionnelle dont papa Ndiaye a
parlé et puis d'une partie conditionnée
pour le coup à de nouvelles missions
c'est le fameux pacte dont on parlait
donc ça c'est déjà un gros point
il y a la question des conditions de
travail il y a la question de la
retraite puisque on est là pour ça après
qui concerne peut-être pas forcément
directement les enseignants enfin pas
que eux en tout cas il y a toute la
question de la mixité sociale et
scolaire ça on attend des annonces
là-dessus dans l'enseignement supérieur
on attend des annonces sur les bourses
également voilà il y a pas mal de
chantiers après c'est vrai que comme
dans d'autres dans d'autres secteurs et
on l'a vu par exemple avec la loi
immigration on sent que pour l'instant
la mobilisation la grogne sociale
est-elle qu'il y a pas mal d'annonces de
choses qui sont mis en stand-by on va
retourner place de la République des
images en ce moment avec qui nous sont
pas place de la République se place de
l'Opéra il me semble c'est à la
destination finale arrivée du cortège
que l'on voit
assez saine on va essayer de retrouver
Timothée délaime qui est sur place une
question il y a deux questions de
sociologie car c'est peut-être pas y
répondre vous pouvez répondre si vous
avez la réponse mais quelle est la
sociologie des manifestants est-ce que
c'est la France d'en haut le
ministration du clivage France d'en haut
France d'en bas en tous les cas ce que
disait Guillaume Rocket qui avait été
tout à l'autre jour à la place de la
Concorde où il y avait les premières
manifestations violentes la sociologie
et c'est ce que indiqué également
Christophe Cornavin dans son papier la
sociologie de ces manifestations non
déclarées que certains qualifiés
manifestations sauvages manifestations
illégales en tous les cas ces
manifestations non déclarées c'est de la
jeunesse quartier
urbain urbain enchaînement sur supérieur
donc plutôt CSP puiser mais c'est pas la
sociologie par contre ou la géographie
des manifestants contre la réforme des
retraites en particulier en région et ça
c'est ce que on peut avoir notamment la
réponse et je vous engage à les regarder
tout ce qu'a fait le feed data Arthur
bizota qui était là avec nous tout à
l'heure on retrouve Timothée délène qui
fait route vers la place de l'Opéra
Timothée vous avez mis votre casque et
celle-ci que les choses quand même ne
s'apaisent pas
effectivement mais avec une charge à
l'instant même
voilà vous le voyez sur ces images de
Julien Leclerc on lisait des grands
moments de tension et bien vous en avez
l'illustration sous vos yeux Vincent
avec donc cette charge de CRS un CRS là
qui vient voilà tomber au sol
était la cible
de projectiles et la foule est bien
qu'ils étaient exclamé lorsque ce CRS
est tombé au sol voilà il y a vraiment
une une ambiance de grande tension on le
voit également là-bas des mouvements de
full au loin que que Julien est en train
de vous montrer donc c'est vrai que
cette fin de cette fin de cortège est
vraiment vraiment très tendu ça se passe
vraiment dans le désordre et on se
demande un peu comment on va finir par
arriver sur cette place de l'Opéra parce
que on est en fait vraiment arrêté
maintenant toutes les toutes les 5
minutes voilà ça ça reprend un moment de
tension un moment où tout le monde
s'observe une charge de CRS pour calmer
tout ça des gaz lacrymogènes des
projectiles qui sont lancés contre eux
une anecdote peut-être tout à l'heure
nous discutions avec avec Julien Leclerc
nous discutons avec eux une femme d'une
quarantaine d'années qui avait perdu son
enfant dans la foule parce que vous
l'imaginez bien ces mouvements de foule
ces moments de tension et bien ce sont
des moments où nous les premiers
d'ailleurs avec Julien parfois nous nous
perdons parce que évidemment on fait
attention et donc voilà cette dame qui
cherchait son enfant qu'elle avait
qu'elle avait perdu donc c'est vrai que
c'est c'est vraiment très confus et vous
le voyez les CRS là qui se sont déployés
donc au milieu de ce boulevard des
Italiens le cortège qui est une nouvelle
fois coupé en deux derrière cette
colonne de CRS c'est le cortège des
syndicats vous voyez d'ailleurs
peut-être le ballon du syndicat
solidaire donc ça c'est le cortège des
syndicats et devant voilà de l'autre
côté c'est donc l'avant du cortège avec
notamment ces groupes violents avec ces
jeunes habillés habillés en noir et qui
ont donc endommagé du mobilier
urbain et qui s'entraîne régulièrement
aux forces de l'ordre lesquelles et bien
riposte par des tirs de gaz lacrymogène
on continue à suivre cette situation
merci beaucoup
Timothée on retrouvera également
Vincent Rozon qui est lui le plus à
l'arrière du cortège dans une ambiance
plus calme bonjour Guillaume Tabar
bonjour Vincent chroniqueur politique au
Figaro auteur du contrepoint et
éditorialiste on vous a écouté ce matin
avec beaucoup d'attention à beaucoup de
plaisir sur Radio Classique pour la
problématique Le Figaro
d'abord un regard sur cette mobilisation
il y a des internautes qui disent qui
nous remercient effectivement de
distinguer les deux parties du cortège
en disant que le cortège
majoritaire n'est pas un cortège violent
et ça c'est sûr ce qu'on voit sur
l'image et de bien faire le distinguer
moi je vais être un peu provocateur mais
dans des manifestations entre guillemets
de droite il y en a beaucoup moins on
n'a pas le suivant le problème non même
dans les manifestations de droite comme
nous appelez il y a même jamais eu même
le moindre abribus cassait pour prendre
alors autrefois celle le pour l'école
libre ou plus récemment les manifs pour
tous ou il n'y avait pas eu le moindre
notamment avec Manuel Valls avec le
mouvement du printemps français à la
manifestation
de la part des des manifestants même là
on se retrouve dans un scénario qui
rappelle les manifs sociales j'allais
dire des années des années Hollande
enfin des années Hollande avec les
manifs contre la loi el khomri ou
ensuite même sous
sous Emmanuel Macron ce premier
quinquennat je me souviens des
manifestations lors des lois de travail
ça les fameuses ordonnances travail qui
assouplissent le code du travail
également des manifs très violentes
notamment la manif du 1er mai ça devait
donc être le 1er mai 2018 où là encore
avec un cortège classique on avait vu
ensuite arriver les les Black Blocs bon
je pense que cette journée elle marque
un tournant à deux points de vue 1 et
finalement par rapport aux
manifestations elles-mêmes et par
rapport au mouvement syndical c'est que
c'est vrai que sur les 8 premières
journées
tous les syndicats avaient réussi à se
dire leur manifestation il y a eu aucun
débordement et tout le monde avait
souligné le calme la sérénité et la
maîtrise des manifestations de rue même
on avait même opposé la sérénité de la
rue aux énervements auxquels on
insistait au sein de l'hémicycle à
l'Assemblée nationale donc ça c'est un
premier tournant maintenant on voit bien
que les black-box ou les violents ou
ultra gauche violentes
maintenant ce mêle à ces manifesteuses
assez manifestations le moment venu fera
aussi s'interroger entre le lien entre
ces Black Blocs et puis quand même
j'allais dire le le visage politique de
l'ultra gauche parce que voilà on voit
bien qu'il y a des syndrome d'appels à
durcir le le durcir la mobilisation qui
vient de la part des dirigeants en clair
de defi bon ça n'est pas totalement sans
lien avec cette énervement qui montre on
va peut-être on va peut-être y revenir
je voudrais que on retrouve Vincent
Rosemont qui lui est sur place est avec
Yannick Jadot c'est peut-être une
question d'ailleurs qu'on peut lui poser
Vincent vous avez la
[Applaudissements]
oui bonjour Vincent je suis
effectivement merci d'être avec nous
aujourd'hui
déjà une question sur la mobilisation
aujourd'hui est-ce que la mobilisation
pour vous ce que vous voyez c'est une
réussite aujourd'hui écoutez je pense
que ça va être la mobilisation record de
contre cette réforme et on voit bien à
quel point finalement les Français
veulent faire la plus belle des réponses
à Emmanuel Macron à son mépris à sa
brutalité c'est la plus belle des
réponses dans la démocratie qui nous
reste celle de la mobilisation dans la
rue puisque Emmanuel Macron a considéré
que la démocratie sociale ne valait pas
le coup d'être exercé et qu'il a écrasé
la démocratie parlementaire qu'est-ce
que ce sera les les futurs étapes avec
cette mobilisation aujourd'hui 600 000
personnes d'après la CGT représente
aujourd'hui mais la future étape c'est
le retrait de la loi c'est Emmanuel
Macron qui bloque le pays aujourd'hui ce
sont pas les 80% de Français qui sont
opposés à sa loi on est quand même à un
moment dans une crise de régime qui est
totalement absurde vous avez toutes les
semaines des millions de Français qui
disent leur opposition et tous les
autres qui les soutiennent on le voit
dans toutes les enquêtes d'opinion et
Emmanuel Macron qui aujourd'hui par
orgueil tient une réforme qui est
considérée injuste par 80% des Français
donc c'est à Emmanuel Macron de retirer
la loi c'est ça la prochaine étape
est-ce que parce que on l'a entendu hier
il a pas l'air vraiment en tout cas
Emmanuel Macron n'avait pas l'air de
d'être enclin à le faire écouter
Emmanuel Macron hier il a expliqué que
80% des Français opposaient à cette
réforme étaient dans le déni de réalité
que ceux qui manifestaient ou qui
soutenaient les manifestants étaient des
factieux il a spontanément attaqué la
sève d'été et les syndicats et il nous a
expliqué qu'au fond c'était nous le
désordre non il est en train de non
seulement il bloque le pays mais il est
en train de l'embraser et c'est
totalement irresponsable je comprends
pas comment un président de la
République avec ce qui se passe dans ce
pays peut faire une telle intervention
comme il l'a fait hier midi notamment
sur les sur les débordements des
manifestations les premières
manifestations en tout cas toutes
celles-ci jusque-là se dérouler
globalement dans le calme il semblerait
que depuis le début la manifestation en
tête de cortège ce soit beaucoup plus
agité il y a beaucoup plus de
débordements comment vous réagissez à ça
mais on voyait bien que et y compris on
le voit tous les médias réalisent
aujourd'hui qu'il y a une violence
policière organisée moi j'ai plein de
témoignages de jeunes qui viennent
manifester très pacifiquement et qui à
un moment donné se retrouve Nasser il se
retrouve gazé violenté sans avoir eu
aucun geste violent et ça c'est
inacceptable notre démocratie elle
devrait fonctionner par le social ce que
le président de la République conteste
devrait fonctionner au Parlement qui a
été rejeté par le Président de la
République et sinon dans la rue le droit
de manifester c'est essentiel et vous
avez notre pacte républicain c'est son
les libertés et c'est le modèle social
notamment
issu du Conseil National de la
Résistance c'est tout ce qui est en
train de casser manuel Macron c'est très
inquiétant le
référendum initiative partagé est-ce que
c'est quelque chose dont vous croyez
justement pour faire sortir pour sortir
de cette crise bien sûr qu'il y aura le
dépôt du référendum d'initiative
partagée s'il est accepté mais je crois
que là le Conseil constitutionnel à
toutes les raisons de sanctionner cette
loi à la fois par le véhicule législatif
qui a été choisi
une loi corrective de du projet de loi
de finance sur la sécurité sociale et
sur la façon on a eu le 44 3 on a eu le
47 de on a eu le 47,3 enfin je veux dire
on est plus en démocratie on est en
permanence à utiliser des des dans la
Constitution certes mais pour écraser le
débat parlementaire c'est irresponsable
merci beaucoup monsieur Jadot voilà
Vincent ce que disait que j'adore ancien
candidat à la présidentielle pour Europe
Écologie Les Verts merci beaucoup
Vincent et vous retrouvera un petit peu
plus tard Guillaume peut-être un
commentaire sur ce qu'on vient
d'entendre de la part de Yannick Jadot
et en particulier sur cette question des
violences en tous les cas il n'y a pas
de remise en cause de violence de
manifestants oui c'est étonnant
d'entendre Yannick Jadot
accusé manuel Macron de ne pas voir le
moindre de ne pas se remettre en cause
de pas se poser la moindre question etc
et en face d'être aussi enfermé dans tel
raisonnement
absolu parce qu'évidemment on voit bien
que cette spirale de contestation de
bascule dans la violence peut conduire à
une situation inextricable ou voilà ou
le pays soit bloqué vous êtes en train
de dire c'est une partie de la gauche la
France insoumise ou peut-être là Yannick
Jadot joue un peu avec le feu bah
écoutez oui il fallait
des mots pour parler du débat
parlementaire qui qui dramatise les
choses c'est-à-dire comme si il s'était
pas quelque chose d'anormal le recours à
un 49-3 le vote de l'émotion de censure
on peut dire que c'est des outils qui
peuvent être débattus voire contester
son pouvoir institutionnel mais qui sont
restes des outils à disposition de de de
la démocratie et que tous les
gouvernements utilisés en ce moment on
est en train de revoir beaucoup une
vidéo d'olive et fort Olivier Faure
aujourd'hui qui qui hurle au déni de
démocratie et qui lorsqu'il était député
socialiste François Hollande défendait
le recours aux 49-3 pour la loi el
khomri de la même manière qu'aujourd'hui
les députés de la majorité voilà donc on
est quelque part d'un posture classique
c'est-à-dire que quand on est dans la
majorité on défend les outils
institutionnels qui permettent d'avancer
et lorsqu'on est dans l'opposition on
les critique ça c'est le jeu normal mais
on voit bien comment aujourd'hui
ce qu'on politique vise à
presque à illégitimer le processus
parlementaire et à légitimer un
mouvement de rue qui en quand même en
train on le voit sur images qui est
quand même en train de de basculer dans
quelque chose de d'inquiétant
sur la question politique puisque les
questions institutionnelles Yannick
Jadot posait la question du référendum
d'initiative populaire alors peut-être
où est-ce qu'on en est sur cette sur
cette question là écoutez le premier
terme c'est que le Conseil consuel doit
examiner la recevabilité de ce rythme
cette demande de référendum d'initiative
partagée
il y a pas grand doute là-dessus oui il
va être recevable par définition cette
procédure existe après il faudra
recueillir environ 4,8 millions de
signatures en gros c'est 10% du corps
électoral donc ça fait 4,8 millions de
signatures on voit bien que cet objectif
qui est très ambitieux n'est pas hors de
portée mais après ça ça n'est qu'une
première étape et ensuite il suffit que
les que l'assemblée décide d'inscrire à
leur ordre du jour le sujet pour que il
n'y ait pas lieu de faire un référendum
donc ce sera certainement ce qui va se
passer donc en clair quasiment aucune
raison qu'une chance d'aller jusqu'au
référendum sur les sur les retraites
pardon donc justement si ça se passe là
est-ce que ça pose pas
un autre problème c'est à dire que vous
avez près dans ce cas-là près de 5
millions de signatures ce qui ne sait
jamais vu et on va par un mécanisme
institutionnel de la démocratie
représente dites représentative essayer
de faire barrage à cette à cet élan je
vais pas dire populaire mais enfin en
tout cas de 5 millions de citoyens c'est
c'est pareil est-ce que c'est pas encore
le signal donné que le pays
institutionnel s'oppose à au pays qui
est plus populaire citoyen le pays
institutionnel il est quand même
lui-même le fruit du pays réel là encore
c'est un peu tout le
débats et Emmanuel Macron s'est fait
vertement critiquer pour avoir
osé c'est la question de 2005 que je
vous pose à travers ça alors on a un
référendum et puis après là c'est très
différent 2005 on a un référendum auprès
de l'ensemble du corps électoral c'est
c'est c'est c'est c'est
qui choisit d'aller aux urnes sur un sur
un sur un traité un traité européen et
voilà qui qui se traité qui qui échoue
donc voilà on est quand même pas du tout
dans le même dans le même dans le même
scénario donc pour revenir quand même à
la journée d'aujourd'hui je parlais
quand même d'une double rupture on y
ruptures c'est que on passe d'une de
cortège
garni totalement serein il paisible à
des cortèges qui maintenant sont
gangrenés par par de la violence le
second tournant c'est que
des réformes des retraites
elles ont toutes suscité une
conversation dans la rue forte au moins
aussi forte que celle d'aujourd'hui la
réforme de 2010 elle Sarkozy il y avait
aussi 3 millions de personnes dans les
rues mais en 2003 comme en 2010 une fois
que la réforme a été votée à l'Assemblée
le mouvement de rue c'est effondré il y
a toujours eu une journée qui a suivi et
il y avait je sais pas moi 50000
personnes dans les rues parce que voilà
en gros la fin du processus
parlementaire marqué la fin du mouvement
de protestation or là le processus
parlementaire est terminé la loi est
adoptée puisque le rejet de la boisson
censure conduit à l'adoption
ipso facto de la loi or là malgré que le
processus parlementaire soit achevé on
voit bien que la contestation
de rue la conception populaire pour la
forme sociale ou politique non seulement
elle ne tombe pas d'elle-même mais elle
aurait plutôt tendance à s'amplifier
puisque c'est vrai qu'on est des
chiffres
au moins le record du 7 mars voilà et ça
pour le gagnant c'est embêtant parce que
il faut tenir il faut tenir face à la
rue le temps que on discute de la loi
une fois que la loi est votée ça y est
c'est derrière nous bah là pour Emmanuel
Macron non le mouvement n'est pas
derrière lui
on passe d'un acte 1 qui était de la
contestation de la réforme des retraites
un acte 2 qui devient une contestation
plus générale contre le président
lui-même et contre sa politique la
manifestation la mobilisation le fait
lui pas ce que dit Laurent Berger cet
après-midi
il y a une question
de l'internaute qui dit mais où sont
donc les les républicains moi je voulais
vous poser une question un petit peu
différente on a beaucoup glosé sur le
silence de Laurent Wauquiez notamment
en 2011 il avait écrit un livre j'ai
appris ça sur la révolte des classes
moyen
et pas contre cette réforme c'est que si
on assistait qu'à une division des
députés LR d'ailleurs ça arrive voilà
mais là je pense que l'électorat
lui-même est divisé on croyait que
c'était un fond un totem des LR mais on
s'aperçoit que c'est moins un totem de
électorat qu'un totem du parti oui mais
qu'est-ce qu'on appelle les enfin plus
exactement aujourd'hui il faut
distinguer le lecteur a LR électorat de
droite
on a on a dit beaucoup au cours de ces
dernières années que le pays avait bascu
à droite en tout cas été majoritairement
à droite et je crois qu'il est
effectivement majoritairement à droite
peut-être même très très majoritairement
à droite or le le parti les républicains
c'est 5% à la présidentielle c'est 10%
pour législatives si on dit qu'on est
dans un pays qui est à droite à 50 ou
60%. ça veut dire que toute la droite
aujourd'hui ne se connaît pas dans LR
bon et peut-être l'une des difficultés
de LR c'est que
ceux qui sont qui voulaient de cette
réforme ils sont chez Macron et ce n'est
pas avec l'attitude que l'on a vu de LR
qui vont récupérer ceux qui ont ceux qui
étaient déjà partis chez Macron et
versement avec cette position floue et
en tout cas c'est pas non plus comme ça
qui vont récupérer le lecteur à passer
au rassemblement national et en tête
cause pour revenir au silence de leur
évoqué je ne suis pas sûr que le silence
soit le meilleur moyen pour convaincre
des électeurs
les droites doit-elle accepter l'offre
de coalition de Manuel Macron
d'abord il y a pas d'offre c'est une
bonne matière à contrepoint ça oui mais
je pense que avant de répondre à cette
question faudrait que que les conditions
d'une réponse existent or il n'existe
pas c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui que
Emmanuel Macron et ce qui veut vraiment
devrait accords de coalition dire ok on
discute de notre programme
qu'est-ce qui est essentiel pour vous à
droite qu'est-ce qui est sur cette pour
nous et puis on construit un programme
de codition il n'a pas proposé ça oui il
y a 16 ans les rejoignez nous
ensuite
il a existé sur les retraites le
gouvernement a recherché et à trouver un
accord avec les républicains avec le
président du parti et avec les
présidents des deux groupes au Parlement
Bruno Retailleau au Sénat Olivier marlex
Assemblée nationale donc cette offre et
cette proposition d'accord elle a été
faite et elle a été reçue mais on a vu
que ça ne servait c'était rien parce que
c'est parce qu'il y a eu un accord avec
trois dirigeants de LR que le groupe a
suivi donc aujourd'hui quand bien même
quand bien même les dirigeants de l'ère
disaient ok banco pour les troupes
parlementaires ne suivraient pas et
ensuite à fortiori de l'électorat ne
suivraient pas enfin
vous savez pour faire une collision il
faut que les deux parties soient fortes
dans une chaîne si les deux parties de
la chaîne ne sont pas fortes et ben la
chaîne elle casse or aujourd'hui
LR et affaiblie est divisée comme jamais
Emmanuel Macron on le voit en ce moment
et affaibli comme il et son gouvernement
ils sont affaiblis comme ils ne l'ont
jamais été et c'est pas l'alliance de
deux faibles qui peut faire une force
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui ce scénario
là a peu de chance de de choses aboutir
et les événements peut-elle doit-elle en
rester à matinignon alors ça c'est à
Emmanuel Macron qu'il faut poser le la
question on peut dire plusieurs choses
on peut dire un que elle a fait le job
qui lui était demandé on lui a demandé
de porter une réforme des retraites elle
l'a porté elle l'a porté il faut le dire
de manière plutôt courageux même de
manière courageuse de manière assez
solide de manière déterminée elle a pas
lâché le morceau bon et c'est ce qu'on
lui demandait et à l'arrivée le texte
non sans mal mais est adopté maintenant
est-ce qu'elle a la capacité
d'enclencher un nouvel élan politique
c'est une autre question et on entend
déjà beaucoup de voix au sein même de la
majorité et j'ajouterai même pour la
suite de coûter téléphone de cette toute
dernière jour au sein même de son
gouvernement beaucoup de gens qui disent
non elle ne peut pas continuer
parce qu'elle est trop affaiblie parce
qu'elle n'a pas réussi à construire une
condition etc fort bien mais qui voilà
le problème c'est que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui le nœud politique devant
lequel nous sommes ça a la capacité à
faire aboutir des textes de manière
majoritaire c'est pas un problème de
personne c'est pas de la faute
d'Elizabeth borne c'est en raison de
l'absence de majorité et ça c'est pas ni
parce qu'on va changer le Premier
ministre ni à la limite parce qu'on va
faire entre gouvernement un député LR
qui aura voté qui aurait été prêté la
réforme que ça va changer
structurellement la situation
l'Assemblée nationale
Alexis Brésil disait tout à l'heure la
situation est quand même compliquée
parce que soit
la réforme est menée jusqu'au bout mais
finalement après ça va être très
difficile de faire d'autres d'autres
réformes soit
la réforme ne se fait pas alors là il y
a plus rien qui se fait
on glose aussi de chacun est parti
politique mais profondément à ce que la
révélation de cette séquence là c'est
que la situation du du pays est quand
même le pays se retourne dans une
situation de risque d'indécision
qui n'a pas été connue depuis la fin de
la quatrième République oui et c'est
peut-être là finalement le le grand
échec d'Emmanuel Macron pas sur cette
réforme mais sur l'ensemble de ces
mandats c'est que et Emmanuel Macron a
été élu sur une promesse de
révolutionner le pays révolutionner au
sens de effectivement on voit des images
mais c'était peut-être révolution qui
date
révolution
casser des faire sauter des blocages
casser des corporatismes remettre le
pays sur de bons rails pour se trouve le
chemin de la croissance économique le
chemin de l'émancipation individuelle
donc oui il fallait faire sauter des
verrous bon il en a fait sauter
quelques-uns on a parlé de la fin du
marché du travail lors de son premier
mandat la réforme des retraites était
aussi un moyen de de réforme mais pour
dire que ou pas ou pas enfin voilà oui
bon mais en tout cas il y a maintenant
il y a des verrous à faire sauter à
l'école dans le monde la santé dans le
monde dans le dans dans le
fonctionnement de l'État et on voit
qu'aujourd'hui même cette réforme est
adoptée il n'a plus aujourd'hui ni la
force ni les soutiens nécessaires pour
opérer ces réformes nécessaires donc il
peut toujours dire comme il a dit hier
ben je n'ai pas droit à l'immobilisme
très bien mais
s'il n'a pas les moyens de mettre des
réformes mais on va être contraint à
l'immobilisme premier exemple quand même
après la réforme des retraites l'autre
grande réforme qui était censé aboutir
c'est celle de l'immigration la réforme
contestée par les uns par les autres
contester par la gauche à cause de du
durcissement des conditions d'expulsion
contestés par la droite à cause de la
promesse d'un nouveau type de séjour de
pour ceux qui veulent travailler mais
voilà il y avait un projet qui était sur
la table et ben là le premier décision
post retraite c'est 1 de reporter ce
texte de de l'éclater en une somme de
petits textes dans l'espoir que une
série de petits textes pour être plus
facilement adoptée on voit bien que il
en est réduit à faire je crois
combattant on appelle ça faire du faire
du cabotage c'est aller de de de porc en
porc et sans ne plus pouvoir faire de
grandes traversées ce sera ma dernière
question Guillaume quelle sortie de
crise pour le président
je pense que
il est trop tôt pour parler de sortie de
crise on est dans la crise la page des
retraites elle n'est pas tournée on est
au coeur d'une mobilisation néocort
d'une contestation et je pense que
l'erreur si on peut parler d'erreur de
l'intervention d'hier c'est d'avoir
prétendu ouvrir vers une étape suivante
alors qu'on est pas encore sorti de la
crise une intervention qui n'a pas
convaincu c'est ce que vous allez voir
en détail avec Damien Canivez qui va
prendre Marlène et Victor Boris de
backbone Consulting qui vont prendre
leur lait on va aller retourner tout de
suite sur le terrain merci beaucoup
Guillaume
apporter cette analyse et
donner votre éclairage par rapport à
toutes ces événements les événements
sont toujours aussi tendus ici place de
l'Opéra à Paris où on retrouve
Timothée délaime j'espère qu'il est pas
trop dans les lacrymogènes et que peut
encore nous parler Timothée
oui Vincent je peux vous parler mais je
vous cache pas que c'est assez compliqué
on va vous montrer ce qui se passe là en
fait nous sommes une centaine de mètres
de la place de l'Opéra il y a des
charges permanentes d'un coup ce sont
les CRS et d'un autre ce sont parfois
les manifestants qui font cela en
direction des CRS avec de très nombreux
gés de projectiles des pavés notamment
qui sont lancés en direction des des
forces de l'or et bien réplique avec des
des charges récurrentes en fait ce qui
se passe c'est que le cortège est
vraiment en définitivement coupé en deux
il a été stoppé au niveau du boulevard
des Italiens et d'ailleurs vous le voyez
juste ici là avec les services d'ordre
des syndicats vous les voyez avec ces
gilet bleu ça ce sont les services
d'ordre du syndicat solidaire si je me
trompe pas c'est vrai qu'on distingue
pas très très bien en tous les cas ce
qui est sûr c'est que ce sont des
services d'ordre de de syndicats et donc
le cortège qui ne parvient plus
maintenant à avancer parce qu'il a des
grandes scènes de tension vous voyez des
petites boules qui fument au sol ça ce
sont et bien des des boules lancées par
les
CRS ce sont des gaz lacrymogène et on a
de plus en plus de mal à parler parce
qu'évidemment il y a toujours cette ce
mélange d'odeur entre ces gaz
lacrymogènes entre également c'est ces
feux de poubelles et on est maintenant à
200 mètres de la place de l'Opéra mais
les manifestants qui ne cherchent plus à
rejoindre la place de l'Opéra je parle
en tout cas des manifestants violents
parce que là on est sur des scènes de
d'affrontement avec les forces de
l'ordre et en réalité la l'Opéra
elle semble se vider en ce moment et les
tensions qui se cristallisent donc au
niveau de ce boulevard des Italiens avec
de nombreux mouvements de foule tout le
monde qui se qui s'observe vous voyez
ici par exemple un scooter ou une moto
qui s'est retrouvé par terre et là une
charge une nouvelle charge de la c'est
la gendarmerie là ce coup-ci
[Musique]
voilà avec un homme qui vient de chuter
à côté de nous
voilà c'est des images évidemment qu'on
n'aime pas voir on fait bien attention à
rester en sécurité en tout cas ce qui
est sûr c'est que la fin de la
manifestation de la mobilisation cet
après-midi
s'annonce vraiment très très mouvementée
du côté du du 9e arrondissement de la
capitale
parisien bonjour à toutes et à tous je
suis ravi de passer cette fin de journée
en votre compagnie pour suivre cette
manifestation particulièrement en
mouvementée à Paris nos reporters vous
l'avez bien compris sont sur le terrain
au cœur du cortège on leur demandera
encore dans quelques instants si les
tensions se calme ou au contraire
s'intensifie mais avant cela nous
accueillons Victor Boris directeur
général de backbone Consulting nous
dévoilera les résultats d'un sondage
exclusif sur le regard que les Français
ont posé sur l'interview d'Emmanuel
Macron hier midi nous recevrons aussi
Joseph touvenet le directeur de la
rédaction de capital social mais aussi
ancien vice-président de la CFTC et
enfin on décryptera la stratégie des
forces de l'ordre de Dieu sait qu'elles
sont au cœur de l'actualité aujourd'hui
dans ces manifestations avec un policier
Mathieu Valley porte-parole du syndicat
si GP commissaire bonjour Victor Boris
Victor Borie vous êtes directeur général
de backbone Consulting vous avez mené
une enquête exclusive avec odoxa pour Le
Figaro sur la réaction des Français face
à prise de parole d'Emmanuel Macron
c'était d'interview qui a été diffusée
hier sur TF1 et France 2 hier à midi
est-ce qu'il a été convaincant le chef
de l'État alors le point il y a
différents points des points positifs
dans les points positifs c'est que les
Français qui ont suivi son intervention
estime que président était plutôt clair
c'est déjà qu'il a plutôt montré qu'ils
savaient où la lettre pour 51 % des
Français mais que c'est pas du tout ce
qu'il attendait donc on observe un vrai
décalage on observe un vrai décalage
mais comment expliquer vous que les
trois quarts des Français n'est pas été
convaincus par sa prise de parole c'est
vraiment ce décalage qui explique qui
explique ça alors en préambule sur le
les résultats du sondage qui sont assez
marquants c'est la pire intervention de
l'histoire des postes tests d'Emmanuel
Macron jamais depuis 6 ans il n'était
pas venu à convaincre aussi peu les
Français donc à part les sympathisants
Renaissance donc
604% de convaincus et les cinq
présidents de tous les autres partis
politiques n'ont pas été convaincus même
chez les lers 60% n'ont pas été
convaincus alors pour répondre à votre
question pourquoi alors pour les
Français manuel Macron n'a pas du tout
compris leur préoccupations pour 74%,
71% d'entre eux n'a pas pris la mesure
de la gravité de la situation pour 70%
d'entre eux et une fois de plus à leurs
yeux ça c'est un point qui revient
souvent dans nos enquêtes d'opinion il
n'a pas du tout fait preuve d'humilité
de modestie voilà donc et surtout il ne
les a pas rassurés pour près de 80 % des
Français alors c'est intéressant ce que
vous dites parce que quand on regarde
votre étude dans le détail on se rend
compte qu'effectivement Emmanuel Macron
n'est pas parvenu à convaincre la
totalité de sa base et je parle bien sûr
de ces fidèles vous savez c'est
sympathisant Renaissance c'est assez
étonnant ça non alors c'est étonnant
mais on voit qu'il y a un clivage qui
s'opère d'une d'une part ceux qui sont
les plus convaincus qui prennent
l'argument de ça suffit maintenant les
Français sont des travailleurs et de
l'autre d'être ceux qui sont vraiment
mobilisés contre la réforme et qui se
cristallise et qui se radicalise
d'autant plus alors il y a un internaute
la chardon bleu c'est un pseudo bien
évidemment sur Le Figaro.fr qui estime
qu'il n'a pas convaincu parce que ce
n'était pas son but est-ce que vous
pensez au regard de votre autre étude
que le but de cette intervention
finalement d'Emmanuel Macron et bien
c'était pas de convaincre alors on peut
se poser la question et d'ailleurs avant
même de prendre la parole le Président
l'intervention du président posait des
questions et à mobiliser un vent
contraire à savoir le choix du format du
Trésor un horaire quand même assez peu
regardé par les actifs alors que sur un
sujet d'une réforme qui concerne les
actifs donc avant même de prendre la
parole ça a commencé à nourrir la
contestation résultat seulement 25% des
Français ont suivi son interview entier
et près de 20% en partie donc on était
dans un contexte déjà au style et
ensuite le clivage dont on a pu parler
qui ce qui ne fait que s'intensifier au
regard de l'absence de mesure qui ont
été annoncées vous avez affirmé que pour
Emmanuel Macron c'est la pire
intervention télévisée qu'il ait pu
faire jusque là jusqu'à sa première
élection donc en 2017 est-ce que lors
des gilets jaunes et bien Emmanuel
Macron était plus convaincant
qu'aujourd'hui encore parce qu'on s'en
souvient lors des gilets jaunes Emmanuel
Macron était extrêmement décrié il y
avait des manifestations un peu de
l'ordre de celle que l'on voit
actuellement sur les images de Figaro
live alors le paradoxe avec
l'information la donnée que je viens de
vous donner c'est que on observe par
rapport à l'époque des gilets jaunes
beaucoup plus de conversations sur les
réseaux sociaux alors que on voit que
son intervention a été moins moins suivi
et donc sur toutes les dimensions
évoquées sont intervention et j'ai
beaucoup plus sévèrement que lors de son
intervention de 2018 sur l'humidité
moins 26 points sur sur la capacité à
montrer qu'il comprenait et
préoccupations des Français - 21 points
et sur la prise en compte de la gravité
de la situation - 25 points donc on voit
qu'il y a un vrai décalage avec cette
époque alors plus d'un Français sur deux
estime que le chef de l'État a été clair
ça pour le coup c'est une qualité pour
pour Emmanuel Macron donc si je
comprends bien ici je résume il a été
clair mais pas convaincant ça a été
limpide mais pas convaincant est-ce que
on peut traduire ça comme une forme de
désaveu de sa politique on va dire qu'il
y a un contexte et les différentes
études d'opinion pendant toute la la
période de présentation de la
proposition de loi ont montré qu'il y
avait un contexte totalement hostile et
qui faisait que ça va que s'aggraver
l'absence de pédagogie en tout cas le
fait de décrier le l'utilisation du 49-3
puis d'y avoir recours était très mal
perçu par les Français donc cette mesure
est l'application de l'article en tant a
été particulièrement pris dans l'opinion
notamment dans les conversations qu'on
peut observer en ligne alors autre
commentaire sur le chat du figaro.fr
commentaire très intéressant qui nous
indique que ce n'est pas contre la
réforme que les Français sont en train
de se de se lever mais plutôt contre le
président de la République c'est Vincent
Lambert qui nous envoie ça sur sur Le
Figaro.fr est-ce que vous sentez à
travers votre sondage que les critiques
se cristallisent essentiellement sur
Emmanuel Macron plus finalement que sur
la réforme des retraites est-ce qu'il y
a une véritable opposition contre le
chef de l'État aujourd'hui il y a une
mobilisation autour du chat de tac il
est crié son nom revient évidemment
beaucoup avant même que celui des
lisabeth borne mais en réalité on se
rend compte que les Français
n'attendaient pas grand chose de cette
intervention la grande majorité des
Français que ce soit dans la partition
d'agir ou l'analyse des réseaux sociaux
qu'on a pu faire ont davantage écouter
par curiosité de que va-t-il dire plus
qu'une véritable attente notamment
l'indicateur de de la résignation pour
mesurer dans les différents sondages
précédents le démontre qui est la fait
que ça gravé alors j'aimerais que l'on
revienne sur ce chiffre là ce 71% des
Français qui estiment que le président
n'a pas du tout compris leur
préoccupations dans quelle mesure se
discours était-il en décalage avec ce
que les Français attendent vraiment
finalement ils attendent quoi
en fait pas grand chose et s'attendait
évidemment la partie de l'opposition et
la mobilisation qu'on voit aujourd'hui
dans la rue attendait que la réforme et
la réforme soit retirée est totalement
ou en tout cas qu'on revienne à la à la
à la forme de la réforme qui était
initiale mais en réalité pas grand chose
c'était plus une curiosité et le format
qui a été choisi une fois de plus
c'était assez peu opportun alors là on
est au cœur de l'actualité avec cette
manifestation qui se déroule à Paris
cette mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites est-ce que ce discours du chef
de l'État est-ce que cette interview
fasse à ces deux journalistes de TF1 et
France 2 a eu un effet sur la
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites alors oui il a une et un effet
vraiment clair le bilan est sans appel
les Français sont plus en plus nombreux
qu'avant son intervention à penser que
la mobilisation contre la réforme doit
se poursuivre après de 70% donc cette
France est sur 10 c'est énorme en
comparaison avec l'époque des gilets
jaunes le souhaitent le mouvement
s'arrête et aussi nettement moins élevé
donc avec 13 points de moins que celui
de constatait au lendemain de son
intervention télévisée en 2018 est-ce
que ça ça veut dire que ce mouvement de
contestation contre la réforme des
retraites peut vraiment durer dans le
temps même plus longtemps que les gilets
jaunes encore alors ça c'est c'est un
point assez intéressant dans notre
analyse des réseaux sociaux c'est que
tous les sapés que sur la dimension on
va dire sur la mobilisation des actifs
et des syndicats dans la rue devraient
dans toute logique c'est c'est souffler
compte tenu du coup financer qu'à cette
mobilisation dans un contexte économique
qui est très difficile pour tous les
Français particulièrement pour les
Français actifs l'autre point et on le
voit aujourd'hui je l'ai personnellement
remarqué mais rendant dans votre studio
c'est la mobilisation des jeunes qui
elle en fait créer une mobilisation qui
est totalement unanime et sans conteste
contre la réforme sous différents angles
même celui de l'écologie on voit
l'hashtag pas de retraité sur une pleine
brûlée qui est beaucoup repris donc
énormément de messages sont échangés
beaucoup de beaucoup de rassemblement
notamment sauvages sont organisés via
les réseaux sociaux via notamment des
boucles fermées auxquelles on peut avoir
accès aux journées de ceci ont accès qui
permet d'anticiper de voir qu'elle est
mobilisation et donc s'inspirant
notamment d'un mouvement qu'on avait
observé à Hong Kong et le mouvement
bivouater qui est de ce mouvoir comme
l'eau et d'être imprévisible comme peut
l'être le cours d'un ruisseau et donc et
certains jeunes on le voit dans les
conversations s'amusent même d'allumer
des faux et de voir les unités de CRS
donc habillées avec par un matériel de
plus de 20 kg à courir de gauche à
droite comme en jouant au chat à la
souris et on peut s'attendre avec la
mobilisation des jeunes elle dure dure
dans le temps la précarité des jeunes en
France aussi ne fait qu'agriver cette
situation puisqu'on le voit et on le
voit le soir notamment ça devient
presque une activité en fait ces
allumages de feu pour une jeunesse qui
en fait est un peu
enfin sans pas sans avenir mais en tout
cas qui le manifeste sur les réseaux et
est-ce que c'est à travers cette
mobilisation des réseaux sociaux dont
vous venez de parler que l'on peut
considérer ce mouvement comme l'acte 2
des gilets jaunes je vous pose cette
question parce que c'est un internaute
nous deux sur le Figaro.fr qui a fait
cette remarque alors l'acte de DG les
jeunes on n'est pas sur les mêmes
raisons on n'est pas sur le même type de
population notamment ceux qui sera
génisse on voit notamment qu'il y a une
espèce de il y a plus de rupture
intergénérationnelle on voit que les
jeunes qui sont dans la rue utilisent
l'argument de leurs parents et comme
s'il prenait le relais de la
mobilisation de l'emperence qui est
assez intéressant dans certaines
mobilisations sociales ou en fait il y
avait bon les jeunes d'un côté et les
actifs ou seniors de l'autre pour
protester contre certaines mesures aux
réformes là on n'est pas du tout là et
donc on peut s'attendre à un mouvement
qui dure acte 2 des gilets jaunes c'est
pas ce qui est employé d'ailleurs dans
le dans l'analyse sémantique qu'on peut
faire ça revient très peu en tout cas
pas dans ces populations alors pour en
revenir à interview d'Emmanuel Macron
qui s'est déroulé hier à 13h sur TF1 et
France 2 c'est vrai que là on l'a vu
avec vous il y a une grosse partie de
son discours qui est décrié par les
Français néanmoins ce qu'il y a des
morceaux de de son intervention qui ont
été néanmoins jugés positifs alors il y
avait on l'a déjà évoqué mais sur la
forme qui était possible sur sa clarté
et cetera sur le fond un point positif
c'est sa vision de l'emploi sur les fins
de carrière sur le sens du travail sur
la réindustrialisation de la France et
comment l'État s'organise pour ça mais
qui à chaque fois tous les arguments qui
auraient pu les peu d'arguments qui ont
été positifs sont quasiment à chaque
fois teintés de négatif mais avec le
commentaire mais pourquoi il ne l'a pas
dit avant et donc on peut voir que en
revanche il y a beaucoup de points
négatifs de son discours qui ont été
décrié ce qui me ce qui a mis un peu le
faux poudre évidemment c'est c'est
l'emploi des termes les factieux les
factions et le comparatif un peu douteux
enfin qui était en tout cas jugé très
douteux par les Français sur l'allusion
à l'invasion du Capitole aux États-Unis
et enfin de manière plus générale et en
parallèle qui est un peu la toile de
fond de des éléments du discours qui ont
été décrit c'est le fait d'avoir un
président et d'avoir le sentiment d'être
un président qui qui est distant qui est
voire méprisant qui est sourd à
l'expression de la rue et des citoyens
qui aggravent le jour en jeu
le sentiment de colère parce que face à
la réforme quand je lis les conclusions
de votre sondage Victor Bury j'ai le
sentiment que les Français sont en train
de banaliser ou en tout cas de légitimer
la violence qui voit ça comme un autre
moyen de contestation il y a un
pourcentage qui est assez éloquent dans
votre étude qui montre que les Français
comprennent ces mouvements violents
sachant que les manifestations
pacifiques ne fonctionnent pas mais
c'est à dire qu'en fait comme sur le
fond il y a une incompréhension des
messages véhiculés par le gouvernement
et le président de la République il y a
une forme de résignation qui fait qu'un
certain temps de la population pour
différentes raisons soit pour défendre
des éléments précis des points de la
réforme on voit sur le report de l'âge
légal à la retraite qui était un point
cristallisant mais aussi et comme je
l'évoquais juste avant dans une note
population que sont les jeunes et qui
est une forme de manifestation
alternatives et aussi qui peuvent
occuper leur quotidien leur soirée aussi
dans votre sondage et vous l'avez
rappelé tout à l'heure seulement 25 %
des Français ont suivi son interview
dans dans sa globalité quelque part
c'est assez décevant aussi on se dit que
la parole présidentielle elle n'est plus
vraiment attendue aujourd'hui c'est
inquiétant ça elle est moins attendue
parce qu'il y avait moins d'enfant moins
d'attente concrètes sur le sur les sur
les mesures qui auraient pu être
proposées et aussi sur le choix du
format c'est à dire que c'est un format
qui a été choisi pour toucher
l'objectif était de touche une
population qui soit pas seulement
citadine mais qui a été perçu comme une
tentative de détournement de la de la
communication directe entre le président
et le peuple français alors
qu'est-ce qu'attendait aussi alors parce
que vous avez parlé effectivement des
Français qui ont suivi cette interview
mais il y a aussi les internautes très
concrètement cette interview elle a été
vécue comment par le prisme des réseaux
sociaux alors sur les réseaux sociaux on
a notre analyse à la façon d'agira sur
les réseaux sociaux on voit qu'on voit
vraiment en fait à la fois ce qui est
assez révélateur c'est le mobilisation
des jeunes et comment il s'organise sur
les réseaux sociaux et mais aussi ce
clivage qui commence à être très clair
très net entre une radicalisation du
mouvement des pour qui sont toujours
bien présents et on le voit qui s'était
plutôt plutôt timoré en fait ces
dernières semaines et en fait qui se
mobisent avec un forme de point sur la
table sur ça suffit on a cette réforme
la France en a besoin et les Français
sont des travailleurs et une autre
partie de la population qui elle est
vend debout contre la réforme et quels
sont les mots qui reviennent souvent sur
les réseaux sociaux en lien avec
Emmanuel Macron là on a noun par exemple
en nous une 78 qui nous dit que sur les
réseaux sociaux lui il voit beaucoup de
propos qui indiquent par exemple que
l'on vivrait dans dictature par exemple
est-ce que ça c'est ce genre de terme
aussi que vous voyez sur les réseaux
sociaux
dans les hashtags on le voit sur à la
fois sur les hashtags retraits de la
réforme sur le hashtag des missions de
Macron qui ont augmenté en termes de
volume de manière conséquente ces
derniers jours alors Victor Bourry est
bien merci pour ce décryptage merci
d'avoir été avec nous sur ce plateau je
rappelle que vous êtes directeur général
de backbone Consulting nous sommes en
direct sur Figaro live en direct du
cortège parisien ou la manifestation se
poursuit place de l'Opéra dans le 9e
arrondissement de Paris et Vincent
roseron est en direct du cortège
parisien Vincent quelle est l'ambiance
actuellement autour de vous est-ce que
les esprits se sont un petit peu apaisés
apparemment nous avons des problèmes de
liaison c'est normal il y a beaucoup de
ah je crois que Vincent nous entend
cent
ah oui moi je vous entends je sais pas
si vous vous m'entendez mais en tout cas
moi de mon côté j'ai passé une
magnifique station bizarrement assez
tranquille par rapport à Timothée je
n'ai pas vu débordement puisque j'étais
plutôt à l'arrière et là maintenant je
me trouve à Richel donc pas si loin de
ça d'opéra et pour l'instant la
manifestation est assez était assez
festive on voit des on voit même des
enfants dans ce cortège tout est tout en
tout est très calme en tout cas de mon
côté de cette manifestation qui a
démarré on le rappelle à 14h à Bastille
pour rejoindre l'opéra je crois que du
côté de Timothée il y a eu à Opéra il y
avait pas mal de de
débordement qui ont lieu tout au long du
parcours plutôt à l'avant mais en tout
cas dans le cœur de la manifestation il
y a beaucoup de manifestants qui n'ont
pas vu ça justement là effectivement sur
le chemin on a vu quelques barricades
quelque barricades oui quelques
comment dire barrière mais métallique en
flamme enflammé quel ciné on va dire de
ce qu'il y a de plus passer un peu avant
mais en tout cas pour une majeure partie
des manifestants aujourd'hui la
manifestation ils auront l'impression
que c'était très calme
si beaucoup Vincent roseron en direct du
cortège parisien non de la place de
l'Opéra bonjour Joseph touvenel bonjour
bienvenue sur le plateau vous êtes
directeur de la rédaction de capital
social je tire votre magazine entre les
mains il est tout chaud il sort de
l'imprimerie il est pas encore dans les
boîtes aux lettres et ceux qui veulent
le commander vous allez sur Internet
capital social magazine et on vous
l'envoie bah formidable écoute ma merci
de me faire l'honneur de me l'apporter
sur ce plateau je le vends en
avant-première c'est Charlotte dornellaz
donc un journaliste de valeur actuelle
qui effectivement en couverture de ce
magazine et vous êtes également ancien
vice-président de la CFTC alors je vais
vous faire réagir sur un chiffre ce
chiffre c'est celui de 800 000 c'est la
CGT qui annonce ce nombre de
manifestants aujourd'hui à Paris une
mobilisation également en hausse dans
certaines régions les chiffres de la
police aujourd'hui annoncent plus de 800
000 manifestants dans toute la France et
on compte même pas Paris est-ce que
c'est une réussite aujourd'hui alors
c'est une réussite quant aux chiffres
annoncés et par la police et par le
gouvernement et par la CGT je crois que
les deux ont des erreurs de calculette
si on fait une moyenne mais c'est une
grosse mobilisation j'en sors le il y a
pas un cortège à Paris il y a deux
cortèges ça c'est quand il y a des très
grosses mobilisations il y a un
itinéraire bis qui est mis en place dire
c'est très intéressant de voir que
l'itinéraire 10 c'est très calme il y a
aucun problème et puis un autre
itinéraire où les Black Blocs viennent
moi je remercie les forces de police de
protéger les manifestants qui sont des
dizaines de milliers très calmes très
paisible et malheureusement on a c'est
même pas des excités je crois que c'est
des gens politiquement dangereux qui
sont l'extrême gauche violente qu'essaye
de mettre le feu et qui d'ailleurs met
le feu un certain nombre de choses voilà
c'est pas les manifestants c'est pas les
syndicats c'est l'extrême gauche et il
faut être très vigilant contre cette
extrême gauche qui essaie de d'amener
les choses par la violence comme elle
l'a toujours fait dans son histoire
c'est vrai que ces incivilités dont vous
parlez Joseph touvenet et ses incendies
qu'on a pu voir ici ou là dans les rues
de Paris aujourd'hui sont devenus
aujourd'hui malheureusement quotidienne
depuis
l'activation du 49-3 à l'Assemblée
nationale par Elisabeth borne en tant
qu'enseigne responsable syndical quel
regard vous vous portez sur ce mode
d'action c'est vrai que ça pose des
barres on en a parlé tout à l'heure et
Victor Boris certains estiment qu'il
faut en passer par là pour que les
revendications soient entendues jamais
moi j'ai une expérience syndicale
importante j'ai gagné des combats
syndicaux et j'ai gagné des combats en
évitant des licenciements en faisant
revenir en arrière
sans violence pacifiquement avec un peu
d'imagination peut-être par exemple au
lieu de bloquer tous les jours les RER
et ça bloque une partie de l'économie ce
qui est pas bon pour le pays donc ce qui
est pas bon pour les salariés ni pour
les entreprises ça met des gens dans des
difficultés réelles grâce à un mouvement
populaire j'habite la banlieue je vois
je vois presque tous les matins une
femme avec une poussette et deux enfants
qui n'arrivent pas à monter dans les RER
si cette femme le matin elle revient
c'est parce que derrière elle doit avoir
un travail il faut qu'elle laisse les
enfants chez une nourrice comment elle
fait si elle a pu le rémunération
si mes amis de la SNCF et la RATP avait
un peu plus d'imagination d'abord il
respecterait ses salariés et puis il
bloquerait les circuits internes de leur
entreprise s'il bloque les circuits
d'information de courrier interne à leur
entreprise là ils feront une action
effectivement de blocage c'est quoi
bloqué des services d'information
interne concrètement
vous faites pu passer les mails internes
et vous allez voir comment l'entreprise
à un moment donné est obligé de
réfléchir et je dis pas que c'est la
bonne solution et forcément il va y
avoir des répercussions sur les usagers
à un moment donné si vous faites ce
genre d'action non les trains contreront
à rouler les métros aussi ce qui importe
les usagers alors c'est vrai que là on
l'a vu Joseph touvenet il y a eu de
nombreuses manifestations au cours des
dernières semaines qui se sont
globalement bien déroulés avec des
débordements ici ou là mais globalement
les syndicats ont réussi à tenir les
manifestants
comment on fait aujourd'hui quel conseil
vous donneriez par exemple au syndicats
aujourd'hui pour que justement ils
puissent faire entendre leur
revendications sans parce que l'on voit
aujourd'hui c'est à dire des incendies
des dégradations et des affrontements
avec les forces de l'ordre la
manifestation c'est utile ça montre
qu'il y a du monde qui a une volonté
tout le monde ne vient pas manifester
notamment j'admire le fait de bloquer
les transports en commun le jour où on
fait du manifestations peut-être
réfléchir et laisser parce qu'il y a des
gens qui viennent pas manifester
paradoxal parce que ils peuvent pas
venir où ils se disent je ne pourrais
pas repartir ça c'est un des éléments
l'autre c'est continuer à communiquer
enfin qui sait aujourd'hui dans ce grand
débat sur les retraites que les derniers
chiffres que nous avons sur le déficit
des caisses de retraite je prends toutes
les caisses confondues c'est pas un
déficit c'est un excédent 2021 + 900
millions 2022 ça sera sans doute plus 3
milliards ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'il y a pas d'urgence par contre
effectivement il faut regarder sur le
long terme sur une génération et dans
ces cas-là il faut poser des choses
d'une politique familiale nataliste
proactive je n'ai pas vu ça dans ce
mauvais texte rien
sur la politique familiale qui est quand
même la base de notre système
et donc il faut communiquer en vérité
continuer continuer à discuter continuer
peut-être à dire comme c'est fait par un
certain nombre d'organisations
syndicales je pense à les CFDT et je
pense à la CFTC aussi qui fait des
propositions pour simplifier les choses
à imite il est normal de poser sur la
table que deux personnes qui ont fait le
même travail avec les mêmes diplômes les
mêmes difficultés par le même nombre
d'années à la fin quelle que soit leur
statut
puisse bénéficier de la même retraite ça
c'est la vraie réforme mais on a tout
mélangé d'ailleurs qui s'y retrouve dans
ce mauvais projet et l'allongement de
personnes l'allongement de départ à la
retraite vous y êtes favorable vous êtes
opposés à ça l'âge de 64 ans c'est de la
fumée aujourd'hui
sur la loi actuelle pas celle qui est
passé au Parlement actuel quelqu'un qui
a 50 ans
la moyenne c'est on commence à
travailler à 23 ans oui c'est la moyenne
quelqu'un qui a 50 ans aujourd'hui doit
travailler 43 ans moi j'ai fait l'école
primaire 23 + 43 = 66 c'est à dire que
cette allongement lié déjà alors parler
de l'âge de la retraite si je ne parle
pas d'une ombre d'unités nécessaires je
fais du vent moi je peux faire mon
Mélenchon et vous dire je vais vous
mettre la retraite à 55 ans oui mais si
vous fait ici il faut que vous
travaillez 43 ans vous le feriez jamais
et donc il faudrait être sérieux et la
communication gouvernementale n'est pas
sérieuse aujourd'hui donc je reprends
mon cas quelqu'un qui a 50 ans
aujourd'hui qui a commencé à travailler
à 23 ans comme c'est la moyenne ne
pourra pas bénéficier d'une retraite à
taux plein à 66 ans et puis autre chose
et un problème de justice sociale les
sénateurs se sont totalement
décrédibilisés il vote la fin des
régimes spéciaux et sans doute qu'il
faut que le régime spéciaux évolue à
tous moi je suis d'accord pour qu'une
exception pour les militaires je suis
d'accord pour une exception pour les
danseurs de l'Opéra donc il faut voir
très pragmatiquement mais nos braves
sénateurs quand une retraite à 60 ans
quand ils font six ans de mandat il
touche 2200 euros il ne réforme pas leur
système comment voulez-vous que ça passe
dans les paysans
c'est parfaitement injuste c'est
parfaitement stupide c'est parfaitement
inaudible et vous dites que la réforme
n'était pas si urgente que ça pourtant
lorsque le gouvernement indique que le
système des retraites est menaçait dans
déséquilibre de 13,5 milliards d'euros à
l'horizon 2030 vous n'entendez pas cet
argument dans les pas en 2030 je
constate que les chiffres ça va vite
arriver quand même 2030 mais 2021 + 900
millions 2022 sans doute 3 milliards
donc à pas une heure non
ce que veut faire le gouvernement c'est
régler un vrai problème budgétaire de
déficit du pays
en faisant une réforme des retraites
mais c'est Epsilon enfin quand on nous
parle du du déficit des retraites si je
le mets à côté du déficit du commerce
extérieur 166 milliards où est la
priorité
le déficit des retraites d'ailleurs des
retraites c'est de l'argent que je verse
donc c'est de l'argent qui rentre dans
la consommation donc c'est pas un
déficit mais qu'on s'y intéresse qu'on
retrouve des équilibres et je
conseillerais au gouvernement de
regarder ce que font les partenaires
sociaux
les pour le privé 74% des salariés les
régimes sont à l'équilibre 72 milliards
de réserves c'est 72 milliards de
réserves ils sont faits parquet par le
patronat et les syndicats qui gèrent les
retraites complémentaires du privé
peut-être que si l'état nous laissait un
peu plus la main ça serait mieux gérer
je constate que le déficit il est du
côté de l'État patron pas du côté de la
gestion paritaire patronathan du garde
comment elle se passe
tous les deux trois ans on revoit les
choses gentiment en s'engueule les
syndicats sérieux
mettre un accord avec le patronat de
bonne gestion ce qui explique qu'on soit
l'équilibre 72 milliards de réserves que
l'état donne l'exemple qu'il gère
correctement ce qu'il a à gérer et on
l'écoutera ensuite avec un peu plus
d'attention je vous laisse Joseph
touvenel pardon j'aimerais vous faire
réagir aux images que l'on voit
actuellement sur Figaro live on a pu
voir il y a quelques secondes de ça des
affrontements entre les manifestants et
les forces de l'ordre on a l'impression
que le calme est assez relatif là en ce
moment en marche de la manifestation à
Paris vous c'est vrai que en tant qu'
ancien vice-président de la CFTC vous
avez dû aussi peut-être gérer ce genre
de situation on sait que les syndicats
ont aussi un service d'or ils doivent
aussi sécuriser les cortèges comment ça
se passe ça concrètement dans une
manifestation vous avez des gardes du
corps c'est ça qui entoure un cortège
comment ça se passe d'abord il y a un
service d'or il y a une organisation qui
est fait avec les forces de police qui
sécurise le cortège le problème c'est
que avant la masse des fastation c'était
avant physiquement devant la
manifestation vient une partie de
l'extrême gauche ou alors
filtre à certains moments et ça c'est
très difficile à gérer
c'est pour ça que les incidences sont
généralement à l'avant et puis ensuite
quand la nuit tombe et que les braves
gens rentrent chez eux il y a l'extrême
gauche là qui essaye d'agiter les choses
et c'est très difficile je comprends les
forces de police ils peuvent pas charger
dans la foule alors que il y a un
certain nombre une toute petite minorité
une pointe d'épingle dangereuse qui en
partie rend service au gouvernement
parce que ça permet au gouvernement de
dire nous sommes le parti de l'ordre
vous pensez que le gouvernement
instrumentalise aussi c'est black bloc
pour justement se mettre quelque part
sur un piédestal depuis le temps qu'ils
existent depuis le temps qu'on les
connaît et qui se passe pas grand chose
je me pose franchement la question bon
on posera la question justement à notre
invité suivante qui est justement
policier alors on a parlé il y a
policier je rappellerai que d'ailleurs
quand les Black Blocs attaquent la
police ils attaquent des syndicalistes
puisque le taux de syndicalisation dans
la police c'est plus de 80% absolument
c'est vrai d'ailleurs on a vu aussi des
débordements entre des militants
radicaux et des membres de la CGT aussi
un moment donné dans les cas dans les
dans les manifestations de la CGT qui
n'est plus celui qu'il était avant et
tant mieux parce que ça pouvait aussi
apporter une certaine menace
en fait vous savez entre les communistes
et les trots ils sont jamais aimés ils
continuent dans la rue je préférais
qu'il arrive pas pendant nos
manifestations alors Joseph Stouvenel on
a parlé il y a quelques minutes du
regard que les Français ont posé sur
l'intervention d'Emmanuel Macron hier
sur TF1 et France 2 Philippe Martinez
fustigé donc le leader de la CGT il a
fustiger je le cite un foutage de gueule
est-ce que vous utiliseriez ces propos
non non par respect pour la fonction
mais je pense que même Macron fait de
grosses erreurs la méthode est mauvaise
un président de la République qui ose
affirmer que les organisations
syndicales n'ont pas voulu discuter tout
le monde sait que c'est faux la
meilleure démonstration c'est quand ils
ont demandé il y a pas si longtemps il y
a quelques jours avant le vote de 49-3
ils ont demandé à être reçu à l'Élysée
on a dit non c'est du mépris président
de la République a refusé la première
ministre a refusé Emmanuel Macron ne
peut pas dire aujourd'hui j'ai toujours
ouvert ma porte aux propositions il en a
écouté aucune et il y a des propositions
intelligentes par exemple sur les
seniors moi je suis très maconomiste sur
les seigneurs comme Emmanuel Macron nous
disait je ne ferai pas de loi retraite
tant qu'on apparaît le problème des
seniors il fait une loi retraite il
apparaît le problème des seniors oui
parce que pour travailler plus longtemps
il faut un travail et oui il faut pas
être au chômage sinon voilà c'est pas
des travailleurs c'est des chômeurs
il y a un problème ils sont en train de
bâtir une usine à gaz avec les tableaux
Excel ou vapard dans les entreprises on
regarde si Madame Michu elle a quel âge
etc c'est encore compliqué la tâche des
entreprises donc être moins
concurrentiel parce que à l'étranger ils
font pas ça il suffirait de dire qu'au
bout d'un certain nombre d'années de
travail et bien les charges sociales
pour les seniors sont baissés
ils ont payé ils ont cotisé etc plein
pot et bien on estime peut-être qu'un je
sais pas à l'âge de est-ce que c'est 56
ans 57 ans on baisse les charges
sociales ça permettrait d'avoir des
seigneurs qui coûtent moins cher ça
permettrait aux entreprises d'avoir
moins de coups et sans doute que ça
aiderait à maintenir les seigneurs dans
l'emploi et l'index seniors qui avait
été un temps ajouté dans la loi qui veut
viser à contraindre les entreprises de
plus de 300 salariés à publier justement
un indicateur sur l'emploi des seniors
au sein de l'entreprise c'était une
bonne idée ça selon vous mais non enfin
à mon sens non parce que tous ces index
ces machins ces trucs enfin c'est de la
paperasserie alors les plus grosses
entreprises mes multinationales les
machins ils ont des services qui font
que ça toute la journée ils peuvent nous
faire des barèmes ils peuvent s'amuser à
faire des tableaux mais même une PME de
350 400 salariés qui essaye de se
développer en France et en
internationale elle a autre chose à
faire je vous le l'assure qu'à faire des
barèmes et des choses et des trucs et
quand je discute avec des responsables
d'entreprises que disent-ils ils disent
que d'abord ils ont une paperasserie
monumentale à faire de leur concurrents
n'ont pas la même paperasserie et qu'ils
ont en plus des règles qui ne cesse de
changer et ça pour notre économie c'est
très mauvais il faudrait un peu de
stabilité dans les textes et qu'on
arrête de leur rajouter dans la rajouter
sans enfin bon le tableau Excel le
machin le truc c'est pas ça qui va
régler je pense que si les seniors sont
moins dans l'entreprise c'est parce
qu'il y a un coût on les paye un peu
plus parce qu'il y a l'ancienneté etc si
on baisse les charges permettrait de les
payer toujours au même niveau que ça
coûte moins cher à l'entreprise ça me
paraît pas très difficile à mettre en
place quand même et si on met les
seigneurs de côté avec tout le respect
qu'on leur doit bien évidemment est-ce
que l'idée aussi peut-être ce ne serait
pas de revaloriser aussi le travail de
donner envie aux gens de rester un peu
plus longtemps sur leur lieu de travail
et donner un sens aussi de pas venir sur
son lieu de travail simplement pour
faire du chiffre et pour avoir quelque
chose d'assez abstrait vous savez
parfaitement raison mais ça c'est un
travail de long terme le goût du travail
le sens du travail
travailler c'est participer au bien
commun et participer à une œuvre et donc
redonner sans celui qui vous parle et eu
des responsabilités importantes en
entreprise mais j'ai commencé aussi avec
des métiers j'ai été manœuvre chez un
articulteur et j'ai été homme de ménage
et bien mon travail avait un sens je
savais que quand je faisais bien mon
travail les gens derrière travaillaient
dans de bonnes conditions donc même les
tâches qui semblent les plus primaires
on peut participer une oeuvre tout
dépend dans quel état d'esprit ça se
fait tout dépend comment l'entreprise
est vue comme une communauté humaine
réelle et à mon sens syndicaliste
chrétiens que je suis où j'étais
considère que l'entreprise c'est d'abord
une communauté humaine qui évidemment si
elle est dans le privé doit faire des
bénéfices pour se développer mais ce
sens de la communauté humaine et on le
voit très bien dans les différences
entre entreprises vois des entreprises
les mêmes ou sa dysfonctionne parce
qu'il y a plus de sens au travail il y a
pas eu de solidarité il y a des
entreprises qui vont faire la même chose
ça fonctionne parce qu'on est content
d'aller travailler avec les autres et on
sait le sens de notre travail c'est ça
qu'il faut aussi rétablir parce que je
suis désespéré quand je vois ces
milliers et ses milliers de personnes
qui ne travaillent pas et qui n'ont pas
envie de travailler alors que travailler
c'est se développer c'est ce grandir
mais voilà la clé elle se trouve
peut-être là dans vos mots chers Joseph
tout venant merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation je rappelle que vous êtes le
directeur de la rédaction de capital
social que j'ai actuellement entre les
mains et anciens vice-président de la
CFTC merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation nous sommes toujours en
direct sur figarolive et 18h30
actuellement nous sommes toujours dans
le cortège parisien qui est arrivé au
niveau de l'Opéra Garnier à Paris et
nous sommes avec Timothée delaime qui
est avec nous alors on a vu des fumées
des fumigènes il y a quelques instants
qu'en est-il actuellement
les amis ah apparemment nous avons un
petit problème de liaison avec Timothée
Delem qui est actuellement sur le
terrain on vient de le retrouver on
l'écoute
non nous ne sommes pas avec on ira le
revoir dans quelques instants voilà non
on est en direct Mathieu Valley qui est
qui est avec nous qui est policier
bonjour à vous vous êtes porte parole du
syndicat SIGP commise CP
je suis un peu dyslexique
exactement on va essayer de retrouver
Timothée delhayme dans quelques instants
parce que c'est important ce qui se
passe actuellement à Paris et puis on va
commenter bien évidemment ces images
ensemble parce que nous sommes pas loin
de nos locaux du Figaro tout ce que vous
voyez à l'image se passe dans le 9e
arrondissement de Paris au niveau de
l'Opéra garni on était au niveau des
Grands Boulevards si vous n'êtes pas
parisien c'est là-bas que je trouve
souvent les endroits ouvriers ou les
Parisiens sortent avec les théâtres etc
et a priori pour l'instant et bien les
les esprits sont retombées en tout cas
voilà le calme est redevenu est revenu
apparemment dans les rues de de Paris on
va revenir vers Timothée bonhomme dans
quelques instants Mathieu Valley donc je
disais vous êtes porte-parole du
syndicat et si c'était commissaire merci
à vous d'être sur ce plateau on a suivi
durant toute l'après-midi le cortège qui
a défilé dans les rues de Paris alors
des incidents ont éclaté on a vu
également des dégradations est-ce que
l'ordre a été correctement maintenu cet
après-midi selon vous bah d'abord on va
attendre que la manifestation se termine
puisque le point de distribution vous
l'avez que c'est place de l'Opéra
l'avait démarré à la place de la
Bastille hier après-midi j'ai rencontré
tous les commissaires de police qui
était engagés sur le dispositif
aujourd'hui à la préfecture de police de
Paris la Direction du renseignement de
la préfecture de police de Paris
craignait des gros débordements vous
savez que sur le cortège actuellement on
a plus de 1000 Black Blocs donc une
partie sont issus d'étrangers notamment
de l'Allemagne de la Belgique de ces
deux pays qui sont très pourvoyeurs de
Black Bloc et on sait que actuellement
on a un policier que vous avez vu sur
vos images à terre un policier de la 11e
compagnie d'intervention qui a perdu
connaissance qui est blessé très
sérieusement qui a été transporté à
l'hôpital qu'est-ce qu'il a ce policier
Vincent une blessure au niveau du visage
il a reçu un projectile au niveau du
casque mais quand on voit normalement
nos équipements tels qui sont composés
aujourd'hui ça a dû être un gros
projectile vous avez eu des jeux de
cocktail Molotov des jets d'excréments
aussi qui ont été faits sur les forces
de l'ordre vous avez des bombes
artisanales aujourd'hui il faut être
clair l'un des ennemis public numéro 1
c'est ultra gauche on a le terrorisme
islamiste qu'on combat actuellement et
qui me fait peser nos relations pays
l'ultra gauche aujourd'hui est à la
manœuvre et dans toutes les villes de
France et y compris sur vos images à
Paris alors l'ultra gauche justement on
en parle parce qu'elle est très active
actuellement dans les rues de Paris nous
sommes en direct avec Timothée delaime
qui se trouve non loin de ses
altercations entre les forces de l'ordre
et les manifestants que se passe-t-il
Timothée
[Musique]
et bien écoutez Damien il y a une charge
là qui vient d'être lancé vous entendez
ce slogan tout le monde déteste la
police c'est ce que scandale certains
manifestants en ce moment même je vous
disais tout à l'heure que le cortège
syndical a fini par arriver sur cette
sur cette place de l'Opéra vous voyez
l'Opéra qui est derrière nous avec
Julien Leclerc nous nous trouvons avenue
de de l'Opéra et nous pouvons donc
redescendre parce que comme il y a
beaucoup de monde évidemment la place de
l'Opéra ne suffit pas à accueillir tous
tout ce monde donc cette avenue de
l'Opéra qui est elle aussi bien remplie
vous voyez au fond de l'avenue de
l'Opéra en direction du musée du Louvre
et bien
ces quarts de CRS qui sont venus et bien
pour encercler cette cette place de
l'Opéra là aussi par exemple pour bien
vous montrer sur ces images la rue Louis
Legrand qui est bouclée par les CRS pour
quelle raison et bien parce que
l'objectif c'est d'éviter que des
cortège sauvages ne se forment aux
alentours de la place de l'Opéra et
quitte l'itinéraire qui lui a été
évidemment déclaré en préfecture la
place et donc bouclée par les CRS les
manifestants qui ne peuvent pas la
quitter par n'importe quelle rue pour
éviter comme je vous le disais que des
cortège sauvages ne se forment pour ce
qui est des violences il y a eu des
moments de grande tension tout à l'heure
vraiment des grandes tensions avec de
nombreuses charges avec de nombreux
projets qui ont été lancés en direction
des forces de l'ordre la situation qui
s'est calmée depuis que le cortège
syndical est arrivé mais malgré tout on
sent évidemment une grande tension dans
l'air à tout moment ça peut partir comme
c'est le cas d'ailleurs actuellement
vous le voyez cette colonne de CRS donc
je vous parlais tout à l'heure qui est
en train et bien de s'avancer pour
intervenir dormir je sais pas exactement
ce qu'il s'est passé en tout cas il y a
à nouveau cette odeur nauséabonde c'est
un c'est un feu en fait qui a été allumé
là-bas vous voyez probablement la fumée
sur ces sur ces images filmées par par
Julien Leclerc et donc voilà une
situation toujours aussi confuse
toujours aussi tendue et on sent que la
manifestation à proprement parler est
terminée mais la soirée elle est loin
loin d'être fini ici peut-être en direct
de l'Opéra Garnier à Paris alors la
question moi que j'ai envie de vous
poser Mathieu vallée porte-parole du
syndicat siccp la commissaire est-ce que
les forces de l'ordre sont réellement
entraînées à gérer ce genre de de
manifestation parce que vous l'avez
rappelé tout à l'heure il y a plus de
1000 Black Blocs dans les rues de Paris
on a le sentiment que c'est démesuré
quoi alors vous avez 31 forces mobiles
c'était un des compagnies républicaines
de sécurité des escadrons de gendarmerie
mobile là si je peux me permettre
commenter ce que votre reporter dit sur
le terrain on est en train de fixer ce
qui est le plus simple en matière de
l'ordre pour les policiers les gendarmes
toute la population et les manifestants
qui arrivent sur la place de l'Opéra
pour qu'on ait qu'un seul point à gérer
et c'est pour ça que dans toutes les
artères toutes les relations que vous
voyez des gendarmes ou des policiers qui
bloquent pour qu'on ait pas de cortège
évidemment sauvage ensuite oui on a été
formé on a appris des ultra jaune et du
mouvement des gilets jaunes qui avaient
démarré 17 novembre 2018 et qui
rappelez-vous avait atteint son
paroxysme le premier le 8 décembre que
ça soit à Paris a pu enlever ou dans les
grandes villes de France et aussi le 16
mars 2019 à Paris sur les Champs-Élysées
qui avait été transformé en champ de
bataille donc on a des techniques vous
avez les braves Mike vous avez les
compagnies d'intervention qui sont à 6
séances les braves c'est les les
brigades de répression violente je me
permets puisque comme le détracteurs se
font un malin plaisir d'en faire une
publicité négative ce sont des policiers
courageux à moto qui ne sont pas des
Voltigeurs puisque en fait leur moto
leur permet d'être mobile réactive
dynamique de se faufiler dans les rues
très étroites de la capitale et en fait
là où un véhicule met 10 15 minutes
quand je suis optimiste pour aller
d'apprendre à un point B une moto ça met
moins de 3 donc vous avez un conducteur
qui emmène derrière lui un opérateur il
met environ 20 hommes donc 20 motos 20
conducteurs qui restent en moto 20
opérateurs qui descendent il vaut au
contact du point chaud ils font
éventuellement des interpellations il
remettent à des effectifs à proximité et
il repartent le but c'est pas exposer
les motos c'est que les policiers
peuvent être projetés rapidement et
repris rapidement ça c'est une des
nouvelles nouveautés du schéma NASA du
machin de l'ordre et ça ça c'est l'un
des enseignements des gilets jaunes par
exemple c'est c'est brave si vous voulez
c'est brigade de répression de l'action
violente comme ce nom l'indique ne sont
pas pour faire de la prévention et sans
les braves Mike on aurait des scènes de
chaos plus importantes j'ai entendu la
polémique qui depuis une semaine toutes
les nuits qui silolent les rues de la
capitale font l'objet de détracteur de
critiques et de d'insultes pour certains
à terme il faut pas dissoudre ces unités
essentielles indispensables dans la
capitale parce qu'ils sont mobiles ils
sont dynamiques il sera actifs ce sont
des policiers qui sont formés il y a 10
jours ils étaient à l'école de police de
Nîmes là où sont formés les élèves
policiers pour présenter leur technicité
et leur expertise et il faut savoir
aussi des policiers qui conduisent les
motos suivent une formation de 3 mois à
l'école de police de sens donc ça veut
dire qu'on met pas n'importe qui sur ces
motos ils sont formés ils sont très
formés et les opérateurs à l'arrière ce
sont des policiers en compagnie
d'intervention qui tournent à tour de
rôle et qui sont formés aguerris et
entraînés au match de Lord au
rétablissement et là malheureusement on
passe dans les violences urbaines quand
vous avez des poubelles incendies du
mobilier urbain qui est dégradé des
policiers qui font l'objet d'attaque de
jeu de projectiles d'extrêmement et de
cocktail Molotov on voit que on a besoin
de ces braves Mike pour être réactif
dans ce dispositif sans eux ça serait
très compliqué si vous voulez j'en
terminerai là les gendarmes et les CRS
fixent les lieux chêne les rues Chelles
le terrain peuvent faire des manœuvres
de dispersion sauf que pour
l'interpellation et la mobilité vous
savez avec 22 kg d'équipements sur dos
c'est très compliqué d'avancer c'est
très compliqué d'aller interpeller c'est
très compliqué de sortir avec des gens
qu'on a intercepté et donc c'est brave
Mike elles ont cette capacité de
compléter l'action des forces mobiles
sur le terrain mais est-ce qu'elles sont
suffisantes c'est la question que je
vous pose parce que là effectivement on
voit un cortège on ne peut plus
classique c'est vrai c'est syndical avec
un itinéraire qui est tracé par la
préfecture de police de Paris mais ces
derniers jours on a vu aussi des
cortèges très mobiles dans la ville de
Paris avec des manifestations qui
d'ailleurs pas du tout déclaré est-ce
qu'à ce moment là ces braves est-ce que
c'est policier à moto sont suffisants
pour pouvoir appréhender ces
manifestants ultra violents on a
l'impression que parfois il court après
ces manifestants qu'ils ont toujours un
train de retard alors j'ai eu la chance
hier de m'entretenir avec le commandant
qui dirige ses braves Mike à la
préfecture de police il m'a montré des
vidéos sur son téléphone où on voit
qu'ils sont très mobiles qu'ils arrivent
souvent alors c'est ce qu'il me disait à
éviter des débordements des exactions
qui sont par nature pas quand il fait
puisqu'ils n'ont pas été commis donc
c'est ce que je vous disais sans eux on
aurait des scènes de chaos encore plus
importantes que s'il n'était pas là et
vous savez par exemple avant de chercher
ils ont sauvé d'un immeuble des gens qui
étaient pris des flammes parce qu'on
avait des émeutiers qui avaient ascendie
des poubelles à proximité des façades
des habitations donc il y a un non
conséquent de policier à moto qu'on
appelle les braves Mike en faut plus on
est parfaitement d'accord là je vous
rappelle quand même que sur le
dispositif on a plus de 5000 policiers
gendarmes 31 forces mobiles si
compagnies d'intervention c'est-à-dire
la totalité des campagnes intervention
de la préfecture de police de Paris qui
sont plus les braves Mike donc vous
voyez on a tous les dispositifs mis en
place sur le cortège parisien et
effectivement on aurait aimé plus de
force mobile sur la capitale mais
évidemment vous avez vu à Nantes à
Lorient à Lyon à Lille à Bordeaux à
Marseille il fallait aussi des forces
pour lui parce que la province fait
aussi l'objet de manifestation qui
malheureusement pour certaines villes
ont été en proie à ultra gauche qui a
mené des exactions inadmissibles vers
nos collègues et vers des bâtiments
aussi institutionnels et quand on voit
alors là je vous parle en tant que
novice mais quand on voit ce genre de
scène dans Paris et on se dit est-ce
qu'il ne faut pas mettre encore
davantage de force sur le terrain de
façon à ce que c'est 1000 black block
soient complètement encerclé alors si je
peux me permettre comme ça peut-être
pour voter les spectateurs là on voit
des gendarmes mobiles évidemment sur ce
qu'on appelle en carapace donc c'est à
dire que vous avez un collègue un
camarade de la gendarmerie ou c'est un
collection devant qui mène la troupe
avec un officier et un commissaire qui
est rattaché à chaque unité de force
froide donc on a un commissaire de
police donc je fais aujourd'hui l'un des
représentants qui manœuvrent avec
l'unité en lien avec la salle de
commandement la direction de leur public
et la circulation et là vous voyez c'est
une très périlleuse parce que vous avez
comme une tortue des collègues et des
camarades qui avancent devant là ils
rentrent carrément à mon avis disloqué
ou pas le contact d'un groupe de Black
Blocs ou d'individus violents et il
s'expose énormément puisque vous voyez
bien que là il court là c'est les
compagnies d'intervention de la
préfecture de police de Paris ils ont
deux bandes bleues là il y a une charge
qui est venue c'est pas un bon sensible
c'est une charge c'est-à-dire que
l'autorité hiérarchique leur demande
d'aller d'un point 1 à un point B pour
aller au contact d'individus violents de
groupuscules à risque et pour les
stocker voir les interpeller et là sur
votre image de gauche je sais pas si on
voit les deux c'est les gendarmes qui
sont en train de tenir une rue et qui
fonctionnent votre carapace c'est à dire
que vous avez une unité de vent cassure
la visibilité une unité derrière cassure
la protection et là vous voyez le
policier où il marqué police c'est un
commissaire de police qui est rattaché à
l'unité de fortune je sais que pour nos
concitoyens la technicité et l'expertise
de leur public et parfois illisible
parce qu'on a des acronymes on a des
techniques on a une doctrine qui est pas
forcément compréhensible pour le quai
d'Inde des mortels mais c'est un peu
comme un chef cuisinier dans sa dans sa
cuisine il a il a le secret des recettes
et des ingrédients qui en font un chef
étoilé ou pas nous le but faut qu'on
fasse preuve d'un haut niveau
d'expertise et de professionnalisme dans
ce qui est notre coeur du métier
rétablir leur public et cette stratégie
elle est nouvelle Matthieu Valley ou
bien c'est
issu de la doctrine du nouveau préfet de
police de Paris lors du nez je pense
qu'il faut détacher les doctrines des
préfets de police on avait un préfet de
police DJ l'Allemand qui était
effectivement très à l'offensive et très
percutant parfois on avait des
difficultés d'ailleurs à avoir le lien
avec les organisations syndicales ce qui
nous est cruellement défaut et c'est
qu'aujourd'hui avec le nouveau préfet on
a vous savez que les nuits Journées
Nationales d'action sans compter celle
d'aujourd'hui se sont bien déroulées
parce que les services d'ordre des
syndicats travaillaient en lien étroit
permanent avec les forces de l'ordre
ensuite vous avez raison changement
notable depuis 2018 il y avait l'ancien
préfet Michel Delpech qui a été limogé
en mars 2019 à l'issue de l'attaque des
Champs-Élysées par les Black Blocs on a
eu un changement de doctrimé de
paradigme si vous voulez avant on était
dans une stratégie de mise à distance
dans une stratégie de mise en retrait là
on voit bien que dès qu'on adopte cette
stratégie on le paye cache le 7 mars
2000 23 lors de la manifestation près de
la place
seulement 14 personnes avaient été
interpellées principalement pour port
d'armes prohibé et participation un
groupement en vue de commettre des
dégradations et violences c'est un
chiffre qui nous a été communiqué par la
préfecture de police de Paris 14
personnes ça paraît peu il y aura mon
sens très peu d'interpellations alors je
suis pas invisible et je peux pas
prévenir l'avenir malheureusement pour
certaines choses c'est peut-être pour le
tout non mais détente à part on a
effectivement très peu d'interpellations
à mon avis on attendra le bilan
consolidé à l'issue d'un manifestation
et des violences parce que là le but
c'est de rétablir l'ordre c'est d'éviter
qu'on ait des magasins qui soient
dégradés des policiers qui soient
blessés et comme on a énormément
d'éléments radicaux et de groupuscules
qui se mur Black Bloc la priorité c'est
préserver l'intégrité de nos
fonctionnaires et de protéger les Kidam
et les citoyens pacifiques qui viennent
manifester c'est ça la priorité si il y
a des interpeller si j'ose dire c'est de
bâbord c'est la soirée sur le gâteau
dans le cadre aujourd'hui qui nous
intéresse exactement ça c'est le baba au
rhum mais parfois le baba au rhum a
tendance à pourrir si j'avais envie de
utiliser encore cette expression là
parce que malheureusement il n'y a pas
de suite judiciaire on l'a vu récemment
oui alors vous savez moi j'ai lu le
communiqué du Syndicat de la
magistrature j'en profite de votre
plateau pour le dire j'ai pas de leçon
on a pas de leçon à recevoir d'un
syndicat qui a érigé le mur des cons qui
a été condamné pour ça alors qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé avec ce communiqué de la
magistrature si vous voulez mais
effectivement pardon parce que c'est
vrai que quand on est policier on est
baigné dans ses acronymes dans cette
culture d'ailleurs quand je vais manger
avec des amis qui sont pas policiers
au-delà des amandes et des
contraventions qu'on veut faire sauter
c'est les premières questions qu'on nous
pose non en réalité ce syndicat d'un
magistrature qui est classé à la gauche
de la gauche pour une autre système
judiciaire si aujourd'hui nos
compatriotes n'ont plus confiance en
notre justice c'est parce que elle est
gangrenée par ce syndicat de la
magistrature qui est plus pour la
culture de l'excuse plutôt que la
culture de la sévérité qui est plus à
justifier l'inacceptable par des
délinquants plutôt que de protéger les
victimes et ce syndicat estimait que les
interpellations qui avaient été opéré
depuis une semaine avec les violences
urban que vous avez constaté depuis
cette nuit notamment dans la capitale
mais aussi à Lyon à Lille à Marseille à
Bordeaux et ben elle estime que ces
dictatoriales que c'est un régime
autoritaire alors que c'est pas du tout
le cas et je rappelle que les gardes à
contrôlés par les magistrats du parquet
qui sont à mon sens indépendants s'ils
sont au fait du drone donc ce syndicat à
part représenter la propre personne et
ériger un mur des cons et pas être dans
la moralité et le respect des
institutions il apporte rien de bon ça
c'est pour le côté juste maintenant
quand vous êtes en intervention vous
voyez bien regarder des policiers des
gendarmes en train de courir vous
interpellez des personnes qui s'adonnent
à des violences des exactions qui se
constituent les infractions que vous
avez indiquées des dégradations en
réunion des participations à un
groupement armés et bien effectivement
ensuite on a pas le temps de faire des
grandes littérature on fait un rapport
de mise à disposition même en mieux on
remplit une fiche parce que le temps que
le policier ou le gendarme remplit cette
fiche il est plus sur le terrain où il
est plus avoir public avec ses collègues
pour manœuvrer je vous donne un exemple
très précis pour vos téléspectateurs
comprennent quand on a un CRS ou une
section de CRS puisque une CRS en
moyenne 3 ou 4 sections interpelle un
individu toute la CRS est bloquée tant
que l'individu n'a pas été pris en
charge par un véhicule pour être
présenté à l'office de police judiciaire
et mis en garde à vue le cas échéant
dans un commissariat c'est toute une
compagnie qui est mis HS si j'ose dire
ce qui représente entre 60 et 80
policiers en fonction qu'on est trois ou
quatre sections 80 policiers en moins
sur le terrain ça se ressent tout de
suite sur une rue à tenir sur une charge
à mener sur un appui à apporter
lorsqu'on fait des bons ou des charges
pour contrer les groupuscules radicaux
et ceux qui viennent semer le chaos dans
les cortèges alors on va retourner dans
quelques instants sur le terrain
retrouver notre collègue Timothée Delam
mais pour le moment apparemment ils se
sont un petit peu séparés en raison
d'une charge policière que vous avez pu
voir sur sur nos écrans c'est très
intéressant ça souvent les gens ne
comprennent pas d'abord il faut le dire
oui il faut que nous autorités
politiques l'assument un peu plus en
ordre public on ne fait jamais des
belles images on est obligé comme la loi
nous le permet et comme c'est inscrit
dans la Constitution d'utiliser la force
légitime et malheureusement on peut pas
dire aux policiers aller au contact
interpeller les fauteurs de troubles et
en même temps faites attention à qui
vous interpellez quand on a des bateaux
quand on a des gens qui regardent comme
on le voit sur vos images il y a un
risque de dommage collatéraux ça c'est
vrai et il faut l'accepter soit on
laisse faire on laisse tout casser on
laisse l'anarchie s'installer soit on
accepte que les policiers en faisant des
charges en faisant des bons offensives
en faisant des interpellations de
groupes à risque puisse y avoir des
badauds des quidams qui n'ont rien à
faire à proximité qui ne s'est
désolidarisent pas de facto des casseurs
et qui peuvent être se prêts à partir
par la charge ou qui peuvent être
interpellés le cas échéant pour un
participant armé ça c'est très peu dit
mais il faut le préciser sur à mon avis
votre antenne et je pense qu'on va
assister beaucoup dessus dans les médias
à venir alors Mathieu Valley j'aimerais
qu'on revienne un petit peu à l'origine
d'une manifestation très concrètement
comment la préfecture fait-elle pour
préparer une stratégie à adopter dans le
cadre d'une manifestation de cet ampleur
là est-ce qu'on estime le nombre de
manifestants et proportionnellement à ce
nombre là on on invite des CRS à
l'encadrer est-ce qu'en fonction de
l'intensité de la violence aussi qu'on
redoute on va mettre plus ou moins
d'hommes à tel endroit comment ça se
passe concrètement très simple on a des
organisations syndicales ou des
déclarants qui annoncent à la préfecture
qui veulent faire une manifestation avec
un parcours à tracer avec trois
responsables identifiés domicilié avec
la préfecture aura comme interlocuteur
par nature le récipissé que la
préfecture donne je dis parce qu'il y a
eu beaucoup de débats lors des gilets
jaunes sur ça ça vaut pas autorisation
ça vaut pour prise en compte ma
préfecture ensuite si la préfecture de
police estime par la Direction du
renseignement qui sont les zones de
l'ombre qui vont calculer un peu savoir
est-ce qu'il y a des éléments à risque
qui peuvent venir est-ce qu'il va y
avoir des individus violents qui peuvent
s'immiscer est-ce que le cortège va
poser problème là le préfet peut prendre
un arrêté d'interdiction et à ce
moment-là la manifestation interdite là
elle est autorisée lorsqu'elle est
autorisée la Direction du renseignement
qui dirigée par une femme à la
préfecture de police de Paris donne une
estimation du nombre de participants
pacifiques qui vont venir et du nombre
de personnes à risque aujourd'hui cette
direction a indiqué qu'il y avait entre
40000 et 70 000 personnes qui devaient
venir à Paris au niveau national c'est
le renseignement territorial pardon
c'est les acronymes et les directions de
la police donc qui a annoncé entre 600
000 et 800 000 personnes et pour la
manifestation parisienne qui nous
intéresse on annoncé 400 à 600 éléments
radicaux le renseignement territorial
fait-il pour estimer cette fourchette de
manifestants et qui plus est ces
militants radicaux qui vont venir
perturber les manifestations à part
comment font-ils pour pour dire tiens il
va y avoir aujourd'hui 1000 Black Blocs
un peu notre fonctionnement on a ce
qu'on appelle le milieu ouvert et le
milieu fermé le milieu ouvert c'est par
la presse c'est par les contacts avec
les organisations syndicales avec les
contacts qu'on a régulièrement avec les
partenaires sociaux ils vont indiquer en
fonction des cars qui font venir de
province en fonction de leurs adhérents
ou dans sa patients qui risquent de
participer à la manifestation nous
donner une fourchette de participants
ensuite en milieu fermé on suit avec des
techniques d'enquête très poussées que
la loi qui lutte notamment contre les
terrorisme nous a donné la loi de 2010
de juillet si je valide août 2018 quand
on a régularisé pas mal de techniques et
immessi catcher les écoutes et les
interceptions administratives etc ça
permet en fait de suivre des groupes à
risque suivre des Black Blocs nos
partenaires étrangers avec qui on a une
coopération exceptionnelle nous
permettent aussi de savoir si on a des
étrangers qui vont venir et à ce moment
là vous avez raison le renseignement
c'est un peu Merlin le vizir c'est pour
leur demande de faire des prévisions et
des prédictions là où personne d'autre
n'y arriverait et il donne une
fourchette et cette fourchette elle est
primordiale pourquoi parce que vous me
le demandiez le nombre de forces mobiles
et le nombre de policiers de gendarmes
qu'on va mettre sur le terrain sera la
conséquence des estimations que le
renseignement va nous donner donc là on
avait 31 forts je sais que la préfecture
en avait demandé une dizaine de plus
mais je vous ai dit vous l'avez vu on
aurait peut-être en parler après à
Lorient à Nantes à Rennes un peu à Lyon
des retours de terrain que j'ai eu il y
a eu des exactions violentes des
groupuscules de l'ultra gauche donc il
faut aussi que c'est policiers dans ces
commissariats locaux puisse avoir
l'appui des forces en ligne donc la
capitale malheureusement ne peut pas
concentrer toutes les attaques et rap et
vous j'en terminerai là en novembre 2018
préfecture du Puy-en-Velay pas de CRS
pas de gendarme pas d'appui vous avez la
préfecture qui a été brûlée vous avez eu
des dizaines de blessés parmi les
policiers et ils ont tenu la
représentation d'État à bout de bras
donc tout ça il faut l'avoir en compte
et après c'est le ministère de
l'Intérieur qui arbitre le nombre de
répartitions de forces mobiles donc
c'est gendarmes nécessaires qui vont
dispatcher sur l'ensemble du territoire
national en fonction de ce que chaque
service de renseignement va évaluer dans
chaque zone et dans chaque ville qui
sera ensuite recoupée compilé et fera
l'objet d'une note nationale c'est les
fameuses notes dont on parle souvent les
médias avec crimes et qui font
saignement exactement et qui sont
transmis à nos autorités ministérielles
allez on va retourner du côté du terrain
du côté du cortège parisien qui s'est
bien disloqué on peut le dire avec
Timothée delaime qui se trouve non loin
je crois de la place de l'Opéra Garnier
en plein cœur de Paris est-ce que
l'ambiance est retombée est-ce que les
esprits se sont calmés Timothée
qu'est-ce qui se passe
et bien écoutez Damien on est toujours
dans cette ambiance très très confuse ce
qui se passe actuellement alors là nous
sommes avenue de l'Opéra cette avenue
qui donne donc sur cette place de
l'Opéra que vous voyez derrière moi et
donc devant moi Julien Leclerc va vous
montrer cela ce sont donc les forces de
l'ordre qui sont en train et bien de
remonter avec leur camion avec les
sirènes donc là ils sont à l'arrêt mais
ils progressent voilà d'ici une minute
ils vont recommencer à avancer quelques
mètres avec les sirènes et donc
l'objectif c'est de faire évacuer cette
avenue de l'Opéra ce sont les CRS là qui
sont qui sont à l'oeuvre vous le voyez
quelques dégâts malheureusement ici par
exemple ce sont c'est un une personne
qui est en train de se faire soigner
c'est vrai qu'il y a voilà il y a eu des
moments de de grandes tensions et donc
certains des plutôt des jeunes
d'ailleurs qui sont là qui proposent de
l'aide pour
qui qui ont peut-être été touchés par un
par un jeu de projectile pour ceux qui
ont du mal à respirer suite au tir de
gaz lacrymogène en tous les cas voilà je
vous le disais donc les CRS qui sont en
train de progresser qui vont avancer
jusqu'à cette place de l'Opéra pour
l'instant la foule ne sait pas encore
dispersé certains ont quitté les lieux
mais il y a encore beaucoup de monde
ceux qui restent se sont majoritairement
des jeunes vous le voyez peut-être sur
ces images beaucoup de d'étudiants
probablement qui sont encore sur les
lieux et là on voit et bien qu'il y a
comme souvent dans ce dans ce genre de
de
moments de tension un un période
d'académie où tout le monde se regarde
un petit peu et puis voilà peut-être que
cela va reprendre dans quelques minutes
quelques jeux de projectiles une charge
et puis ensuite à nouveau une accalmie
on se regarde voilà
c'est toujours très très confus et les
CRS je vois
il semble que ce soit le commissaire des
visionnaires qui qui va ordonner d'ici
quelques secondes au camion de CRS et
bien d'avancer de nouveau pour tenter
d'évacuer cette avenue de l'Opéra merci
beaucoup Timothée delaime en direct de
l'avenue de l'Opéra à Paris alors le
dernier décompte indique qu'il y a eu
finalement 26 interpellations au total à
Paris bon c'est vrai que ça parait assez
peu mais on imagine que les
interpellations que le chiffre va
gonfler au fur et à mesure que que la
soirée avance c'est très intéressant
cette image effectivement avec ces
quarts de CRS qui se trouve avenue de
l'Opéra et qui empêche quelque part les
manifestants de sortir de ce périmètre
est-ce que le risque ce soir Mathieu
Valley c'est que les manifestants comme
ça a été le cas au cours des derniers
jours joue au jeu du chat et la souris
pendant toute la soirée avec la police
ou bien c'est pas forcément une fatalité
la police elle protège des institutions
de la République et d'ailleurs je peux
vous dire qu'actuellement on a des
unités qui ont fait mouvement sur la
place Phantom puisqu'on a le ministère
de la Justice qui besoins et aussi place
de la Concorde parce qu'on a l'Elysée
l'Assemblée nationale qui sont aussi à
proximité donc oui il y a un risque au
même titre que les nuits précédentes
bien que celles de mercredi à jeudi hier
soir c'est plutôt bien passé par rapport
aussi précédentes notamment en termes de
violences urbaine et d'interpellation et
c'est vrai que là si je peux me
permettre sur votre écran en fait les
cartes de CRS ne sont pas logiquement
pour empêcher les personnes d'aller
encore être sauvage c'est aussi ce qu'on
appelle la stratégie des gros muscles
montrez les gros muscles pour ne pas
avoir les utiliser alors c'est pas la
stratégie du crocodile avec une grande
bouche et des petits bras c'est la
stratégie du gros musc de pouvoir les
gonfler de manière à ce qu'on soit
impressionnant on va pas derrière qu'on
soit imposant et qu'on n'est pas utilisé
la force donc là les gyrophares sont
allumés les garçons alignés vous avez
des sections que vous voyez devant vous
des CRS qui sont éparpillés tout au long
de l'avenue pour qu'on enchaîne le point
du mur A au point B de manière à ce que
là évidemment personne ne passe et le
commissaire divisionnaire je le préciser
des propos de votre porter ne fait pas
une charge on n'avance pas d'initiative
tout est coordonné je leur engage parce
qu'on en parle jamais par la salle de
commandement de la préfecture de police
de Paris c'est des policiers derrière
leur pupitre qui ont toutes les caméras
de la capitale qui ont toutes les ondes
radio pour coordonner les unités mobiles
unité de terrain les unités locales de
manière à ce qu'on fasse quelque chose
de coordonné d'orchestrer et vous avez
une préfet de police vous avez le
directeur de leur public la circulation
qui sont en réalité les chefs
d'orchestre dans un orchestre aucun
musicien ne joue sa musique tout seul il
y a une partition qui est notre schéma
national vous avez un chef d'orchestre
qui est préfet de police et directeur de
leur public et vous avez sur le terrain
ces musiciens qui font rendre hommage
que sont ces policiers puisque un
musicien c'est quelqu'un qui est formé à
guéri expert de sa matière et ben là
vous avez la même chose en ordre public
alors justement c'est intéressant ce que
vous dites par rapport à ces charges de
policiers j'étais dans ce cortège là
pour être honnête avec vous le 15 mars
dernier dans le cortège à Paris pas très
loin des éléments
c'est absolument je n'étais pas aussi
bien habillé je dois vous dire la vérité
et en fait parfois on se demande à quel
moment les charges sont décidées par les
supérieurs de ces CRS qui se trouve sur
le terrain on a l'impression qu'il se
passe pas grand chose qu'il y a un black
bloc qui se forme qu'il n'y a pas
spécialement de violence à ce moment-là
mais que comme d'un seul homme c'est
policiers vont bondir d'une rue qui se
trouve d'ailleurs souvent parallèle et
appréhender voir interpeller des des
personnes bien précises est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner les coulisses de ce
genre de je vous fais la distinction une
charge c'est quand on veut récupérer un
pardon une charge c'est quand on va
aller au contact d'un groupe à risque et
qu'on veut les percuter c'est-à-dire
notamment souvent dit pourquoi vous
percutez les banderoles derrière
lesquels il y a des revendications non
souvent les banderoles elles sont
matelassées elles sont renforcés
derrière par les Black Blocs ce qui en
fait un bouclier à ciel ouvert donc la
charge elle permet de percuter par
exemple cette banderole d'aller chercher
les Black Blocs les disperser quand on
peut les interpeller de manière à ce
qu'après le rapport de force est
installé les interpellations sont faites
la donne et le tempo sont donnés par les
policiers et pour quelle raison y
allez-vous pas dès le début parce que
les Black Blocs comme vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure il se forme très tôt dans
la manifestation il se forme très
rapidement
très rapidement alors pas forcément très
tôt alors il y a une opportunité d'aller
au contact vous savez que d'envoyer des
unités au contact ça sous-entend et je
vous l'ai expliqué tout à l'heure
d'avoir des groupes de policiers qui
sont isolés même s'ils sont nombreux
d'avoir une mobilité sur lesquelles à
tout moment puisse leur dire vous
revenez parce qu'on vous a trop exposé
et à ce moment dans cerclé je vous donne
les images de tout à l'heure regardez
Strasbourg Saint-Denis on a fait des
charges les policiers ont été dépassés
par les manifestants les individus
violents qui ne sont pas des
manifestants face à eux ils ont fait ce
qu'on appelle un repli stratégique
puisque au lieu d'aller au carton et
d'avoir x blessé parmi les policiers on
préfère reculer pour mieux revenir en
force et ça c'est une jauge
effectivement qui est très compliqué à
décider et c'est ce que je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure c'est chef d'orchestre à
la salle de presse de commandement qui
avec le retour du terrain avec les
caméras de la préfecture peut déterminer
si c'est le bon moment d'aller à la
charge et c'est là où je voulais quand
même le terminer il y a la charge pour
aller percuter il y a le bon sensif le
bon offensif on est par exemple devant
le siège du Figaro boulevard Haussmann
on veut aller vers opéra on fait un bon
pour faire reculer les gens et pour
récupérer du terrain sans qu'il
interpellation c'est la différence entre
une charge et un bon voilà ça c'est du
technique très policier mais là on a eu
beaucoup de charges parce
qu'effectivement au début du cortège
vous avez énormément de la blocs qui se
sont constitués mais ils sont très
rapides ils arrivent à changer de
vêtements en moins d'une minute ils
arrivent à se remettre à morphoser en
vêtements initial avant même qu'on ait
pu parfois les interpeller même parfois
lorsque
on essaie de plus en plus de le faire on
arrive à suivre par les caméras et par
des techniques que je vais évidemment
pas ici exposer les individus qui ont
commis des violences et ben on les
interpelle après la manifestation je
donne un exemple très concret le 7 mars
le médecin de SOS médecins qui avait été
agressé dans enfin son véhicule a été
dégradé dans Paris qui avait en plus
jeté des projets l'individu sur des
policiers des gendarmes c'était le même
individu il a été suivi de A à Z ah ben
on a déjà on a des techniques et des
sources fermées comme j'étais
c'est-à-dire des techniques qu'on peut
pas évoquer sur le plateau qui nous
permettent de le faire et vous avez la
capitale qui est émaillée de caméra et
ça c'est un vrai plus c'est pour ça que
nous on demande que dans toutes les
villes de France ont pu savoir un
maillage de caméra vidéoprotection non
pas pour fliquer les gens mais tout
simplement pour faciliter le travail des
policiers lorsqu'on recherche des
individus lorsqu'on veut faire des
manœuvres dans public parce qu'on sait
bien que quand on a une physionomie sur
l'ensemble du territoire ça permet de la
faciliter et je rajoute un petit point
si vous me permettez on a les drones
qu'on parle dont on parle très peu le
drone ça permet avec ce qu'on connaît un
engin et reporté avec une caméra d'aller
faire une autonomie d'aller voir un
point par exemple qui peut être chaud et
sur les caisses on envoyait des
policiers il pourrait être immédiatement
prêt à partir donc le drone c'est
vraiment une solution de facilité de
simplicité et de sécurité dans la
manifestation à Paris aujourd'hui je ne
pense pas mais on peut être amené à
l'utiliser vous savez que le Conseil
constitutionnel nous l'avait interdit
avec le Conseil d'État pendant x temps
et depuis moins de 2 ans il y a eu un
changement de législation notamment avec
la loi sécurité globale qui ont permis
de pouvoir utiliser ces drones vous
savez moi j'ai travaillé à Marseille à
la Castellane à cité de Zidane vous
allez dans l'Afrique de subéfiant les
dealers ils ont pas attendu le Conseil
d'État pour utiliser des drones
absolument voilà donc c'est toujours
pareil on passe pour les derniers de
corvées puisque vous avez les dealers
vous avez des agresseurs les voleurs et
les casseurs qui ont le droit d'utiliser
du matériel
alors moi j'entends qu'on dit les sages
du Conseil constitutionnel ça serait
bien que l'état de droits sont un peu du
côté des policiers qui protègent les
victimes plutôt que des délinquants qui
font des victimes c'est un peu ce qu'on
dit en fait c'est du bon sens je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on manque cruellement de
bon sens dans les décisions du politique
et dans les décisions qui sont prises
chaque jour sur le terrain le bon sens
c'est quoi c'est simplement de la
logique vous savez pour être moi je fais
des résidences de jury de recrutement on
demande du bon sens on demande pas
d'avoir fait Sciences Po d'avoir fait
des nains il y en a qui ont des têtes
bien rondes et bien faites et c'est pas
pour autant des bons policiers il y en a
qui ont à peine le bac mais c'était mon
cas quand je suis rentré gardien de la
paix et pour autant qu'on a du bon sens
on fait du bon travail et c'est le bon
sens aujourd'hui qui monte dans les
décisions politiques notamment sur les
drones mais je pourrais vous parler d'un
autre sujet parce que si vous me lancez
je suis parti c'est sur les Black Blocs
on a réussi avec le plan Leprou en 91 de
lutter contre les oliganes et les
factieux dans les stades de foot avec la
possibilité au préfet d'interdire aux
gens violents de venir dans les stats
c'est à dire qu'on attendit on attend
pas la décision d'un juge pour interdire
individuellement de personnes à un stade
dès qu'on a des éléments du
renseignement et sur son passif par des
condamnations de l'individu violent on
va pas attendre qu'il casse tout dans le
stade on interdit tout simplement de
venir en le faisant pointer au
commissariat de là où il habite pendant
avant pendant et après là on aimerait
bien le faire pour les Black Blocs
c'est-à-dire les éléments radicaux qui
constituent les blocs c'est pas possible
puisque le Conseil constitutionnel nous
dit un stade c'est fermé il y a une
billetterie il y a un accès qui est
contrôlé c'est géré par des prestataires
privés alors c'est plus important
aujourd'hui de protéger nos stats que de
protéger nos manifestations qui sont un
droit inali même constitution donc là
c'est pareil moi je demande on demande
dans mon syndicat qui a un débat public
sur la possibilité d'interdire
administrativement ces gens de venir
dans les manifestations pour se mettre
des violences alors là on est en train
de voir des des policiers qui sont en
train d'avancer avenue de l'Opéra c'est
vrai que c'est policier ils ont toujours
un accoutrement assez impressionnant ce
bouclier très lourd vous avez dit tout à
l'heure 22 kg c'est quoi exactement
l'équipement d'un policier aujourd'hui
en manifestation il y a un temps fa donc
cette espèce de bâton là qui peut
d'ailleurs par permettre parfois de
frapper les manifestants un petit peu
violents
et puis également le le le bouclier il y
a des quoi des grenades de
désencerclement qui sont utilisés aussi
qu'on entend assez souvent dans les
vidéos que vous avez d'autres choses
effectivement ceux qui disent que nos
collègues sont des robocops lorsqu'on
voit par exemple un Fos-sur-Mer mardi
mardi la dernière lorsqu'il a fallu
débloquer la raffinerie on a un CRS de
Marseille qui intervenu et qui malgré
ses jambières c'est ce que vous voyez au
niveau comme un comme un joueur de
football c'est un collier d'avoir des
Jean-Pierre pour faire du foot ils ont
des jambières renforcés pour faire du
match à Land et ben ça a transpercé la
fusée des tresses la jambière il était
grève en blessé à la malléole à l'artère
avec une opération d'urgence dans la
foulée malgré l'équipement lourd malgré
l'équipement en fait on a fait beaucoup
d'avancées dans l'équipement
rappelez-vous alors moi j'étais jeune
mais je l'ai appris en école de police
la manifestation démarre un pêcheur à
Rennes en 95 c'était une boucherie en
terme de policier blessé parce qu'ils
étaient pas du tout protégés là
désormais vous le voyez sur vos images
on a un casque qui renforcé pour match
en langue on a ce qu'on appelle un gilet
tactique avec des épaules et des
protèges bras pour éviter d'avoir un
impact de projectile sur les avant-bras
et le torse du corps on a ensuite des
jambières on a parfois aussi des
protections des parties génitales
absolument de la tenue et vous avez des
tenues match Charlotte qui sont censés
être renforcés et plus résistant
notamment aux agences incendiaires et
aux attaques notamment des fusées de
détresse même si elles peuvent
transpercer ça a été des équipements qui
sont encore de réflexion maintenant sur
les moyens offensifs pour pouvoir tenir
le terrain et faire face à aux individus
violents on a ce qu'on appelle des
grenades lacrymogènes alors vous avez
différentes grenades vous avez ce qu'on
appelle des MP7 que c'est 7 plots c'est
souvent les poudres sur lesquels les
individus ont l'habitude tirés qui
revient sur d'ailleurs il faudra
réfléchir à ce que lorsqu'on lance des
grenades lacrymogènes les plus exposer
tout de suite est-ce que c'est grenades
lacrymogènes aussi sont plus ou moins
fortes en fonction de la violence de la
manifestation on a deux types de
grenades lacrymogènes dont une les cm17
il y a plus de pendant les Sims il y a
plus de plots qui sont un peu plus forts
mais c'est vrai qu'on constate
qu'aujourd'hui alors il y a une vraie
réflexion aujourd'hui sur les grenades
lacrymogènes puisque vous voyez bien que
si vous avez été sur le terrain comme
vous le disiez tout à l'heure les gens
viennent avec des masques à gaz ou de
plongée ils viennent avec des
équipements de protection c'est du juste
s'ils sont pas aussi protégés que les
policiers sauf que c'est pas lui c'est à
dire qu'il les payent et donc du coup il
y a une un menuisement de l'efficacité
de ces gaz lacrymogènes et on nous a
changé nos grenades de désencerclement
c'est c'est quoi très simplement on
lance une grenade sur un groupe à risque
elle est censée faire disperser par des
petits plots qu'ils explosent et qui
touchent les personnes sans pour autant
les laisser grèvement elle est censée
les faire disperser immédiatement on
nous a changé suite à Rémi Fraisse
notamment cette personne qui avait été
décédée suite à une action de
gendarmerie à Civens on a eu un
changement de nos grenade et les
grenades aujourd'hui sont beaucoup moins
efficaces il faut le dire tous les
policiers me le disent que celles dont
on avait la dotation avant c'est-à-dire
que les individus en connaissent
parfaitement nos techniques et nos
équipements et nos armements l'armement
dont on dispose aujourd'hui les lacrymo
moins opérantes les grenades des
arguments moins efficace il y a une
vraie réflexion sur notre armement à
apporter alors malgré l'équipement lourd
dont dispose les policiers les blessés
sont nombreux dans vos rangs combien de
blessés sont recensés aujourd'hui chez
les gendarmes et et les policiers alors
depuis du but depuis le début de la
manifestation depuis le début du
mouvement contre de plus depuis pardon
le début du mouvement c'est près de 400
on était à 394 mardi midi et depuis
jeudi dernier on est à une centaine
alors je vais vous dire très simplement
jeudi dernier on a un officier d'une
compagnie d'intervention de la
préfecture de police c'est des sortes de
CRS de la préfecture de police qui
appartiennent du coup au ressorts
territorial de Paris et de la petite
couronne en fait il a eu un pavé dans
les dents et la partie il a perdu la
moitié de sa dentition avec la mâchoire
des form samedi vous avez un commissaire
de police à Lille qui a pris des coups
de poing et dont le matériel était
dégradé par l'individu violent qui a été
aussi interpellé mardi après-midi par le
tribunal de Lille mardi vous avez eu ce
CRS de Marseille à Fos-sur-Mer qui a été
opérée à la jambe et qui avait eu la
malléole et l'artère donc c'est à dire
des organes assez importants au niveau
de la jambe qui avait été touché par une
fusée de détresse ensuite vous avez ce
policier aussi à Besançon qui a été
lynché par des délinquants qui
manifestaient qui ensuite ont mené des
violences urbaines et ce policier son
état va un peu mieux mais il a été
transporté d'urgence à l'hôpital et
heureusement on a l'un des deux
agresseurs qui a pris trois ans de
prison ferme vous voyez on a un niveau
de violence qui depuis c'est vrai une
semaine monde crescendo et il faut le
dire aussi peut-être que je prends mes
patins en disant on a une corrélation
entre le degré de violence qui monte et
les décisions politiques qui sont pris
dans le cadre de la réforme des
retraites à savoir le 49-3 jeudi dernier
et malheureusement il faut le dire la
parole du chef de l'État hier n'a pas
contribué à apaiser les esprits et je
vais vous dire beaucoup de policiers et
beaucoup de personnes qu'on a rencontré
nous ont dit que ça mettait feu aux
poudres plutôt que d'apaiser les gens et
en la payer un peu aujourd'hui sur les
manifestations notamment à Paris Fabien
Roussel tout à l'heure le patron du
Parti communiste a appelé cet après-midi
les forces de l'ordre à laisser tomber
la matraque et rejoindre le mouvement
vous lui répondez quoi à Fabien Roussel
je réponds que le jour où on laisse tout
tomber on laisse on abandonne la
République vous savez que dans la
déclaration du droit de l'homme ce sont
nos révolutions de 1789 dans la salle du
Jeu de Paume qui après avoir mené la
révolution place de la Bastille se sont
réunis et ont décidé que dans le peu
d'articles qu'ils ont rédigé mais qui
sont fondamentaux qu'il y avait une
constitution d'une force publique pour
l'intérêt général et non l'intérêt
particulier de ceux à qui elle est
confiée donc ceux qui portent uniforme
aujourd'hui c'est pour permettre que ce
que le révolutionnaire a voulu et ce
qu'on fait tous les 14 juillet ça parle
aux gens parce que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on oublie souvent de
traditions et les symboles qui font
notre République le drapeau comporte sur
nos écussons l'uniforme qu'on abordement
c'est pour protéger la République
c'est-à-dire protéger les gens et les
plus faibles donc je dis à Fabien
Roussel qu'il a d'habitude a toujours et
il faut le dire même si il est classé
plutôt à gauche il y a pas que des gens
qui sont idiots qui sont défavorables
policiers Fabien Roussel qui est classé
à gauche du parti communiste il a pas
oublié finalement que les policiers
étaient des gens du peuple ils étaient
des ouvrez la sécurité ce que vous dites
vous êtes quelqu'un du Popster vous êtes
un citoyen comme moi comme après tout
ceux qui manifestent et c'est vrai que
vous êtes aussi quelque part un peu
touché par la réforme des retraites
est-ce que dans vos rangs aussi on est
un avis sur cette réforme est-ce que
vous n'avez pas envie de manifester
aussi parfois vous savez que c'est ça
qui est terrible c'est qu'il y a des
policiers majoritairement hostiles à la
réforme des retraites à qui on demande
d'assurer leur public et comme ils sont
courageux qui font preuve d'abnégation
ils savent faire la part des choses
entre leurs convictions et la mission
républicaine que la nation leur a confié
on sert pas un gouvernement sert pas une
politique on serre la nation et je pense
que depuis les attentats de Mohamed
Merah de 2012 on a eu 17 policiers
assassinés par des terroristes quand on
voit tous les blessés dont vous avez on
a parlé tout à l'heure 400 en trois mois
on peut quand même louer l'engagement le
professionnalisme et la détermination
des policiers et des gendarmes qui quel
que soit le grade garde la pub public
dans notre pays et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui j'aimais au nom syndicat
un sérieux signal d'alarme l'ultra
gauche est en train de venir une menace
aussi importante que le terrorisme
islamiste pourquoi parce que c'est une
gauche menaces notre paix notre ordre et
nos institutions républicaines certains
parlent de climat insurrectionnels même
parmi des policiers qui s'expriment sous
couvert d'anonymat est-ce que c'est
exagéré de parler de climat
insurrectionnel aujourd'hui en France le
climat insurrectionnel que j'ai connu
c'était le premier lui décembre dans les
villes de France et dans la capitale
avec notamment l'attaque de l'Arc de
Triomphe et toutes les scènes de
violence que vous avez au moment des
ultra jaune vous savez la volonté on en
terminera peut-être là pour que vos gens
comprennent bien c'est que on a une
ultra gauche aujourd'hui qui veut
récupérer chaque mouvement social ça a
été le cas pour la loi sécurité globale
c'était le cas pour les lois travail dès
le premier en 2016 ça a été le cas
maintenant pour la loi contre la réforme
des retraites sur lesquels les gens
manifestent à chaque fois on est une
ultra gauche en chaîne faïence qui
attend qu'une seule chose d'infuser le
venin de la haine de la violence dans
ses cortèges pour faire de ces
manifestants de la chair à canon et de
faire nos policiers et de véritables
victimes et de véritables blessés parce
que la stratégie ultra gauche c'est de
mener une révolution pour renverser nos
institutions et je suis pas excessif
dans mon propos quand vous avez une
ultra gauche qui attaque les casernes de
gendarmerie comme c'est le cas en Isère
quand vous avez une ultra gauche qui
démonte des pylônes de 5g quand vous
avez une trace qui casse des relais
téléphoniques et des relais de
télévision le droit d'informer était
censé dans le démocratie quand vous avez
une ultra gauche qui s'en prend à nos
policiers nos gendarmes quand vous avez
une ultra gauche qui mène des actions
comme à au bassine aux Deux-Sèvres on a
eu 60 gendarmes blessés 61 GBC pardon il
y a un mois et demi on a une trace qui
aujourd'hui est une menace pour notre
pays ça c'est une certitude et pour vous
elle est sous-estimer cette menace elle
est sous-estimée par les autorités
politiques je pense qu'effectivement nos
collègues de la direction générale de la
sécurité intérieure du renseignement
territorial du renseignement de la
préfecture de police de Paris et de la
sous-direction antiterroriste vous voyez
ça fait quand même beaucoup de services
doivent être beaucoup plus mobilisés les
collègues sont prêts ils sont même
volontaires pour le faire mais il faut
qu'il y ait une politique une volonté et
des instructions pour qu'on lui beaucoup
plus contre l'ultra gauche
l'ultra-droite et aussi importante mais
jusqu'à présent pour l'instant celle qui
crée des dégâts dans le domaine public
celle qui attaque nos policiers nos
gendarmes nos institutions c'est bien
ultra gauche et c'est elle qui est à la
manœuvre de tout ça j'entends certains
[Musique]
mince la difficulté pour les joueurs
c'était quoi c'était qu'ils avaient pas
d'éclairage et de luminosité suffisant
pour pouvoir faire face à des véritables
et métiers en face vous savez qu'on a
une ultra gauche qui a des gants qui a
des sites sur lesquels parfois on a des
surveillants et qui s'entraînent
rigoureusement pour faire face à nos
techniques policières à notre équipement
policière à notre armement policier donc
là la luminosité qui baisse c'est
évidemment une difficulté pour nos
forces de l'ordre alors là on a la
chance si je veux dire d'être au cœur de
la capitale on a de l'éclairage public
on a aussi des véhicules qui permettent
d'avoir un éclairage mobile donc là
c'est plutôt gérable mais je pensais
plutôt dans les matchs par exemple pour
les rêves parties ou pour aujourd'hui ce
qu'on appelle les ADD comme par exemple
la ZAD en dessous Notre-Dame-des-Landes
là ça rend le travail plus compliqué
parce que vous avez pas d'éclairage
public vous avez pas des terrains qui
sont propices au manoeuvre des policiers
puisque il y a de la gadoue il y a dans
l'ISMANS il y a pas les routes et puis
le bitume qu'on peut connaître là donc
tout ça ça paraît très très bidon et
gamelle mais ça rentre en compte de
manière majeure pour le travail et les
forces des forces noires sur terre alors
tout à l'heure on a vu effectivement
cette rangée de véhicules de CRS avenue
de l'Opéra et ces véhicules ont avancé
en marchant finalement avec les hommes
qui se trouvaient de part et d'autre de
ces de ces véhicules pour quelles
raisons là ils sont en train d'encercler
la place de l'Opéra Garnier à Paris
comment ça se passe alors d'abord vous
avez chaque section de CRS ou chaque
peloton d'escadrants mobiles qui est
rattaché un véhicule on les voit sur
votre image à droite je sais pas ce que
voter ce facteur d'ailleurs on voit un
gros car derrière alors c'est un peu
comme la RATP on voit un car marqué
police bah en bleu blanc c'est le car on
met tous les interpellés alors on
transporte pas des voyageurs mais on
transporte des interpeller ensuite vous
avez les Irisbus c'est les escadrons
gendarmerie mobile dont les fourgons
sont plus longues se décrs qui
permettent par exemple de tenir des rues
au lieu de mettre par exemple 60
gendarmes avec ces fourgons on peut
tenir une rue et en mettant que des
petits pelotons ça facilite le travail
des forces de l'ordre et ça permet de
garder de la réserve opérationnelle
ensuite sur les fourgons que ça soit CRS
ou genre mobile on ne dit ceci jamais un
équipage de son chauffeur si on a un
parc donc ce qu'on appelle le parc donc
des véhicules qui composent la compagnie
ou la escadron qui est isolé il peut se
faire attaquer et ça aussi c'est une
technique de ceux qui sont aguerris à au
désordre public qui sont les
professionnels du désordre s'ils voient
des véhicules isolés avec simplement un
chauffeur par véhicule ils savent qu'on
allait en contact le policier aura du
mal à se défendre parce qu'il va falloir
qu'il manœuvre avec son véhicule il
pourra pas descendre pour pouvoir se
défendre face à 5 10 15 à 20 individus
rappelez-vous le gendarme Nivelles en 98
à Lens isolé dans son parc avec des
hooligans qui étaient venus s'acharner
sur lui et qui a terminé de
tétraplégique merci beaucoup Mathieu
vallée je rappelle que vous êtes
policiers porte-parole du syndicat SICp
commissaire merci d'avoir été sur ce
plateau il est 19h15 nous sommes
toujours en direct sur Figaro live on
l'a dit la nuit est en train de tomber
la manifestation arrive à son terme et
nous sommes avec Timothée Delam qui se
trouve au cœur de cette fin de
manifestation Timothée j'ai envie de
vous poser cette dernière question quel
bilan aujourd'hui tirez-vous de ce
défiler vous qui avez été au cœur de
l'action du début à la fin
et bien justement Damien ce bilan nous
allons faire avec Amaury Coutances et
perversaire du service actualité du
Figaro alors que la place vous le voyez
sur ces images est en train de se vider
considérablement l'écart de CRS qui ont
remonté toute cette avenue de l'Opéra et
donc les policiers qui s'apprêtent à
vider la place par ce boulevard des
Capucines que vous que vous voyez à
l'instant même sur ces images de Julien
Leclerc Amaury vous avez suivi comme
nous cette cette manifestation
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que ce qui était
assez frappant c'est qu'il y avait
vraiment deux ambiances il y avait le
cortège syndicat avec une manifestation
finalement assez classique et puis un
premier cortège qui s'est formé là avec
des individus beaucoup plus violents oui
effectivement on a pu voir assez tôt
d'ailleurs dans cette manifestation aux
alentours de de 15h30 une manifestation
d'abord très calme qui est partie de la
place de la Bastille et ensuite un
certain nombre de jeunes environ
peut-être un millier de personnes
habillées en noir qui ont cherché très
vite le contact avec les forces de
l'ordre à partir du moment où le cortège
est arrivé aux alentours des Grands
Boulevards les forces de l'ordre on
cherchait à les anglais elle est ramener
devant ce cortège de black block
finalement est arrivé en premier sur la
place de l'Opéra il y a eu de nombreux
charges et contrechages avec les forces
de l'ordre c'est ces personnes là qui
ont été enfermées par les forces de
l'ordre lorsque le cortège syndical est
arrivé ces personnes là étaient encore
ici ce qui fait que le cortège syndical
n'a pas véritablement pu arriver sur la
place de l'Opéra encore maintenant on
peut le voir sur les images de votre GRI
la place de l'Opéra est vide finalement
seule les Black Blocs sont tenues à la
place et les forces de l'ordre sont
aujourd'hui en train de les évacuer
pendant le moment où le début du cortège
syndical est arrivé ça a duré à peu près
une quinzaine de minutes et très vite en
fait les gaz lacrymogènes ont été tirés
par les forces de l'ordre afin de
disperser les gens les chiffres sont en
train de tomber c'est vrai que nous en
tout cas vu de l'intérieur on a
l'impression que on a le sentiment qui
avait quand même vraiment beaucoup de
monde aujourd'hui dans les rues de la
capitale oui honnêtement vraiment
beaucoup de Mons qui est frappant c'est
qu'il y avait surtout beaucoup de
familles de personnes qui sont voilà
venues assez nombreuses qu'en discute
avec elle en fait je pense que c'est ça
qui a retenu aujourd'hui c'est que les
gens n'ont pas envie de se démobiliser
ils ont été très frappés par ce qu'ils
appellent l'attitude méprisante du
président de la République hier dans son
intervention à 13h ils veulent ne pas
céder en tout cas ces personnes là je
pense resteront un peu ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est les personnes
qui ont sont venues au contact des
forces de l'ordre et qui elles nous ont
bien fait comprendre qu'elles seront là
ce soir pour aller au contact avec les
forces de l'ordre et c'est vrai que ça
ça a été assez frappant c'est qu'il y a
des gens qui sont venus ici pour être
violent il y en a qui sont venus pour
être tout à fait manifester totalement
pacifiquement d'autres qui ont fait
preuve d'acte de violence très tôt dans
la journée où il y a vraiment très tôt
je vous le disais vers 15h30 encore une
fois c'est prévisible c'est assez
habituel toujours en tête de cortège il
y a des personnes qui viennent pour
rechercher le contact avec des forces de
l'ordre ce qui était frappant mais comme
on peut le voir encore derrière nous en
ce moment c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des
feux d'artifice qui ont été tirés sur
les forces de l'ordre les forces de
l'ordre ont fait usage de beaucoup
beaucoup de gaz lacrymogènes elles ont
vraiment tenu à ce que la place de
l'Opéra ne soit jamais véritablement
remplie très vite elles ont cherché à
scinder en petits groupes ces groupes de
casseurs on peut voir encore en ce
moment sur la place de l'Opéra juste
derrière nous des canons à eau qui n'ont
pas encore été utilisés malgré de
nombreux jets de projectiles j'ai même
vu moi-même un cocktail Molotov qui
était lancé tout à l'heure on peut
imaginer qu'en tout cas le gouvernement
n'a pas voulu que la place et que la rue
soit aux manifestants et je pense que
pour le moment on peut dire que c'est
une opération réussie voilà une
opération réussie en tous les cas une
place totalement bouclée par les forces
de l'ordre comme vous le voyez avec ici
des cartes de CRS et puis également
c'est c'est gris que vous voyez
notamment ici c'est gris qui sont
destinées à protéger la place Vendôme où
vous le savez le ministère de la Justice
se tient un canon en haut donc vous
parlez Amaury tout à l'heure que vous
voyez par exemple juste ici sur ces
images de Julien Leclerc et la place
donc qui s'est nettement nettement vidé
maintenant et qui devrait continuer de
se vider probablement par ce boulevard
des Capucines d'où un gaz lacrymogène
vient d'être lancé à l'instant même
merci beaucoup Timothée delaime vous
étiez en direct de la manifestation à
part y rester avec nous parce que il est
pas impossible que je revienne vous voir
d'ici les prochaines minutes bonjour
Christophe Cornavin bonjour Damien vous
êtes journaliste au Figaro spécialiste
des questions en lien avec la police
vous avez également aussi suivi cette
manifestation qui s'est déroulée
aujourd'hui dans la capitale comment
s'est-elle fini cette manifestation on a
l'impression qu'il y a on a vu des
scènes de chaos dans Paris avec des
affrontements avec les forces de l'ordre
avec des des pars de feu des voitures
retourner qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en
fait dans Paris il y a eu effectivement
à la différence des précédentes journées
nationales d'action contre la réforme
des retraites on a eu quand même à Paris
qui a été
qui a beaucoup plus souffert que
d'habitude Paris n'a pas brûlé Paris a
résister mais Paris était chahuté et on
le voit bien parce que dès le dès le
début de la manif il y a eu il y a eu
des heures au bout de même pas au bout
d'un quart d'heure 20 minutes après que
le cortège se soit
il est il est encore soumis il est
suspendu à un point d'interrogation
parce que
bah oui bah oui parce qu'en fait ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que là
la manif la manifestation elle n'est pas
finie bien sûr il y a normalement si on
en croit la préfecture de police qui
annonce quand même 119000 participants
à Paris à Paris c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
les services de renseignement apparaît
attendaient entre 50000 et 70 000 ah oui
et là on est à 119 donc on est largement
au-delà de ce que le renseignement
territorial avait prévu on est on est à
deux fois ce qu'avait estimé un peu les
analystes du ministère parce que je
pense que les premières analyses avaient
été faites avant que le Président de la
République ne fasse en allocution et
contrairement à ce que a souhaité
manifestement l'Elysée on peut imaginer
que cette allocution a plutôt été de
nature à remobiliser le front de la
contestation et à remettre des gens dans
la rue et ça
on le voit on le voit de manière tout à
fait claire 119.000 à Paris et plus d'un
million dans les rues de France donc
alors qu'on attendait entre 600 et 800
000 personnes en France bref à Paris il
y a donc 119000 personnes qui sont
actuellement dans la rue et qui voudrait
bien finir de de leur manifestation
parce que le parcours c'était on se le
rappelle c'était Bastille qui a
République et on arrivait il devait
atterrir gentiment
à l'opéra à 19h là il est 19h23
on a vu que en fait les forces de
l'ordre ont eu toutes les peines du
monde à à libérer cette place de l'Opéra
parce que en tête de cortège comme on
l'a vu il y avait entre 1000 et 1500
casseurs alors des spécialistes de la
guérilla urbaine parmi lesquels
évidemment se trouve les Black Blocs qui
venaient de l'étranger nous a dit notre
interlocuteur précédent aussi parce
qu'en fait parce qu'en fait c'est une
espèce d'international de la casse on
les a on l'a vu sur des sur des fronts à
Strasbourg à Gênes dans des sommets de
l'OTAN dans des sommets économiques en
fait c'est c'est une espèce de de grande
de grande communauté de l'ultra gauche
qui peut se donner rendez-vous là où on
peut semer le chaos donc certains ne
savent même pas peut-être qu'il y a une
réforme des retraites en France ah mais
pour être très caricatural il s'en moque
comme d'une parce que il pourrait là ils
auraient pu être pour je sais pas une
manifestation sur
pour aller voir par exemple vous pourrez
voir je pense les gens qui sont dans
cette manifestation là le 25 dans
quelques jours dans les Deux-Sèvres où
il y aura une très très grande
manifestation contre les mégas bassines
de rétention d'eau qu'utilise les
agriculteurs et que et que les
écologistes prennent du doigt comme
étant contraires à la comme une attaque
à une attaque à l'environnement et ben
ces gens-là ils passeront allègrement et
sans sourciller du d'une fronde sociale
à une fronde environnementale et
spontron à côté des échos guerriers pour
eux aussi porter le faire parce que
l'idée c'est pas tant c'est pas tant le
discours qui compte l'idée c'est de
c'est de pouvoir casser des symboles de
l'état des symboles du capitalisme et au
passage si on peut esquinter des
policiers et ben voilà ça c'est ce sera
fait et donc par exemple
on a vu qu'il y a un policier d'ailleurs
qui était blessé absolument vous savez
d'ailleurs si dans quel état de santé il
est actuellement l'image est très
impressionnante on peut la décrire c'est
à dire qu'on voit ce policier qui est en
train de s'activer avec ses collègues et
qui reçoit un projectile sur son casque
et qui tombe au sol on voit qu'il est
inconscient il se fait traîner sur
plusieurs mètres par ses camarades et on
ne sait pas dans quel état il est vous
avez cette information en fait c'est un
policier donc de la compagnie
d'intervention de Paris
et c'est vrai que la la scène est assez
frappante elle est assez
forte dans la mesure où on a vraiment
l'impression que le que le que le que le
que le policier est touché par une balle
par un il est touché par une balle par
un projectile qui touche se casque et
il tombe il tombe au milieu de ses
collègues comme s'il avait été touché
par une balle elle est vraiment
inconscient il tombe et en fait il a été
il a été soigné sur place il est de
nouveau donc la bonne nouvelle c'est que
heureusement ce fonctionnaire là est et
a repris conscience
je pense qu'il a eu une commotion due à
la violence du choc parce que on croit
déceler sur les images une espèce de de
pavé
manifestement quasiment à bout portant
par un par un émeutier parce que l'idée
c'est que
la violence qui est décrite par les
forces de l'ordre ces derniers jours à
leur rencontre et est extrêmement forte
il y avait un le ministre de l'Intérieur
hier il est allé dans une caserne dans
17ème arrondissement on était voir des
policiers blessés il faut savoir que
dans les 5 premiers jours de Manille il
y a eu 94 policiers blessés donc
plusieurs à Paris parmi lesquels figure
au moins un
policier votre gendarme qui a eu la
mâchoire cassée par fracturé par un par
un par une pierre ou par un par un
parpaing ou par un objet en tout cas un
projectile assez lourd et ben c'est
policier blessé ont raconté que ils ont
l'impression d'être face à une violence
qui est presque aussi forte que qu'au
calacé des gilets jaunes au moment où
les gilets jaunes étaient les plus les
plus actifs les plus virulents et alors
il nous racontait que par exemple il y a
des modes opératoires de plus en plus
étonnants par exemple ils ont vu des
notamment des des casseurs des ébutiers
qui balancent des bouteilles de parfum
au bout desquels ils mettent un système
de mise à feu et ça fait comme des
petits cocktails Molotov qui peuvent
exploser en en frappant le policier et
l'idée étant de l'enflammer un peu comme
ça c'est pas ça à Rennes vous savez que
le 11 février dernier il y a un policier
qui a été enflammé à Rennes exactement
alors justement des flammes on envoie
sur vos images actuellement sur Figaro
live c'est manifestement un kiosque qui
est enflamme actuellement Timothée
delaime et sur place les éléments
radicaux apparemment ne sont pas
forcément partie de cette femme
manifestation
oui tout à fait Damien c'est particulier
en fait parce que ce que je vous
décrivais tout à l'heure c'est une place
qui était en train de se vider mais en
réalité il y a une partie du cortège qui
n'était pas véritablement encore arrivé
sur la place de l'Opéra et c'est ça qui
est assez particulier parce que certains
manifestants ont commencé à quitter la
place les policiers qui ont commencé à
évacuer la place mais en réalité la fin
du cortège continue d'arriver par ce
boulevard des EC capucines et donc le
semoir des Italiens pardon et donc voilà
là ce sont certains manifestants qui ont
mis le feu à un kiosque vous le voyez
sur ces sur ces images de Julien Leclerc
et évidemment des scènes de tension qui
en résulte certains semblent d'accord
d'autres pas du tout avec ce qui est en
train de se passer et donc voilà là je
vois certains manifestants qui sont en
train de s'invctiver entre eux en tous
les cas ça n'est pas terminé pour les
scènes de tension ce kiosque qui est
véritablement en feu avec vous
l'imaginez une odeur assez prégnante et
très désagréable et on imagine les les
sapeurs-pompiers qui vont probablement
intervenir d'une minute à l'autre comme
ils l'ont fait à plusieurs reprises cet
après-midi en tout cas un gros
a-troupement autour de de ce kiosque et
à nouveau ce slogan qui retentit dans
les dans les rues de Paris tout le monde
déteste la police merci beaucoup
Timothée delaime en direct du cortège
parisien on voit qu'il y a effectivement
encore beaucoup beaucoup de monde en
autour de vous il est 19h30 nous sommes
toujours en direct sur Le Figaro.fr vous
avez parlé de de ces Black Blocs tout à
l'heure Christophe Cornavin journaliste
au Figaro qui sont-ils qui sont c'est
militants radicaux alors on sait voilà
on l'a dit tout à l'heure qu'ils
viennent de l'étranger est-ce que ce
sont des militants politiques est-ce que
ce sont tout simplement des gens qui
s'ennuient dans leur vie et qui à un
moment donné ont envie de se défouler
qui sont ces personnes alors on n'est
pas on n'est pas dans Fight Club
pas forcément que du que du cadre qui
veut se battre qui veut faire du combat
de rue on est plus véritablement sur des
militants qui sont politisés on les a vu
c'est passé pas d'hier parce qu'en fait
les Black Blocs on pourrait dire que
c'est c'est apparu dans les années 80 à
Berlin on est sur les appelait à
l'époque les schwarzen block donc les
Black Blocs en allemand et après ils ont
essayé à travers l'Europe c'est à dire
que dans il y a une contestation
berlinoise il y a une quarantaine
d'années puis après on les a vu dans des
sommets à Washington on les a vu aussi
hyper 94 on les a vu au sommet de temps
à Strasbourg et tout d'un coup en fait
et après ils ont eu vraiment une grosse
présence pendant les projets de loi la
loi el khomri notamment sur le sur le
sur le travail ou là ils ont donné toute
la mesure de ce qu'il savait faire donc
ils ont beaucoup cassé en fait c'est les
gens qui sont quand même assez
politisés et
dans la grâce de majorité des gens de
d'ultra gauche ce qui est ce qui est
très ce qui est toujours marquant chez
les Black Blocs c'est que donc ce ne
sont pas des ce ne sont pas des
d'ailleurs que vous Damien ou moi je
pourrais pas être black en fait on
utilise une technique de Black Bloc ah
oui que en fait le blackboard c'est une
stratégie de combat c'est une stratégie
pas c'est pas la personne c'est le mode
d'opératoire qui permet de se mettre
qu'il y a eu 1000 Black Blocs
aujourd'hui dans Paris ça ne veut pas
dire grand chose c'est 1000 personnes
qui ont formé un black bloc et le black
bloc en fait c'est ces personnes là se
regroupent sans crier gare en fait ils
font partisans quand même cette espèce
de de culture du secret une espèce
d'activisme à l'ancienne un petit peu et
une dose qui se regroupe via un
rendez-vous via des via des réseaux
sociaux voir des réseaux cryptés et la
police a du mal d'ailleurs à pénétrer à
espionner parce que c'est pas facile et
après ils ont toujours à peu près la
même stratégie se mettre derrière une
barrière noire rigide souvent ou
derrière des parapluies ce qui leur
permet de de passer à l'offensive sans
être véritablement vu et de se protéger
quand la quand la les forces de l'ordre
font des bons offensifs pour essayer de
les de les récupérer et de les
interpeller et une fois qu'ils ont donc
leur mission c'est
se faire de la police
des banques et casser tout ce qui peut
représenter l'état ou le capitalisme et
une fois qu'ils ont fait ça après ils
ont et donc là c'est une stratégie de ce
qu'on appelle de recomposition
perpétuelle c'est-à-dire que en fait le
Black Bloc c'est comme une matière molle
c'est-à-dire que
elle n'est pas elle évolue en fonction
de la situation elle peut se disperser
se vaporiser dans les rues
adjacente si la police tout d'un coup
magnanation et se reformer un peu comme
du mercure une goutte de mercure pour
repartir à l'action et en fait ça c'est
la proposition perpétuelle donc c'est
une vraie technique de guérilla urbaine
et après ils font ce qu'on appelle le
défi étage des silhouetages donc c'est à
dire que
et il se rhabille en fait ils sont ils
sont ils sont en noir et ils se
remettent derrière leur écran et tout
d'un coup il
il y avait des personnes qui n'étaient
pas forcément tout vêtus de noir est-ce
que ces personnes là qui aussi
commettent des exactions dans Paris sont
des Black Blocs non en fait c'est des
gens qui s'agrègent donc à cette
technique de Black Bloc donc là on est
sur l'application purée dur là en fait
sur du casseur purée dur on peut être
sur de l'étudiant qui a décidé de chat
et à la souris avec les forces on peut
être avec sur des gilets jaunes
radicalisés qui ne veulent pas lâcher
l'affaire depuis qu'ils ont occupé des
ronds en 2018 on a une espèce de de de
de de de d'agglomération un peu de gens
qui tous s'expriment leur colère de
nébuleuse quoi de de nébuleuse et
en fait ce qui se passe et pour en avoir
discuté avec un policier encore hier
responsable policier c'est que dans ce
petit jeu en fait qui n'est pas un jeu
parce que parfois les conséquences sont
quand même dramatiques
sont interpellés ce qui compte le et
ceux qui ne sont pas forcément les
meneurs parce que les meneurs eux ils
connaissent les techniques de guerrier
urbaine ils savent se dissimuler quand
ils détecte la police et les attaques de
la police et donc restent entre
guillemets sur le champ de bataille que
les nevisses qui eux se font embarquer
et comprennent pas forcément d'ailleurs
pourquoi on leur pourquoi ils sont ils
sont interpellés parce que il faut leur
expliquer que casser c'est pas bien et
que jeter des projectiles sur les forces
de l'ordre c'est pas bien vous et quand
je dis ça c'est pas forcément une un vue
d'esprit de l'esprit ou une espèce de
pour faire un mot c'est que c'est
vraiment le cas les policiers pour
beaucoup d'interpeller en tout cas ces
derniers jours leur explique
explique que les gens qui sont
interpellés sont un peu étonnés de
conviennent les chercher quoi oui ils
pensaient que c'était ça faisait partie
une forme de protestation comme ça
ferait carrément qu'il y ait presque de
la prévention auprès de ces gens là en
leur disant non ce n'est pas normal de
faudrait une forme de prévention allez
on tourne du côté du terrain avec
Timothée delaime parce que la
manifestation n'est pas terminée et pour
cause une vague de manifestants est en
train de venir vers vous je crois
[Musique]
oui tout à fait Damien vous voyez en
fait la manifestation qui ne se termine
pas parce que comme je vous le disais ce
sont ces manifestants en fait qui ont
fini par arriver sur cette place alors
que les premiers étaient arrivés il y a
déjà plusieurs plusieurs une heure
peut-être deux heures même donc un gros
un gros décalage entre le début du
cortège et la fin du cortège et du coup
là à nouveau une situation fuse ce gant
là le monde déteste la police les
pompiers les sapeurs-pompiers de pareil
qui sont en train d'intervenir de ce
kiosque a été incendié il y a quelques
secondes et vous le voyez d'ailleurs
cette intervention des sapeurs-pompiers
à l'instant même et donc voilà il n'y a
eu comme comme souvent les forces de
l'ordre ont tenté d'intervenir mais pour
disperser la foule qui était avec
glutinée et bien
quelques g de gaz lacrymogène afin de
permettre aux sapeurs-pompiers
d'intervenir et vous voyez cette cette
intervention en direct là avec avec les
sapeurs-pompiers qui voilà qui tente
d'éteindre le feu on vous voyait
également ce sont des des CRS qui est
bien qui sont là pour pour veiller à ce
que le personne ne vienne s'agglutiner
autour
de autour du kiosque et cette odeur
toujours nauséabonde se mélangent de de
cramé et de et de gaz lacrymogène sur
une place qui en fait vient de de se
re-remplir elle s'était considérablement
vidée et elle est de nouveau assez
pleine depuis que une partie du cortège
a fini par arriver et par nous rejoindre
ici
en direct de la Place de l'Opéra Garnier
à Paris une question que je voulais vous
poser Christophe Cornavin est-ce que les
policiers est-ce que la préfecture de
police de Paris n'a pas fait une erreur
d'appréciation au regard de ce que l'on
voit sur ces images est-ce que les
effectifs étaient suffisamment
importants vous nous avez dit tout à
l'heure que le nombre de manifestants
avait été sous-estimé est-ce que si le
nombre de manifestants avait été revu à
la hausse dans ce cas là des effectifs
de police aurait été les effectifs de
police auraient été plus nombreux sur le
terrain en fait
l'estimation donc pas mal comme la
simulation elle avait été faite avant la
locution présidentielle effectivement
on n'a pas eu l'idée que cette que la
marée de colère la déferlande de colère
serait forte même si il savait les
services de renseignement on l'a écrit
d'ailleurs ce matin dans Le Figaro que
on allait partir vers de la colère forte
dans la rue en revanche
il y a quand même 5000 policiers dans la
rue là c'est 5000 policiers c'est énorme
c'est un très très gros dispositif
c'est un dispositif comme on en a vu
pendant les gilets jaunes de les grosses
manifs des gilets jaunes donc c'est pas
tant le c'est pas tant le nombre de
policiers il y a assez de policiers je
pense dans la rue policier gendarme
d'ailleurs dans la rue c'est plus le
l'idée du pour l'instant de de du trajet
mais le parcours en fait c'est pas la
préfecture qui décide du parcours en
fait le parcours c'est le les
organisateurs d'accord qui en parle avec
le préfet de la préfecture qui le valide
qui le valide voilà exactement et en
fait le l'organisateur il dit bah moi je
vais bien par contre la dernière fois on
est parti de République on était à la
nation là on va on va partir de Bastille
on va aller à Opéra et généralement la
préfecture de police dit plutôt ok les
endroits où il tique un petit peu c'est
plutôt rive gauche
ah bah parce que rive gauche il y a il y
a il y a les ministères il y a les
extravail il y a l'Elysée il y a les
institutions il y a là il y a
l'Assemblée nationale il y a le il y a
beaucoup de il y a véritablement les
pôles du pouvoir sont plutôt rive gauche
et
donc et donc c'est plus c'est pas
forcément le meilleur endroit pour pour
accepter les manifestations est-ce que
la stratégie de la police aujourd'hui
était différente de celle qui a été
adoptée lors des dernières mobilisations
dans la capitale parce que aujourd'hui
on a remarqué que les policiers étaient
très visibles alors évidemment il y
avait des débordements assez tôt qui ont
éclaté dans la manifestation mais pour
avoir couvert effectivement ce genre de
mouvement au cours des dernières
semaines on se rendait compte que la
police était invisible sur le parcours
de la manifestation c'était un peu caché
dans des rues parallèles là c'était moi
le cas quand même faut le reconnaître
ouais non mais Damien vous avez
complètement raison en fait les forces
de l'ordre elles sont vraiment
normalement cachés elles ont l'ordre
d'être caché l'ordre de ne pas
apparaître dans le décor vraiment c'est
il faut que il faut qu'il n'y a que du
manifestement dans la rue c'est la
volonté du préfet de police mais et le
fait de police en cela il ne fait que
appliquer une consigne qui vient du min
à l'intérieur qui est qui a été décrite
dans ce qu'on appelle le schéma national
du maintien de l'ordre qui dit un ne pas
apparaître devant les manifestants et en
particulier les casseurs parce que les
casseurs s'énervent et jettent des
projectiles dès qu'ils voient les forces
de l'ordre voilà ce sont des sites c'est
un chiffon rouge si vous retirez le
chiffon rouge tout d'un coup les
casseurs et d'ailleurs pendant très
longtemps ça a été le cas ils savent
plus trop quoi attaquer parce que
les banques généralement sont protégées
sur le parcours les forces de l'ordre
sont en retrait et là il y avait un
service d'ordre des de les retard
syndical qui a été assez conséquent et
donc du coup les casseurs est un peu
démunis parce qu'ils sont tout le temps
là faut pas croire que qu'ils sont
passés à l'action parce que avant ils
étaient pas ils ont tous à chaque
manifestation ils sont là ils attendent
le moment pour passer à l'action là il
pouvait ils ont pas pu le faire jusqu'à
maintenant l'idée c'est que le préfet de
police donc lui il disait on ne met pas
de policiers dans la rue on les voit pas
ils sont dans la rue adjacente parce que
quand on est dans la manif on les voit
pas mais en revanche dans les rues
perpendiculaires ou les rues parallèles
juste derrière là tout d'un coup vous
avez les forces qui sont là avec pour
mission de de dévaler un peu comme comme
la cavalerie dans la vallée après de
dévaler sur les de dévaler sur les
casseurs pour procéder à des
interpellations dans dans les minutes
dans les quelques minutes qui suivent
c'est une prise de risque parce que
parce que le préfet il dit ben il faut
absolument que
que tout d'un coup l'action de casse
s'arrête en quelques minutes c'est à
dire qu'il faut il a très confiance dans
ces hommes et il faut dire que les
forces notamment les pelotons
d'intervention de la de la de la
gendarmerie et aussi les les forces les
forces d'intervention de la des CRS sont
ultra
ultra efficaces surtout quand ils sont
appuyés par ces fameux braves la brigade
de répression de l'action violente
autorisée
brave Mike voilà exactement qui qui sont
là pour vraiment intercepter les
casseurs et ils sont effectivement des
très très rapide même si on remarquera
que ils sont pas omniprésents ce soir
place de place de l'Opéra parce que la
séquence est plus une séquence statique
une guerre de position qu'une guerre de
mouvement en revanche il pourrait
rentrer en piste assez vite dès lors que
les groupuscules un peu radicaux vont
peut-être partir dans des rues
adjacentes et essayer de semer le chaos
comme ça a été le cas au cours des
derniers jours exactement c'est-à-dire
que pour l'instant là on est là vraiment
la volonté c'est je pense de de des
autorités c'est de faire en sorte que la
manifestation arrive enfin son terme là
on est sur un accouchement douloureux
parce qu'on a presque 45 minutes de
retard mais l'idée c'est que les
derniers manifestants puissent rejoindre
la place de l'Opéra et que le contrat
soit rempli le contrat de la respiration
démocratique parce que ces gens-là tous
les tous les gens qui sont les personnes
qui sont hostiles à au mouvement des
retraites
fondamental qui est celui de manifester
et le préfet de police doit s'employer à
ce que ce soit le cas et donc il doit
dégager la place des faire en sorte que
la pâte la place soit dégagée des
casseurs pour pouvoir faire en sorte que
cette manif arrive à enfin à son terme
mais là c'est vrai que on est quand même
dans une situation un peu compliquée et
c'est vrai que pour répondre encore plus
directement à votre question l'arrivée
de la place de l'Opéra quand on avait un
cortège de 100 parce que 120000
personnes on avait on pouvait imaginer
quand même qu'on soit dans un goulot
d'étranglement parce que c'est vrai que
120 000 perds pour qui connaît un tout
petit peu Paris 120.000 personnes
passent de l'Opéra c'est
vraiment beaucoup vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup et donc le lait aurait pu
déborder de la casserole sans problème
et faire en sorte que tout d'un coup
comme on l'a vu un peu place Vauban ou
place de la Concorde ces derniers jours
tout d'un coup euh il y a euh
les manifestants qui qui partent en
cortège dit sauvage dans les rues et qui
reprennent reprennent les les incendies
en série il faut quand même garder en
mémoire que lundi il y a eu 240
incendies dans la nuit 240 incendie et
là c'est plus compliqué pour les forces
de l'ordre d'appréhender ces
manifestants qui effectivement sont
parce que vous avez ce qu'on peut
appeler une vaporisation du mouvement
c'est-à-dire que au lieu d'avoir
simplement une foule à gérer de manière
compacte vous aviez
des des vraiment des des des micros des
micro groupes un peu partout disséminés
dans Paris sur plusieurs arrondissements
dont il fallait anticiper l'action à
chaque fois et donc il fallait que
chaque policier se démultiplie et ça et
en fait certains avaient commencé à 6h
du matin et en fait la manif sous cette
forme là en tout cas s'est arrêté à 2h
du matin c'est à dire qu'ils avaient un
service extrêmement long allez on va
retourner du côté de Paris du côté de la
manifestation parce que des personnes
dont le visage est manifestement masqué
et des personnes aussi vêtues de noir on
a parlé des Black Blocs qui sont
toujours là Timothée delaime est-ce que
quel est l'ambiance exactement autour de
vous on a du mal à se faire une idée là
en regardant ces images
et bien je vous comprends Amiens parce
que c'est vrai que l'ambiance ici est
très particulière vous le voyez beaucoup
de dégâts sur cette sur cette place de
l'Opéra et sur les avenues adjacente par
exemple ce kiosque ici même qui a été
incendié par des individus violents tout
à l'heure celui en face a également été
incendié mais de l'autre de l'autre côté
c'est pour ça que vous ne voyez pas les
dégâts toujours comme tout à l'heure
cette odeur cette odeur de cramer mais
également une odeur très nauséeabonde
d'une odeur d'excrément qui est en train
et bien de se répandre sur sur la place
les manifestants qui ça y est sont tous
arrivés qui sont en train de repartir
vous voyez donc cette ce boulevard des
Italiens c'est ce boulevard même qui a
emprunté tout à l'heure le cortège
lorsque et bien les manifestations sont
arrivés sur la place ça y est ils sont
en train petit à petit d'évacuer les
lieux mais malheureusement cela ne se
fait pas dans le calme puisque vous
entendez toujours ces pétards toujours
ces feux d'artifice dirigés contre les
elle est force de l'ordre et puis cette
odeur cette odeur de gaz lacrymogène là
la sirène que vous entendez c'est une
sirène des sapeurs-pompiers de Paris
parce que c'est vrai qu'ils ont été mis
à contribution à de nombreuses reprises
cet après-midi la situation est en train
de se de se calmer même si on reste
prudent parce que c'est vrai que à
chaque fois qu'on dit que ça se calme
derrière ça reprend là en tous les cas
depuis quelques minutes c'est vrai que
c'est vraiment en train de se calmer les
manifestants sont en train de quitter
les lieux en nombre et vous le voyez
d'ailleurs ce flux continu là de
manifestants qui est en train d'évacuer
la place et qui est en train et bien de
se diriger peut-être vers le métro en
tous les cas voilà la place elle
continue de de s'évacuer peu à peu on
voit là-bas une fumée alors est-ce un
nouveau feu qui a été allumé est-ce des
gaz lacrymogènes on va aller vérifier
tout cela
ouais la manifestation est en train de
se terminer mais on a le sentiment que
pour les forces de l'ordre elle ne fait
que de que commencer cette soirée merci
beaucoup Timothée delann merci d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur Figaro live
et de nous avoir fait vivre cette
manifestation qui s'est déroulée
aujourd'hui à Paris merci aussi à vous
Christophe Cornavin de nous avoir
accompagné pour ce début de soirée de
nous avoir voilà aidé à comprendre un
peu mieux ces images de cette fin de de
manifestation l'édition spéciale en lien
avec la mobilisation contre la réforme
des retraites et ses manifestations que
vous avez suivies et bien c'est terminé
merci à vous de nous avoir suivi durant
toute cette après-midi et même toute
cette journée on vous souhaite une
excellente soirée et à très bientôt sur
Figaro live